très bien mes chers collègues nous
consacrons cette matinée à l'audition
des partenaires sociaux sur le projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour
2023 demander
réforme des retraites toutes les
organisations étaient entendues par nos
rapports mais je souhaitais que nous
conduisions également cet exercice en
réunion plénière nous entendons tout
d'abord les représentants des syndicats
je précise qu'une invitation est envoyée
aux organisations syndicales
représentatives au niveau national et
interprofessionnel la CFTC m'a fait
savoir qu'elle ne pourrait être
représentée et nous entendons ce matin
voilà monsieur beaugasse nous entendons
ce matin monsieur Alexis Jamet
conseiller confédéral non il n'est pas
là
conseiller confédéral Confédération
générale du travail CGT
Ivan ricordo ça c'est bon
secrétaire national responsable de la
politique sur la retraite de la
Confédération française démocratique du
travail
la CFDT
Gérard
Martinez secrétaire général de la
Confédération française d'encadrement
Confédération générale des cadres
CFE-CGC c'est vrai qu'on connaît les
sigles on a parfois oublié le déroulé de
du nom et Michel bogas
secrétaire confédération de l'emploi et
des retraites de force ouvrières et faux
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat
je vais donner la parole à chaque
intervenant afin qu'il expose brièvement
les principales observations de
l'organisation qu'il représente sur ce
texte avant qu'un débat ne s'engage avec
nos rapporteurs
rapporteur général René Paul Savary
rapporteur pour la bronche vieillesse et
Sylvie vermeyer rapporteur pour avis de
la commission des finances puis ensuite
avec nos collègues je vous laisse la
parole alors qui commence de commencer
peut-être on fait comme ça OK
donc ça tombe bien bonjour bonjour à
toutes et à tous merci pour pour cette
discussion c'est très important pour la
CFDT d'avoir un échange avec les
sénatrices les sénateurs à avant
l'ouverture des débats dans dans au
Sénat dans quelques jours c'est d'autant
plus important qu'il y a beaucoup de
commentaires qui s'effectuent sur les
enjeux du débat parlementaire en cours
et que il est important pour notre
organisation d'avoir un débat sur le
fond c'est ce qui importe
pour les pour les travailleurs de ce
pays c'est clairement la nature des
discussions qui ont lieu y compris quand
les discussions se passent dans la rue
au moment où il y a des cortèges
nombreux dans dans la période c'est
vraiment des discussions sur ce qu'est
le monde du travail aujourd'hui que
représente la retraite et ça nous semble
important que dans l'ensemble des
des lieux où se projetent de réforme
doit être débattue qu'il se fasse de la
façon la plus approfondie et la plus
apaisée possible c'est ce qu'on essaye
de conduire en termes de responsabilité
donc c'est c'est de cette façon là qu'on
souhaite échanger pendant deux heures
avec vous ce matin quelques mots de
d'introduction avant d'avoir le
traditionnel échange sur le fond à
partir de de vos de vos prennent
attention prioritaires la CFDT regarde
la situation en face sur la question des
retraites il nous semble qu'il y a trois
paramètres qui sont importants ou trois
enjeux qui sont importants quand on
discute des retraites c'est qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans le monde du travail
dans la période actuelle qui nécessite
qu'on regarde qu'on a juste les éléments
de transition entre la carrière
professionnelle et la période de
retraite et donc il y a des enjeux
particulièrement forts dans la période
actuelle post pandémique qui nécessite
que on a juste la façon dont se situe
les dernières parties d'activité pour
simplement améliorer la question des
transitions il me semble que la question
des transitions professionnelles y
compris dans la dernière partie de
carrière et un élément qui qui bouge et
qui a beaucoup bougé y compris au moment
de la crise sanitaire le deuxième
élément qu'on regarde en face c'est que
le système de retraite porte en lui-même
en son sein de nombreuses inégalités et
que pour nous il est important pour y
répondre de avoir un élément de
refondation du système de retraite on a
beaucoup travaillé on s'est beaucoup
investi sur la façon dont il y avait des
améliorations trouvées dans le système
de retraite et que ces améliorations là
passeraient à terme c'est sans doute le
sens de l'histoire de l'évolution de la
production sociale de notre pays par un
système au moins de base universelle qui
permettent de donner les mêmes droits à
l'ensemble des travailleurs quel que
soit leur situation leur parcours
professionnel ou l'origine
professionnelle nous sommes que cet
élément fondateur qui a été débattu il y
a trois ans dans notre pays sera
l'élément d'avenir de construction et de
renforcement de notre système
répartition et le troisième paramètre
qu'on regarde en face et la question de
l'équilibre financier qui est tout sauf
un tabou pour la CFDT parce que c'est le
premier élément de confiance dans un
système par répartition quand on veut
avoir de la confiance entre les
générations il faut faire la
démonstration que le système est à
l'équilibre à terme et donc on sait
toujours investi dans de nombreuses
réformes des retraites pour faire en
sorte de garantir cette pérennité
financière là et on regarde cette
question avec avec beaucoup de lucidité
dans la période actuelle donc si la
question est est-ce qu'il faut un
rendez-vous retraite alors
en janvier février mars 2023 ou courant
2023 peu importe la réponse pour la CFDT
est plutôt positive donc c'est le
premier élément de de positionnement de
notre organisation le deuxième élément
c'est que contrairement à des moments de
réforme sur le système de retraite qu'on
a connu dans notre pays depuis 20 ans on
n'est pas dans une situation dramatique
et c'est ce qui doit justement la nature
des échanges et la nature des
ajustements à faire pour nous on a et
donc on regarde avec beaucoup de
lucidité c'est ce que je dis c'est ce
que j'ai dit on a
un besoin d'équilibre financier aux
alentours d'une dizaine de milliards
d'euros dans dans la période à venir
c'est les chiffres alors on va pas on
discutera tout à l'heure sans doute des
des analyses des projections qui ont été
effectuées mais si on regarde cette cet
horizon là on peut convenir je pense de
façon assez raisonnable que le système
de retraite au niveau financier nous dit
deux choses c'est qu'il y a un
déséquilibre qu'il faut corriger car
rien à voir avec les déséquilibres qui
ont été corrigés aux réformes
précédentes et donc du coup quand on
regarde ce qui était les projections et
les débats sur la réforme 2014 2010-2003
il y a absolument aucune
cohérence en termes de besoins
financiers par rapport à ses précédents
rendez-vous là ce d'autant plus que ces
rendez-vous là donnaient des pers à long
terme qui était des perspectives en
chute libre des perspectives dégradées
alors que aujourd'hui s'il y a un débat
sur l'horizon court terme de l'équilibre
financier je pense qu'il y a très peu de
débats pour dire que il y a une
perspective à long terme en chute libre
personne n'a dit ça dans le débat
retraite et donc du coup il est hors de
question pour la CFDT de dramatiser cet
élément-là d'autant plus que plus le
débat avancé depuis le début de la
concertation l'automne plus les experts
se sont prononcés pour dire trois choses
c'est que ce déséquilibre là il existe
il est pas dramatique que la question de
la projection sur le système de retraite
des éléments qui avaient été donné sur
la fonction publique son sujet à caution
et que les démographes de plus en plus
disent que la question de l'espérance de
vie fait aussi partie des éléments
correctifs à terme sur ce qui avait été
travaillé jusqu'à maintenant donc du
coup ces éléments là la CFDT je vous ai
dit regardez le rendez-vous avec
lucidité regarde ce rendez-vous sans
aucune dramatisation et on a on n'est
jamais tombé dans le débat
dramatisation financière donc du coup
l'enjeu pour nous et comment répartit
l'effort puisqu'il y a des éléments qui
sont qui sont à travailler dans
l'évolution du système de retraite et il
est hors de question pour la sfdt de
faire répartir les efforts uniquement
sur les travailleurs
de tout temps quand on a fait évoluer le
système de retraite on l'a fait évoluer
avec une répartition entre ce que les
entreprises contribuent à l'évolution du
système de retraite est-ce que les
travailleurs contribuent sur sur
leur cotisation on a un projet de loi
qui fait répartir les efforts uniquement
sur les salariés donc on a un élément de
difficulté selon nous de cet ordre là et
le deuxième élément c'est que la seule
d'État a toujours été opposée au
décalage d'un paramètre sur les
différents paramètres qui existent qui
est le paramètre de l'âge parce que en
décalant ce paramètre là on fait
reporter l'effort uniquement sur une
partie des salariés et sur les salariés
qui sont les salariés les plus modestes
alors contrairement à d'autres réformes
qui ont vu des décalage de l'âge les
salariés les plus modestes ceux des
premiers des cils en termes de
rémunération sont eux épargnés de la
réforme parce que c'est des salariés qui
bénéficient la retraite à 67 ans et
comme il n'y a pas de décalage de la
décote du coup cet amortisseur là
continue à fonctionner donc il y a pas
de mieux mais il y a pas de pierre pour
les premiers des cils par contre pour
l'ensemble des cils au dessus du
troisième des cils jusqu'au 9 et 10e là
par contre la facture elle est lourde et
donc la CFDT est opposée au fait que ça
soit notamment les classes moyennes et
les travers de la deuxième ligne qui
payent l'ensemble de la facture de la
réforme des retraites ce qui est le
projet qui nous est présenté aujourd'hui
en faisant le choix de décaler l'âge de
62 à 64 ans donc en conclusion
cette affaire là méritait que yait un
rendez-vous dans notre pays qui soit le
rendez-vous du comme on travaille mieux
et dans le nom qui nécessitait d'aborder
la question par la question du travail
parce que peut pas faire appel FS et
encore moins un peu les fesses
rectificatif donc fallait aborder la
question par le travail aborder la
question par les questions d'emploi et
de pleine emploi et d'emploi des seniors
et dans ce cadre-là posez la question de
l'évolution du système de retraite y
compris de la durée d'activité c'était
ça le système vertueux qui permettait de
poser les bases d'un débat
approfondi sur l'évolution de notre
système de protection sociale on est
aujourd'hui dans un rendez-vous qui est
un rendez-vous d'ajustement financier
dans un cadre un bel FSS et on le voit à
travers le débat et la nuit en est la
démonstration flagrante c'est que du
coup on a un débat qui réduit à comment
on envoie un ajustement financier et
comment dans cet ajustement financier là
on trouve quelques amortisseurs et la
mauvaise nouvelle de cette nuit c'est
que l'enjeu essentiel qui était de faire
en sorte que l'emploi des seniors soit
quand même un peu la clé de voûte de
cette affaire là à terme ben on voit que
l'ambition qui était déjà pas très
élevée permettez-moi de le dire comme ça
et retomber à son plus bas niveau et que
ça augure d'un continuation des débats
et qui va être particulièrement
difficile sur ce terrain là qui nous
semble être pourtant le terrain
prioritaire voilà sur les propos
liminaires de la CFDT je rentre pas dans
les éléments précis qu'on a débattu dans
le cadre de la concertation je pense
qu'on y reviendra dans le cadre des
échanges juste après merci de votre
attention
bonjour à vous et au nom de la CGT à mon
tour on vous remercie de ce moment
d'échange et d'écoute du coup des
organisations syndicales puisque vous
avez devant vous les représentants de
l'ensemble de fêtes des organisations
syndicales qui toutes vous explique leur
opposition à ce projet de loi antisocial
pour les travailleuses et travailleurs
nous rappelons que le principal argument
du gouvernement après avoir tenté quand
même de faire croire qu'il était de
justice sociale et finalement devenu
l'équilibre financier que là aussi pour
nous comme le vient de le dire mon
collègue repose sur de faux constats
tout d'abord bon pour nous il n'y a pas
de problème pour financer le système de
retraite par répartition parce que comme
les organisations syndicales vous
l'expliquent même monsieur Brun
le président du corps a déclaré que les
dépenses de retraite ne dérapent pas ce
qui pose problème
au gouvernement je le cite c'est ce que
dit le président du corps c'est que ce
sont les dépenses qui ne sont pas
compatibles avec les objectifs de
politique économique et de finances
publiques du gouvernement il est donc
clair pour la CGT comme pour tous les
syndicats et j'insiste l'écrasante
majorité de la population aujourd'hui
que l'objectif de cette réforme des
retraites et de faire payer aux
travailleurs les aides publiques et
autres allégement successifs de
cotisations sociales que la majorité
présidentielle défend en fait cette
réforme comme ça vient d'être dit aussi
elle veut imposer d'énormes recules
sociaux pour des résultats budgétaires
extrêmement faibles et non nécessaire
nous insistons aussi sur ces deux sujets
aujourd'hui les arrangements si je puis
dire avec la réalité du gouvernement
relève quasi de l'irrespect vis-à-vis
des salariés cela fait plusieurs
semaines que la CGT les autres
organisations syndicales alertent par
exemple sur la proposition présentée
comme une mesure de social les fameux
1200 euros c'est d'ailleurs à la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée nationale que nous avons
aussi alerté et questionner les députés
de la majorité sur ces 1200 euros aucune
réponse de pluie l'augmentation du
niveau des pensions des plus modestes à
1200 euros n'est que pour une carrière
complète et attend complet cela ne va
finalement concerner que très peu de
retraités la plupart des travailleurs en
carrière complète à temps plein étant
déjà au-dessus et les millions de
travailleurs au SMIC ont le plus souvent
une carrière hachée ou à temps partiel
et ignorant donc pas droit deuxième
élément l'allongement du temps de
travail affaiblira encore les pensions
contrairement à ce qui peut être affirmé
par les ministres notamment aujourd'hui
40% des femmes et 32% des hommes partent
en retraite avec une carrière incomplète
car il ou elle ont connu des périodes de
maladies ou de chômage et trop souvent
très souvent sont les mêmes qui nous
licencie avant 60 ans qui veulent nous
faire travailler jusqu'à 64 ans reculé
encore l'âge de départ à la retraite
c'est rendre toujours plus difficile la
validation d'une carrière complète et
qui dit carrière incomplète dit pension
incomplète pour ceux qui malgré tout
parviendront à bénéficier d'une carrière
complète même l'étude d'impact réalisée
par le gouvernement évalue entre 0,3 et
1,5 % les augmentations de pension
conséquence de l'allongement de la durée
de travail à qui veut-on faire croire
que c'est un progrès le rapport
de le report pardon de l'âge légal de 62
à 64 ans est inacceptable allongez l'âge
de départ ce n'est pas connaître la
réalité du travail et c'est l'un élément
fondamental cela va impacter l'ensemble
des salariés du public comme du privé à
un âge où la pénibilité liée au travail
et partagée par tous et toutes que l'on
soit infirmière ou j'allerte par exemple
sur le taux d'accident du travail
supérieur à celui du BTP c'est dire ou
même au cadre où la pression travail et
le développement massif des risques
psychosociaux qui induits l'exemple le
plus frappant ce sont les troubles
musculo-squelettiques première maladie
professionnelle en France plus de 44000
cas en 2019 touchant autant les
personnels soignants les métiers de la
logistique les employés sur les chaînes
de production et autres préparateurs de
commande cela va impacter en priorité
les salaires
avec des carrières les salariés avec des
carrières les plus hachées et les
salariés les plus modestes à chaque fois
que l'on modifie l'âge de départ en
retraite on pénalise d'ailleurs
notamment profondément les femmes à
chaque fois que l'on repousse la durée
de cotisation requise on la rend
toujours moins atteignable notamment
pour les femmes notamment par l'absence
de politique ambitieuse d'égalité
homme-femme et lié au temps de autant
partielle subis en 2020 26% des femmes
salariées à temps partiel le son pour
s'occuper de leurs enfants ou d'une
personne dépendante allongez encore la
durée de cotisation creuserait donc
encore le fossé des inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes quant aux carrière
longue alors qu'aujourd'hui les
travailleurs et travailleuses peuvent
partir à 60 ans il et elle travailleront
de longues années de plus avec cette
réforme pire il et elle devront cotiser
jusqu'à 43 ou 44 ans puisque il y a une
nouvelle annonce vous avez vu hier de
Madame la première
mais on ne sait pas si c'est un nouveau
une annonce ou d'un énième effet de
communication pour faire diversion enfin
reporter l'âge de départ à retraite ces
reportés le paiement des pensions de
retraite sur les autres prestations
sociales partir plus vieux c'est partir
en plus mauvaise santé avec recours plus
souvent aux arrêts maladie plus exposées
aux invalidités et c'est aussi je vous
alerte si je puis me permettre sur le
sujet
moindre retraités en bonne santé pour
les activités bénévoles pour la
solidarité pour ce qui fait liant dans
la société pour celles et ceux qui
s'occupent des procédants etc vous le
connaissez cela nous insistons aussi sur
ce sujet c'est la même chose avec les
travailleuses et les travailleurs dites
seniors à 60 ans vous le savez aussi un
actif aujourd'hui sur de seulement et
ton corps en activité parfois seulement
à temps partiel l'augmentation du nombre
d'annuités à valider en lien avec le
report de l'âge de départ à la retraite
entraînera donc un allongement de que ça
de précarité et une baisse massive du
nombre de travailleurs et travailleuses
en capacité d'atteindre une carrière
complète la prise en compte de la digue
pénibilité et de notre point de vue
scandaleuse et bien évidemment pas à la
hauteur perte de 2 ans pour les
personnes ayant commencé entre 18 et 20
ans et éligible dispositif carrière
longue le gouvernement nous parle de
pénibilité après avoir retiré quatre
critères lors du passage du C3P au C2P
en 2017 et sont les mêmes qui toujours
en 2017 ont supprimé les chcct comité
d'hygiène et de sécurité des conditions
de travail avec les ordonnances dites
Macron l'attaque contre les régimes
spéciaux qui sont les régimes qui
prennent le plus en compte la pénibilité
la pénibilité au travail les régimes
pionniers dit spéciaux va d'ailleurs à
rebours complet de la reconnaissance de
la pénibilité dans ces secteurs
nous accélération nous
assistons à une accélération de la
réforme Touraine couplée à la réforme
proposée par le gouvernement borne qui
va entraîner un raccourcissement de la
durée espérée passer à la retraite c'est
la seule réforme qui joue à la fois sur
la légale de départ et sur le nombre
d'annuités cotisées les seules variables
que souhaitent finalement le patronat
jamais ne sont discutés l'augmentation
des salaires des cotisations sociales
l'égalité homme-femme la taxation des
produits des grands groupes les profits
des grands groupes c'est pourtant ce que
demande aujourd'hui les salariés qui
produisent les richesses de ce pays
pour finir
l'urgence de la population c'est
d'augmenter les salaires et pas de
reculer l'âge de départ à la retraite la
population vous le dit par million à
travers des sondages des pétitions des
grèves des manifestations y compris avec
la participation de certains petits
patrons qui comprennent bien qu'on ne
peut pas faire travailler les salariés
jusqu'à 64 ans l'heure est au retrait du
projet il y a tellement d'autres sujets
importants à traiter nous insistons les
citoyens regarderont attentivement le
vote de chaque parlementaire répondait
positivement à leurs attentes
répondez positivement à leurs attentes
on est là pour échanger et alerter
mais s'il vous plaît on se calme on se
calme on débat on se calme on n'est pas
on n'est pas dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale s'il vous plaît
donc on se calme
on se calme on se calme on se calme et
maintenant la parole est Hakim monsieur
Boga
oui merci voilà
il y a eu le petit effet je peux je vais
je vais attendre
on est là pour débattre effectivement et
donc si vous nous avez si vous nous avez
invité
côté déplacer de la remarque mais
néanmoins nous continuons le débat
non
moi je trouve que jeté à la vanille
populaire les parlementaires quel que
soit le choix de leur vote ne fait pas
partie du débat démocratique point donc
mais jamais chacun le verra chacun
pourra le voir mais ce n'est pas c'est
une forme de menace je persiste et signe
mais néanmoins nous continuons le débat
je vous remercie voilà mais tout le
monde sait tout ce que tout le monde
vote donc il y a pas besoin voilà donc
c'est bon voilà Michel bogasse
de me couper mon électricité ou de
menacer ma famille ou m'envoyer des
mails et des lettres de menaces au
parlementaire c'est inadmissible voilà
ce n'est pas le sujet mais il y en a qui
qui poursuivent dans cette voie donc je
tiens voilà donc monsieur Bocasse vous
allez la parole
voilà merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs merci d'avoir
organisé cette cette rencontre où
effectivement les organisations
syndicales et
vous allez l'entendre partage un certain
nombre de constats sur le projet de loi
qui est qui est proposé le premier des
constats c'est que effectivement il y a
pas d'urgence à réformer le système de
retraite tel qu'il est et il y a surtout
pas d'urgence à ne faire que un seul
paramètre c'est-à-dire reculer l'âge de
départ à la retraite pour l'ensemble des
salariés de ce pays c'est-à-dire de
passer de 62 ans à 64 ans tout en
parallèle en accélérant ce qu'on a
l'habitude de dire la réforme Touraine
qui en fait touchera les gens
dès 1900
la génération
1966 au lieu de la génération 19
2013 notre opposition à ce projet est
basé en fait sur les constats que soit
il n'y a pas d'urgence mais que la
première des préoccupations et ça a été
dit par une des organisations c'est
d'abord l'emploi
nous avons fait des propositions
gouvernement en matière d'emploi
notamment en matière d'emploi des
seniors et il nous semble aujourd'hui
que le gouvernement prend les choses à
l'envers on aurait dû d'abord traiter
les problématiques d'emploi des seniors
des études économiques démontrent que
d'augmenter de 10 points le taux
d'emploi des seniors rapporte 50
milliards et quand on oppose les 50
milliards ou 10 milliards projetés je
rappelle bien projeté parce que ce ne
sont que des projections du corps et
donc ce n'est pas la réalité il y a 5
ans le corps prévoyait 2021-2022
déficitaires alors que il est
excellentaire sur l'ensemble des régimes
de retraite d'accord quand on prend
l'ensemble donc ce ne sont que des
projections et il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
à
s'alarmer tel que le fait le
gouvernement
travaillons d'abord sur une loi qui
protège les salariés de ce pays pour que
les entreprises arrêtent de licencier à
partir de 50 ans les seniors et les
laisser et les laisser comme ça au
chômage et au chômage pour de nombreuses
années puisqu'on sait que quand un
travailleur senior et au chômage il
reste le plus longtemps c'est lui qui
reste le plus longtemps et on trouve les
seniors dans les demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée
l'autre cas c'est effectivement il y a
une étude du CNAM qui vient de sortir au
mois de février qui fait la
démonstration que lors du passage de 60
à 62 ans on a vu chez les seniors une
augmentation des arrêts maladie ça veut
dire que faire travailler les gens plus
longtemps c'est un transfert vers
d'autres pièces sociales c'est un
transfert vers les maladies vers la
sécurité sociale c'est un transfert vert
la caisse de chômage c'est un transfert
vert et vous qui représentez les
territoires vers en fait les minimas
sociaux voilà c'est simplement juste un
transfert et c'est un transfert pour
plus d'un tiers des économies prévues il
faut bien l'avoir en tête et que donc
pour nous il suffit d'abord de
travailler sur les questions d'emploi de
faire en sorte que les entreprises et
c'est pas avec un index que les gens que
les entreprises conserveront les seniors
c'est avec des contraintes je rappelle
que l'index égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes sur de salaire on constate
encore aujourd'hui en moyenne 20% des
quarts de salaire et c'est 20% là
si les salaires des femmes étaient
égales aux salaires des hommes il n'y
aurait pas de problématiques il n'y
aurait pas de problématiques de recettes
dans les caisses de retraite voilà c'est
ça qu'il faut faire c'est d'abord ça et
c'est bien ça qu'il faut mettre qu'il
faut mettre en avant aujourd'hui
c'est animé ce matin
et donc
les problématiques là sont les
principales problématiques et donc c'est
bien des questions d'emploi de
conditions de travail et de salaire qui
font qu'aujourd'hui et bien il y a moins
de recettes parce que c'est c'est pas un
problème de dépenses les retraites c'est
écrit dans les tous les rapports du
corps c'est un problème de recettes
d'abord c'est d'abord un problème de
recettes etc c'est un manque de
cotisation
et ces cotisations bien évidemment et
bien il faudra regarder d'un autre côté
toutes les exonérations qui ont été
faites aux entreprises
Force Ouvrière porte le fait que toutes
les exonérations toutes les aides aux
entreprises doivent être conditionnées
conditionnés à l'égalité salariale entre
les hommes et les femmes et les femmes
et les hommes conditionnés au maintien
des salariés en emploi qu'ils soient
jeunes ou seniors d'ailleurs et une fois
qu'on aura conditionné les aides qu'on
n'y pas il y a des entreprises qui ont
besoin des aides mais je suis pas sûr
que les entreprises du CAC 40 on est
vraiment besoin quand on voit les
profits qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont aujourd'hui
engrangés donc nous aurons
nous avons alors je pense qu'il y aura
un débat mais nous avons donné le
gouvernement des dettes enfin des
documents iti sur l'emploi des seniors
sur comment préserver l'emploi des
seniors sur l'égalité salariale
également
par exemple nous avons fait une
proposition
et bien que les aides soient aussi
conditionnées dans le cas du temps
partiel subi pour les femmes 89% du
temps partiel en France est subit et il
est subi par les par les femmes je suis
je suis syndicaliste et je viens de la
grande distribution et bien croyez moi
une hôtesse de caisse à la pas le choix
on lui demande pas de travailler à temps
plein on lui impose un contrat de
travail à temps partiel et c'est ça
qu'il faut et c'est là où il y a une
difficulté ensuite à la retraite entre
les femmes et les hommes la différence
elle est là et c'est tout ça qu'il faut
changer avant de penser à reculer l'âge
de départ voilà je me tiens à votre
disposition ensuite pour débattre avec
vous de ce que nous pouvons proposer
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
bonjour à toutes et à tous alors je vais
adapter un peu mon propos à ce qui est
déjà été dit par mes collègues afin de
ne pas être trop long mais c'est je
précise parce que tout le monde se lève
pour voir la pancarte
secrétaire général et d'ailleurs je
voudrais ce titre vu qu'on avait été
reçu par Monsieur Savary madame douano
et une autre collègue qui est ici il y a
quelques semaines j'avais communiqué des
éléments écrits au secrétariat de la
commission je sais pas si ça a circulé
mais je vais m'appuyer là-dessus pour
mon propos avant je voudrais juste
souligner que on a été très déçu de la
concertation avec le gouvernement où il
y a eu très peu d'écoute à l'automne ou
finalement on sentait qu'on était déjà
sur une réforme dogmatique et je me
disais bah dans le projet de loi qui va
être soumis et en particulier les
éléments assimilables à une étude
d'impact on va trouver des choses et la
grosse déception vu que sur un certain
nombre de choses alors je prendrai en
particulier l'article 2 sur l'emploi des
seniors alors qu'on est dans un projet
de loi
rectificatif certes mais de financement
de la sécurité sociale il y a un certain
nombre de cases qui sont prévus à
renseigner au niveau de la CNAM au
niveau des autres caisses d'assurance
maladie et moi si je prends sur l'emploi
des seniors donc il se limite à un
emploi seniors un index senior et ben
rien n'est mis sur les conséquences que
ça pourrait avoir sur les arrêts maladie
qui se multiplient comme la souligné
Michel Boga etc et donc cette étude
d'impact est vraiment enfin j'imagine
que vous représentant de la nation et
parlementaire vous l'avez décelé comme
ça mais c'est une
enfin je veux dire c'est inadmissible
d'avoir aussi peu d'éléments
justificatifs à une réforme comme ça bon
je vais vous dire que de mon côté j'ai
pris quelques contacts avec des juristes
constitutionnels qui
mon soufflet qui avait des démarches à
entreprendre sur ce sujet donc
voilà on voit aucune
impact sur l'assurance chômage sur
l'assurance maladie sur la caisse
accident du travail maladie
professionnelle qui va être très
concerné et si on prend l'article 7
alors on voit le comme seul l'impact qui
est listé c'est les amandes qui seraient
éventuellement enfin les pénalités qui
sera éventuellement infligées si
l'indique l'index au senior n'était pas
publié par un pourcentage donné
d'entreprise donc si vous voulez
ça fait un peu léger quand même comme
conséquence etc sur l'article 7 pareil
il y a des éléments incohérents vu que
on voit bien qu'il est justifié
l'augmentation de l'âge à partir de
statistiques d'augmentation d'espérance
de vie de 99 à 2019 alors qu'on sait
bien que
Céline c'est qui le montrent l'espérance
de vie n'augmente malheureusement plus
depuis
2014 donc ça fait 8 ans et que
l'évolution 99 à
2012-2013 bah elle a été prise en compte
dans la loi Touraine et elle s'est
traduit déjà par une augmentation de la
durée de cotisation donc si vous voulez
il y a des arguments qu'on peut
qualifier de bidon qu'on qualifie comme
ça dans la presse et qui est aussi
interpelle un certain nombre de juristes
et qui fait que c'est je pense la
représentation nationale devrait
s'émouvoir de d'aussi peu enfin de
justification ou de leur
degré de validité
bon un certain nombre de gens qui ont
pignon sur rue moi je parlerai d'un pas
de Monsieur bras mais de Hervé le bras
qui a un expert démographe de l'Institut
national démographique à lui-même
mentionné qu'effectivement les
hypothèses d'espérance de vie qui est
d'évolution d'espérance de vie n'était
pas réaliste et donc à un moment donné
on espère tous qu'à un moment donné il y
aura des facteurs qui feront qu'elle
repartira à la hausse mais attendons de
constater qu'elle reparte à la hausse
pour
justifier encore des projections à la
hausse pour justifier l'âge de départ
l'augmentation de l'âge de départ alors
après nous ce qu'on a fait parce que
devant ce manque
d'éléments du gouvernement et bien on a
fait nos propres chiffrages parce qu'il
y avait dans le rapport du corps des
coefficients de sensibilité etc et comme
les projections d'équilibre financier
sont l'argument majeurs qui est pris par
le gouvernement pour justifier ce report
de l'âge et ben on a fait nos propres
chiffrages et finalement quand on
considère un scénario espérance de vie
constante et ben là où la première
ministre disait alors je reprends une
référence un article du Parisien du 2
décembre mais disait il y a 100
milliards d'euros de déficit dans les 10
ans qui viennent et bien
un chiffrage espérance de vie constante
montre que c'est 47 milliards d'euros de
sur les 10 ans qui viennent de
alors essentiellement de dépens en moins
là mais de positivité sur lesquelles
financiers de notre régime de retraite
on a également considéré l'emploi des
seniors parce que finalement quand vous
regardez dans le poids des seniors
aucune conséquence financière n'avait
été né chiffrée dans le l'impact du
projet de loi ce qui corrobore l'idée
que l'index senior était une mesure
bidon finalement vu que le gouvernement
n'a même pas chiffré d'impact sur
l'emploi des seniors bah nous on a fait
nos évaluations et si on améliorait
comme l'ont d'ailleurs chiffré aussi des
gens Hervé Lorenzi par exemple et
certains de ses collègues
et bien on arrive à montrer que c'est
plus de 40 milliards d'euros aussi sur
les 10 ans qui viennent donc vous voyez
en gros si on avait un emploi des
seniors amélioré mais amélioré dans la
tranche d'âge 57 à 62 63 ans pas en
allant faire travailler les gens à 64 65
66 ou 67 ans pour ceux que
l'augmentation de l'âge de départ
forcera à faire et bien on aurait déjà
un système qui par rapport au scénario
central du corps qui est pris en
référence serait à l'équilibre sur les
10 ans qui viennent alors qu'on est
encore dans une période où il y a un
effet du Peppy boom on sait que le
pépi-boumjou mais pour ça les régimes
qui sont bien gérés qui sont ceux des
salariés de privés et un grand nombre de
régimes spéciaux mais ils ont 180
milliards d'euros de réserve pour faire
face à cette bosse et sa personne n'en
parle dans les études d'impact or
ces réserves qui ont été constituées
l'ont été en grande partie pour faire
face à la projection démographique liée
au Peppy boom et donc ça faut quand même
la voir en tête quand on parle
d'équilibre d'équilibre financier
ensuite et bien on en vient au partage
de la valeur parce que on voit que le
partage de la valeur mes collègues dans
évoqués
on a vu encore les chiffres récents des
dividendes et des rafales d'actions
effectués en 2022 par les groupes du CAC
40 80 milliards d'euros et bien sûr on
revenait un partage de la valeur plus
équilibrée et on n'a pas fait des des
calculs irréalistes on a dit il faut
revenir alors que la part
des salariés à diminuer de 5% du PIB
dans les 25 ans passés nous on a dit on
revient on rééquilibre on gagne 2% dans
les 10 ans qui viennent progressivement
du fait d'une loi qui pourrait être
votée d'ici fin 2023 et qui rentrerait
en effet en 2025 par exemple et qui
serait associé une meilleure gouvernance
des entreprises qui iraient de père avec
une
plus d'investissement donc plus de
création d'emplois
ce qui serait homogène d'ailleurs et
cohérent avec les discours du
gouvernementaux de réindustrialisation
de souveraineté économiques etc et donc
qui permettrait sans problème de ramener
plus de 100 milliards d'euros dans à nos
régimes de retraite dans les 10 ans qui
viennent et qui montrent que notre
système de retraite avec tous ces
éléments et bien ils permettent
clairement de financer les mesures de
solidarité qui ont évoqué mes collègues
et sur lesquels je ne reviendrai pas les
petites retraites etc donc on voit bien
qu'il y a un gros problème sociétal un
système de retraite on voit bien le
poids financier qu'il a et les impacts
qu'il a sur la vie des gens c'est un
sujet sociétal et le traité en quelques
semaines de débat parlementaires
sur dans le cas d'un projet de loi de
finance et bien c'est vraiment très
réducteur donc nous voilà notre position
il n'y a pas de problème financier et
encore une fois les justificatifs amenés
par le gouvernement sont vraiment
fallacieux pour vis-à-vis des
parlementaires et vis-à-vis de l'opinion
qui elle-même a bien compris parce que
nous aussi on fait de la pédagogie là où
le gouvernement fait de la communication
et des tiens des éléments de langage et
bien nos concitoyens ont bien compris
les éléments et qu'on les emmenait dans
une impasse et on fait confiance à la
représentation nationale pour ne pas
voter ce projet de loi après je pourrais
revenir en détail sur un certain nombre
d'autres éléments
très bien merci à vous quatre tout de
suite la parole à Elisabeth Doisneau
rapporteur général
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
commencer par vous remercier on a eu
l'occasion effectivement déjà de vous
rencontrer alors peut-être pas tous mais
en tout cas je crois que voilà on a bien
des occasions et je pense qu'il faut en
dehors d'un projet comme celui-ci d'un
projet de réforme il faut se voir
régulièrement moi je regrette tout
simplement que finalement parce que
votre engagement il est important parce
que
il permet à l'ensemble des personnes que
vous représentez de mieux comprendre les
réformes mais comme les avancées
sociales ou comme peut-être ce que vous
pouvez qualifier de retour en arrière
mais en tout cas vous vous avez cette
vocation de de pédagogie et puis de
réflexion et moi je voudrais vous
remercier parce que je trouve qu'en
France les syndicats sont pas
suffisamment représentés alors là en ce
moment on voit qu'il y a un regain
d'adhésion dans vos dans vos syndicats
mais je pense qu'il faut tenir l'affaire
il faut tenir la faire parce que si vous
voulez avancer sur
comme l'égalité entre mes femmes en
termes de salaire si vous voulez avancer
sur le travail des seniors si vous
voulez avancer sur le temps partiel tous
ces sujets mais que nous aussi
nous essayons de de comprendre parce que
ce sont des des phénomènes certainement
qui sont encouragés par notre système et
donc il faut réfléchir à le corriger
mais on ne peut pas non plus le faire
sans vous et moi je le dis j'ai j'ai
vraiment ce respect pour votre travail
mais surtout j'ai du respect dans le
sens où il faut effectivement que vous
soyez plus fort au sein des entreprises
plus fortes pas seulement au moment où
justement il y a une réforme des
retraites et moi je suis pour ce comment
cet échange mais régulier et en dehors
de de ces moments de crispation parce
qu'on en arriverait pas aux mots qui ont
été tenus tout à l'heure moi j'ai pas
été élu pour qu'on me dise quoi faire en
fait j'ai un parcours vous avez le vôtre
nous avons donc des angles
d'appréciation différents mais quand je
vous écoute quand je vous reçois dans ma
permanence dans mon département et bien
je me mets à l'écoute comme vous vous le
faites vis-à-vis des salariés que vous
rencontrez et je crois que c'est
important que vous compreniez que en
tout cas moi je me sens pas dans une
seringue et que je ne veux pas l'être ni
par les uns ni par les autres
je pense qu'il faut simplement du
respect nos enfants nous regardent nos
petits-enfants nous regarderons je pense
qu'on laisse une mémoire collective une
mémoire collective et bien en fait à
l'Assemblée comme ici mais comme dans la
rue et bien il faut que ça s'entretienne
donc le respect le respect parce qu'il
encourage la confiance voilà pour ces
quelques mots et c'est pas une leçon que
je donne c'est ma propre leçon de vie
que je partage
après ça je voudrais vous dire que on a
eu l'occasion de nous autres rapporteurs
de vous poser des questions donc c'est
vrai que j'ai plutôt envie de laisser la
main à tous ceux qui n'étaient pas là
lors des auditions vous dire simplement
qu'on est quand même d'accord sur le
constat le constat c'est de dire que le
système est durablement en déficit
pourquoi comme vous l'avez dit c'est pas
les dépenses et d'ailleurs voilà les
expressions du corps ont permis de bien
comprendre entre ce qu'ils ont dit à
maman ce qu'ils ont rectifié à un autre
moment en termes de compréhension parce
que c'est vrai que vous l'avez dit les
éléments de langage ils sont d'un côté
comme de l'autre je dirais que chacun
profite un petit peu des slogans qui
peut afficher donc ce qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de faire nous c'est comment
dirais-je
de dire les choses factuellement telles
qu'elles sont après chacun voilà avec sa
curiosité personnelle parce que je pense
qu'il faut que chaque citoyen aussi ce
document personnellement il est
important que
on ne se fige pas sur un seul son de
cloche donc pour vous dire que oui il
est durement en difficulté parce que
c'est effectivement les recettes qui
vont manquer puisque moi d'actifs pour
des retraités c'est vraiment l'équation
qui va se poser à nous et donc comment
comment on peut
faire en sorte de de répondre à cette
difficulté parce que tous les autres
pays je dirais à peu près européen mais
de notre catégorie ont quand même avancé
l'âge de départ à la retraite après avec
des systèmes qui sont un peu différents
moi j'entendais monsieur ricordo parler
d'un système
je sais pas comment vous le qualifiez à
point ou un peu de capitalisation je
sais pas j'aurais voulu avoir plus à
point j'aurais voulu avoir plus
d'éléments par rapport oui mais en même
temps en même temps il faut être très
très précis là-dessus parce que à point
sont capables d'avoir des points en
quelle CIR et avec quel niveau de
salaire ça c'est aussi pour moi quelque
chose qui peut être un peu inversant une
égalitaire enfin il s'agit pas de faire
l'égalité mais il s'agit d'être juste or
aujourd'hui les Français souvent ah bah
c'est ils se compare au voisin tiens il
a pas travaillé il a pas cotisé pour que
leur une retraite c'est souvent voilà
c'est simpliste mais c'est ce qu'on
entend donc c'est ce qu'on nous on
essaie d'expliquer bon donc voilà moi
j'ai seulement ce petit cette petite
question à vous poser par rapport à vos
propos j'aimerais que vous les que vous
comment expliquer monsieur ricordo ce
que vous envisagez dans ce cette
retraite à point peut-être que vos
autres collègues sont pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vous d'ailleurs
oui on a déjà eu l'occasion d'échanger
donc j'ai pas de question plus
particulières c'est vrai que chacun fait
des propositions qui sont différentes
l'aide conditionné des entreprises de FO
j'ai travaillé dessus vous proposiez
également les primes pour l'emploi des
seniors s'intéressant la CFDT je suis en
train d'analyser les propositions
ouvertes vous avez des avis dévergence
et tout à fait normal et tous les
systèmes de toute façon on va pas
pouvoir compenser les inégalités qu'il y
a au niveau du travail or là notre épure
c'est la retraite quelque chose de très
notre notre feuille de route c'est est
vachement limitée
une réforme paramétrique donc elle peut
pas tout gommer
vous vous dites le système par point et
la CGT dit carrière hachée pension
hachée carrière incomplète pension
incomplète mais par point c'est encore
pire par point c'est encore pire
c'est encore pire que le système
paranuité donc vous voyez bien que de
toute façon quelque soit les systèmes
contenus de la complexité des inégalités
du travail
le système de retraite on va essayer de
gommer un petit peu ces inégalités mais
il y a les inégalités entre régime qui
apparaissent quand on parle que de
retraite 8 trimestres pour le privé deux
trimestres pour la fonction publique en
ce qui concerne les maternités donc on
voit bien que là aussi ces inégalités
c'est pas comme ça en claquant les
doigts qu'on va bon
quel que soit ce qu'on lit on voit bien
que on a un temps passé à la retraite
qui est plutôt fait identique à celui
qu'on connaissait il y a des dizaines
d'années avec une natalité qui diminue
donc mathématiquement il est bien on
voit bien que me semble-t-il le constat
qu'on peut faire c'est que le système ne
s'équilibre pas voilà après en ce qui
concerne effectivement les façons d'y
répondre elles sont forcément
différentes si on revient à notre épure
bon on va pas d'histoire d'âge entre
nous
simplement il faut bien
constater quand même et je pense que là
vous le remettez pas en cause les 43 ans
de durée de carrière
c'est pas ce qui est proposé par ce
gouvernement c'était proposé par le
gouvernement d'avant donc c'est 43 ans
d'activités il faut bien les prendre en
compte après il y a le facteur là
effectivement qui mais c'est 43 ans
d'activité pour bien prendre en compte
donc je vais essayer de rester dans la
réflexion simplement sur cet état de
fait que la loi actuelle même si ça
accélère on se projette dans l'avenir
c'est quand même 43 ans d'activité donc
après ça nous interpelle par rapport à
la longueur des carrières c'est un grand
sujet d'actualité
carrière longue
carrière longue ça veut dire par rapport
à la carrière normale qui sera de 43 ans
au-dessus de 43 ans quoi
non
mais bien d'accord 43 ans c'est une
carrière normale c'est pour ça que il
faut trouver des dispositifs alors votre
avis par rapport à ça et une fois qu'on
a des 43 ans il y a effectivement une
usure professionnelle ce qui est que
personne ne peut effectivement contester
c'est tout à fait normal donc nous on
essaye modestement par rapport à ce qui
nous est proposé de voir comment on peut
adoucir ces mesures de façon à prendre
en compte vos préoccupations qui sont
les notes aussi en ce qui concerne
l'usure professionnelle c'est la raison
pour laquelle on envisage de de rester
par exemple un certain nombre de
dispositifs à droit constant quand vous
avez des dispositifs actuellement qui
qui sont par exemple incapacité
permanente qui est on pourrait laisser à
l'âge actuel c'est deux ans avant l'âge
de départ on pourrait rester au droit
actuel par exemple est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est une façon quand même de
prendre en compte l'usure
professionnelle il y aurait pas
d'amélioration mais il y aura pas
d'aggravation c'est déjà peut-être une
avancée
en ce qui concerne la retraite
progressive c'est pareil c'est
semble-t-il un moyen intéressant pour
faire une phase intermédiaire
quand on voit la durée moyenne de vie
maintenant au-delà de 85 ans vous avez
une je parle en masse une vingtaine
d'années pour l'éducation la formation
vous avez 22 à 25 ans de de retraite et
de retraite pas pour une génération pour
deux générations bien souvent quand on
rencontre les personnes très âgées et
qu'on leur parle de retraite elle dit
mais mes enfants sont déjà en retraite
d'accord un enfant deux personnes en
retraite et puis il y a l'actif voilà
commençons en train de s'organiser
progressivement avec le vieillissement
de la population et ça c'est un constat
qui est incontournable donc il y a plus
qu'un actif donc et il va falloir qu'ils
travaillent effectivement un petit peu
plus longtemps cette activité alors la
retraite progressive peut être
intéressante parce que je pense
maintenant que dans un parcours
de
vie je parle en moyenne il y aura la
partie éducation la partie de vie active
et une partie intermédiaire une partie
intermédiaire qui sera incontournable de
quelques années qui sera cette
transition c'est pour ça qu'il faut
trouver
derrière un accompagnement de l'emploi
de ces personnes expérimentées ou
seniors de façon à apprendre et vous
avez des propositions qui me semblent
intéressantes souvent qui ont peut-être
on peut reprendre là cette partie
intermédiaire faut qu'on travaille là
dessus parce que ça ça peut nous
rassembler sinon le reste ça va nous
diviser mais il faut y travailler sur
cette partie alors est-ce que la
retraite progressive laissée à 60 ans
comme aujourd'hui est une solution moi
ça me paraît une solution plutôt que de
la décaler à 62 ans vous voyez quel est
votre avis là-dessus et puis chacun une
proposition
par rapport à cette
cette vie de seniors intermédiaire
dont on pourrait s'en parler
une seule parce qu'on va pas diffuser
mais une seule proposition vous voyez
pour construire quelque chose
Sylvie vermeyer on en aura fini avec les
rapporteurs on vous laissera répondre et
ensuite on passera aux questions des
collègues Sylvie Vermeillet pour la
commission des finances merci madame la
Présidente et merci messieurs pour votre
présentation votre exposé juste quelques
questions
concernant tout d'abord
alors
tantôt il y a pas de déséquilibre
parfois il y en a un mais il est pas
dramatique
pas très grave en tout cas à corriger
monsieur ricordo vous parlez
éventuellement d'un besoin de 10
milliards vous avez vous avez pas été
plus précis sur les moyens de le
corriger est-ce que c'est simplement
l'emploi senior est-ce que vous pourriez
revenir sur votre votre manière de
remédier à
ce déséquilibre et puis de façon par
contre un peu Générale vous êtes un peu
tous revenus sur
l'espérance de vie alors parfois vous
vous appuyez sur les travaux du corps et
parfois c'est le contraire vous
contestez ce que le corps a pu dire sur
la progression de l'espérance de vie
donc est-ce que vous pourriez repréciser
ce que vous pensez être juste dans la
projection de l'espérance de vie et puis
juste une question pour Monsieur le
représentant de la CGT
concernant la disparition de certains
régimes spéciaux
si je prends l'exemple de la RATP
avec une pension moyenne de 2800 euros
actuel
comment est-ce que vous expliquez que
pour ceux qui peuvent partir à 52 ans
5000 sur les il y a 5000 aujourd'hui
contractuels qui en étant parti à 52 ans
recontactualise avec la RATP pour faire
le même travail est-ce que vous
considérez qu'on est dans une situation
de pénibilité dans ce cas là
alors voilà qui qui commence à répondre
on prend le même ordre monsieur rigordon
c'est Monsieur Vacheron
merci je vais je vais essayer de
répondre aux différentes problématiques
qui ont été posées de façon assez
synthétique je l'espère la première
c'est par rapport à l'intervention de
sénatrice d'oiseaux sur au début de
votre propos
j'apprécie beaucoup votre soutien
syndical tel que vous l'avez exprimé je
non non mais sans enfin de façon très
franche et directe comme vous l'avez
fait et je pense que dans la façon
effectivement de travailler les
éléphants les éléments de réforme de
notre pays quel que soit l'enjeu si ce
protection sociale si c'est travail si
c'est parcours professionnel peu importe
la question de du renforcement du
dialogue social et un élément clé nous
semble-t-il sur lequel
enfin on fait beaucoup de benchmark
européens sur les questions de réforme
le dossier de retraite est l'exemple
type du benchmark européen
regardons comment les éléments de
protection sociale ont été construits et
ceux qui sont mis en exergue comment ils
donnent la part en terme de
responsabilité aux différents acteurs
notamment aux acteurs sociaux et la
question du poids des organisations
syndicales et des organisations
employeur vous allez voir après nous
sommes essentiels de ce point de vue là
et y compris pour ne pas trop prolonger
y compris dans cette réforme il y a des
voies à trouver pour renforcer les
éléments de dialogue social ce qu'on
fait comme proposition sur la question
de l'emploi des seniors c'est des
éléments de renforcement du dialogue
social entre nous on n'a pas beaucoup
d'espoir parce que ça fait partie des
éléments de désaccord qui ont provoqué
le rejet de l'index senior à l'Assemblée
et même sans être un grand analyse de ce
qui se passe au Parlement et nous semble
que dans l'équilibre politique qui est
en train de se construire les éléments
de renforcement du dialogue social ont
quand même pas beaucoup de voix d'avenir
sur ce projet de réforme malheureusement
je le dis en toute responsabilité parce
que on ne coûtera pas sur ces questions
névralgiques d'emploi du seigneur de
qualité de carrière si on ne renforce
pas le dialogue social et le chemin qui
est pris à l'Assemblée nationale depuis
hier soir et le chemin inverse à cette
affaire là donc je c'est pour ça que je
le disais de façon très très direct par
rapport à votre propos initial je
développe pas beaucoup parce que
malheureusement la question du
rendez-vous sur comment on peut refonder
de façon un peu plus fondamentale notre
système de retraite ne semble pas être
complètement l'horizon des quelques
semaines qu'ils ont devant nous donc de
ce point-là je vais pas être très très
long cela étant dit un système à points
peut être un système de renforcement de
notre système par répartition il y a une
belle démonstration qui est faite dans
notre pays historiquement c'est il nous
semble que dans les systèmes qui sont
très bien gérés il y a le système de
retraite complémentaires des salariés du
privé agir Arco qui est solide qui est
tenu financièrement et sur lesquels on
peut s'appuyer pour trouver des éléments
de construction à l'avenir et du coup
y compris dans des systèmes à points on
peut trouver des éléments de solidarité
qui permettent de trouver des correctifs
tels que les propos ont été apportés
donc voilà je rentre pas plus
précisément mais
ce qu'on veut dire par là c'est que le
débat actuel en fait la démonstration si
on veut corriger les questions
d'inégalités femmes hommes si on veut
corriger fondamentalement d'aller au
bout de ces logiques là si on veut
corriger une des plus principales
injustices qui est le fait que quand on
est poli pensionné à chaque fois qu'on
change de régime à chaque fois on a une
diminution de calculs de la pension si
on veut quelques y compris sur la
question du minimum de pension si on
veut
avancer fondamentalement sur ces
questions là autrement que en mettant
des rustines on ne pourra le faire que
dans une base de refondation de notre
système de retraite ça ne passera pas
autrement il y a il y a eu trop de
réformes qui ont trop sédimenté la façon
dont les doigts ont droit ont été
construits que désormais quand vous
bougez un curseur vous faites des
partager et des inconvénients et donc du
coup c'est ces éléments là qu'on est en
perspective donc voilà c'est pas c'est
pas le rendez-vous malheureusement qui
nous est proposé cette fois là puisque
le choix était fait de faire un
demi-tour à 180 degrés par rapport à ces
éléments d'avenir sur l'usure
professionnelle
il y aura pas d'amélioration sur l'usure
professionnelle je
pourrais même modérer un peu votre
propos monsieur Savary c'est sur la
question de l'usure professionnelle il y
a des éléments qui
correspondent à des demandes de la CFDT
c'est l'amélioration du C2P actuel
compte de prévention de la pénibilité
c'est il y a actuellement il y a des
éléments qui sont sur l'abaissement des
seuils qui sont plutôt positifs sur la
question de la prévention on met en
perspective des éléments qui sont plutôt
intéressants le problème c'est que il y
a pas d'amélioration sur la question de
la réparation de l'usure professionnelle
c'est ça le désaccord fondamental de la
CFDT sur ce projet de loi il faut
attendre que le salarié soit cassé avant
de
non de prévention de prévention les
éléments de prévention sur les critères
ergonomiques et tout commence à arriver
et donc ça va mettre ça va mettre en
place des politiques au sein des
branches qui sont des politiques
d'avenir et la question de la prévention
semble avoir un effet levier dans ce
projet de loi la question c'est la
réparation la question c'est parce que
du coup faut sortir des statistiques sur
ces éléments là c'est quand vous quand
vous travaillez dans une menuiserie que
vous passez votre carrière à prendre des
ventouses pour porter les les éléments
vitrés quand vous quand vous êtes
peintre en bâtiment que vous portez les
sauts de peinture et que vous êtes
systématiquement sur des postures
pénibles ces salariés là c'est salariés
là le projet de réforme il leur dit soit
vous avez un taux d'incapacité auquel
cas vous pouvez partir
deux ans avant les autres mais que à 62
ans quand même que à 72 ans quand même
c'est-à-dire comme aujourd'hui comme
aujourd'hui par contre tous ceux qui ne
sont pas cassés au moment de leur
carrière professionnelle on leur dit
mais vous allez jusqu'à 64 ans
et pour ces salariés là c'est juste
inenvisageable c'est ça le problème de
l'usure professionnelle donc et du coup
si nous si on a une proposition à faire
sur ce thème là la question c'est il
faut que sur les salariés qui sont
exposés aux trois critères
ergonomiques que tout le monde connaît
par cœur maintenant sur ces trois
critères ergonomiques là par des charges
lourdes ne vibrations mécanique et
posture pénible il faut qu'il bénéficie
d'un droit à la retraite anticipée en
fonction de critères et de seuil qui
auront été définis par les branches
professionnelles et ce système là il est
tout à fait possible à mettre en place
de façon très simple on nous avait
objecté une usine à gaz on a fait des
propositions dans le cas de la
concertation qui
sur lequel on arrive à résoudre les
problèmes originaux qui étaient posés
donc aujourd'hui il y a plus de
problèmes de construction il y a juste
une problème de décision et on sait que
ça bloque uniquement au niveau de la
décision et donc c'est ça qu'on veut
obtenir sur la retraite progressive on
est complètement d'accord avec votre
propos c'est il faut renforcer tous les
dispositifs qui permettent de baisser
l'intensité au travail dans la première
partie de carrière c'est comme ça qu'on
montera la qualité de l'emploi dans
carrière je crois qu'on est assez voisin
dans la façon dont vous avez posé la
problématique je suis désolé je suis
désolé ce qui est en train de se monter
en termes de parce que c'est comme ça
que les choses vont se faire ou alors on
n'a pas complètement compris le film
le débat à l'Assemblée nationale montre
que le consensus politique va se faire
sur quelques éléments fondamentaux et
dans les aliments fondamentaux sur
lesquels le consensus politique va se
faire partielle bien sûr c'est le fait
de ne rien faire sur l'emploi des
seniors c'est ça qui est en train de se
mettre en place et donc du coup
l'inverse de l'échange qu'on a ce matin
sur lequel il faut absolument mettre le
paquet pour soutenir la question de la
qualité de l'emploi du seigneurs c'est
ça qui est la voix de passage sur la
forme des retraites et le consensus
politique est en train de se monter et
dont on a eu la démonstration cette nuit
je suis pas en train d'instrumentaliser
le vote de cette nuit la trajectoire qui
est en train de se mettre en place c'est
de vider de sa substance le peu qui a
déjà dans le projet de loi et donc du
coup on va l'inverse de la pro qui faut
poser sur l'avenir du système de
retraite j'ai presque fini je réponds
juste ah non j'ai lutte pas une question
parce que je pense qu'il faut un débat
de franc et direct sur cette question là
et même en sachant que c'est retransmis
la CFDT ça fait 20 ans ça fait 20 ans
que la sève d'été dit il y a une
augmentation de la durée de vie dans le
pays cette augmentation de la durée de
vie il faut la répartir entre la
carrière et la retraite et donc du coup
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait le choix
depuis 20 ans de la durée de cotisation
et donc la CFDT elle n'a jamais remis en
cause cette affaire là et elle ne remet
pas en cause y compris sur le
rendez-vous 2023 la question de la
réforme Touraine à 43 ans de cotisation
on a un propos qui est très clair
là-dessus je suis sur sur les
perspectives financières en fait j'ai
accès mon propos sur le fait qu'il y ait
un déséquilibre la question de comment
rétablit l'équilibre et très voisin de
ce qui a été dit justement par par mes
voisins c'est-à-dire c'est la question
des recettes qui est posée sur ce
rendez-vous là la question des recettes
nécessite qu'on affine vraiment quand
même ce qui a été construit dans la
perspective de l'équilibre financier
c'est pour ça qu'on insiste lourdement
quand même la perspective de l'emploi
public tel que les choses ont été
calibrées dans le projet de loi nous
sommes quand même être un élément de
confrontation qu'il faut avoir dans des
balles quoi est-ce que oui ou non on est
dans la perspective de baisser de 10% la
masse salariale la fonction publique
dans notre pays si oui dites comment
donc parce que ça pèse lourdement sur
l'évolution de du financement cette
affaire là donc voilà donc ce débat là
il est pas posé dans les termes que je
viens de le poser la question de la
démographie est posée la question de
l'emploi la qualité de l'emploi et de
l'emploi du Seigneur est posée
très bien monsieur Vacheron merci de
leur donner la parole comme a priori et
c'est pour ça que les échanges sont
extrêmement nécessaires se connaître et
changer se rencontrer c'est se
comprendre et c'est comme les monts ont
un sens évidemment
les menaces n'ont pas lieu d'être c'est
une évidence par contre les alertes sont
insistantes et non pas la CGT mais
l'entièreté des organisations syndicales
transmet un comiqué que j'imagine vous
avez lu de près le 7 février qui est
indiqué et qu'un invité le gouvernement
allait parlementaire à ne pas être sourd
à cette mobilisation puissante puisque
neuf travailleurs sur 10 rejettent cette
réforme et notamment sur un élément qui
est extrêmement fort pour nous une
démocratie qui fonctionne se doit être à
l'écoute de la position largement
majoritaire de la population qui
s'oppose à cette réforme et à ce titre
nous rappelions toutes et tous ensemble
tous syndicat confondus que lors de
l'examen des projets de loi qui passera
à l'Assemblée au Sénat
[Musique]
qui a indiqué solennellement par un
rapport la discrimination syndicale que
ça induisait ce qui participait à la
syndicalisme et qu'il faisait reculer et
qui nous a toutes et tous conduit vous
le savez ici comment ça à raisonner
autour de cette assemblée deux années de
gilets jaunes qui parce que nous n'avons
plus de possibilités de droit pour
défendre les nôtres au quotidien pas sur
les retraites mais le quotidien notre
syndicalisme c'est d'aider d'accompagner
nos collègues de travail au boulot c'est
pas dans le feu des projecteurs c'est
pas dans la rue c'est au quotidien des
centaines de milliers de syndicalistes
quel que soit l'étiquette qu'ils le font
quand ceci est à Moinerie on a pu voir
au chapitre et du coup c'est d'autres
sans nous sans représentation qui
partent et sortent dans la rue et vous
l'avez entendu et nous nous souhaiterons
pas que ça se reproduise pourquoi nous
disons cela vous voyez bien quand la
population est aussi massivement opposée
les alertes sont extrêmement fortes et
importantes à ce sujet deuxième élément
sur ce qui a été dit parce que pour nous
c'est extrêmement important
la France est le deuxième pays au monde
on est champion du monde numéro 2 on est
en finale de la richesse produite par
salarié on est le deuxième chacun que
nous travaillons et la deuxième heure la
plus productive au monde une la première
européenne et à ce titre là à titre là
ça nous induit un deuxième élément c'est
ou par les richesses qui sont créées mon
collègue a vous inviter en disant la
part dans les richesses produites la
part qui va aux salariés par rapport à
celle qui va à ceux qui détiennent les
entreprises et ben elles font et du coup
la conséquence de ça c'est des salaires
à Moinerie et des petites retraites
troisième élément très important parce
que c'est un sujet nous sommes en France
et vous êtes les représentants de la
République donc des citoyens etc on a
cette chance incroyable d'être le seul
pays au monde où nous n'avons quasiment
plus de retraités pauvre et pourquoi
nous n'avons plus de roter très pauvre
ces gars grâce à notre système de
répartition solidaire mis en place par
le Conseil National de la Résistance ou
tout est tous je le sais ici nous y
sommes très attachés pourquoi j'insiste
sur le sujet c'est parce que nous sommes
l'exception française c'est celle qui
protège c'est celle qui défend c'est
celle qui compte vos citoyens
concitoyens viennent vous voir comme
vous me le disiez dans vos dans vos
permanences vous alertes sur les risques
sur l'avenir sur parce que ils sont
conscients de la chance et des du droit
qu'il y a dans ce pays qui n'est pas un
petit sujet et j'insiste sur le fait
dont je comprends sur lequel vous y êtes
très attaché
sur la réforme elle-même les
déséquilibres on est unanime sur le
constat mais unanime parce que il y a du
travail sur le sujet le corps indique
qui peut vous
annonce un déficit dans quelques années
de 12 milliards d'euros 12 milliards
d'euros 12 milliards d'euros par rapport
aux pensions qui sont versées chaque
année ces 3% du déficit vous savez les
déficits des ménages incomparables avec
le déficit des retraites et tout autre
le déficit de de l'État est différent le
déficit des entreprises privées et
gigantesques 3% de déficits dans
quelques années
u égard
aux autres déficites que je viens de
citer c'est pour cette raison que comme
le corps comme le président du corps pas
simplement un de ces mondes sans
minimiser ce que ce qu'il est elles sont
indiquent qu'il n'y a pas d'alerte sur
le sujet ce n'est ni la CGT ni les
organisations syndicales c'est un
constat partagé par contre nous ne
balayons pas ce déficit nous considérons
qu'il faut trouver des solutions parce
qu'à chaque problème trouver une
solution c'est ça organiser la société
comme nous le partageons ici première
élément ça a été dit très fortement
travaillé à l'égalité homme-femme femme
quant aujourd'hui encore sous un fumeux
index il y a encore 27% de salaire
inférieur pour les femmes que pour les
hommes
entendez entendez que il y a ce sujet
est à travailler et pourquoi il est à
travailler pas simplement pour
l'inégalité subie mais pour les 5,5
milliards ça rapporterait 5,5 milliards
c'est pas la CGT qui le dit la cnavl a
dit etc deuxième élément puisqu'il faut
résoudre les questions des déficits
prévus
je note quand même que le déficit 2020
n'a pas été de celui-ci le déficit 2021
encore moins le déficit 2022 il est
bénéficiaire en milliards notre régime
celui pour lequel nous sommes ici assis
à réfléchir à débattre parce que c'est
extrêmement important plusieurs
milliards de bénéfices en 2022 alors que
les prévisions étaient déficitaires ce
n'est pas grave ce qui est important
c'est de se concentrer au cas où parce
qu'il faut protéger et gouverner c'est
anticiper et ben augmenter les salaires
augmenter les cotisations sociales c'est
un élément fondamental qui participe à
rehausser le niveau des retraites et
rehausser le niveau des cotisations pas
beaucoup on demande un peu
revalorisation du SMIC pour vivre
dignement décemment revalorisation
un projet de loi qui est porté en
demande qui n'y est que dès lors que le
SMIC augmente lié à l'inflation il y a
une indexation de tous les minima de
branches
sur juste l'inflation pas pour gagner
plus pour ne pas gagner moins ça aussi
ça amène du salaire et donc de la
cotisation sociale enfin avec un une
symbolique augmentation des cotisations
sociales d'une poignée d'euros pour
quelqu'un qui est au SMIC pour les
cotisations dites patronales et
salariales non seulement on est à
l'équilibre mais on peut enfin avoir
quelque chose qui pour nous est
fondamental aucune pension en dessous du
SMIC quand on travaille on a le SMIC
pour travailler pourquoi quand on aurait
retraité on n'y aurait plus droit c'est
une question extrêmement importante et
pour terminer sur le financement il y a
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
d'exonération de cotisations sociales si
vous ne partagez pas une partie des
éléments que je viens de proposer
j'aimerais savoir lesquels mais c'est un
débat et c'est pour ça que nous sommes
ici pourquoi ne pas conditionner à ceux
qui ne respectent pas qui désemploie les
seniors qui nous lissent aussi avant 60
ans on peut vous faire des listes par
milliers de salariés qui le subissent
dans lever des exonérations de
cotisation puisque c'est une proposition
que vous souhaitiez à ceux qui ne
respectent pas au moins c'est qu'il
critère là on demande pas plus on
demande les au-delà des paroles et des
éléments de communication la mise en
application pour terminer puisque nous
nous étions rencontrés il me semble que
votre appréciation exacte que j'avais
noté monsieur Savary quand on s'était
rencontré c'est que la manière dont a
été mise en oeuvre cette loi est les
deux effets cumulatifs
de Ross de l'âge de possibilité de
départ cumuler à une accélération de la
loi dit de Touraine qui c'est pas juste
43 ans aujourd'hui ce qui est ce qui
devait être appliqué en 2035 nous sommes
en 2023 puisque c'est enregistré ce
serait appliqué accélérer
pour les générations nés après 73
c'est donc il y a bien un effet
cumulatif d'une accélération du nombre
de côtes d'années de cotisations parle
bien d'années de travail pas de chiffres
les années les plus pénibles sont celles
de notre fin de travail les années les
meilleures à la retraite sont celles des
premières années de retraite pour autant
les deux effets cumulatifs me semblait
que votre appréciation s'en surtout
déformer vos propos était ne vous
emballez pas formule poli dernier
élément
pour l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales c'est ni 63 ni 64 en 62 ans
c'est déjà trop vous avez évoqué la
question des carrières longues écoutez
la moitié des actifs aujourd'hui ne sont
plus au travail à 60 ans la moitié il
faut bien solutionner ce qui avant nous
licencie enfin ceux qui nous licencie
avant pour pour pouvoir avancer si on
travaille pas ces questions là d'égalité
femme de carrière longue de
licenciement de maladies de RSA parce
qu'il faut c'est le sas de précarité qui
augmente c'est les retraités et dans vos
circonscriptions dans vos permanences
vous devez rencontrer j'imagine des
citoyens dans cet élément qui est en
train de de décrire
vraiment et dernière puisque là c'était
une question précise je réponds réponse
précise sur ces régimes pionniers les
régimes les plus protecteurs il y a
l'élément que vous avancez je le partage
je suis au Sénat je vous alerte une fois
de plus quand des caisses sont
excédentaires comme c'est le cas des
énergéticiens par exemple parce qu'il y
a une surcotisation comme votre régime
il y a une et c'est tout à votre honneur
qu'il soit à l'équilibre on remet en
cause des régimes qui protègent qui sont
à l'équilibre et qui sont efficaces
on pense que c'est pas la piste de
solution que de s'attaquer à ceux qui
sont les plus efficaces plutôt que de
trouver des solutions pour ceux qui
n'ont pas encore de possibilité d'en
bénéficier
sans revenir sur ce qui vient d'être dit
puisque je l'avais déjà précisé dans mon
propos liminaire enfin on sait on sait
tous que la retraite c'est la résultante
de la carrière et que donc la difficulté
c'est pas c'est bien pendant la carrière
c'est pas une fois qu'on arrive à la
retraite on peut réparer mais c'est
d'abord travailler sur les conditions
d'emploi d'abord travailler sur le
maintien dans l'emploi d'abord
travailler sur les augmentations de
salaire d'abord travailler sur les
exonérations pour certaines entreprises
dans les conditionnant ça je l'ai déjà
dit je vais répondre à quelques
questions même si je n'ai pas été très
directement
posé je vais reprendre sur les régies
spéciaux
1 ça a été dit c'est chaud bien souvent
il y a de la surcotisation ou alors il y
a un système de financement qui permet
aux caisses étaient équilibre je pense à
celle des clerc de notaire par exemple
voilà
il y a un système qui permet ce que le
régime soit soit équilibré pourquoi
pourquoi aller supprimer ce régime voilà
comment explique je comprends pas
vraiment et puis surtout ces régimes ces
régimes ces régimes ces régimes ils sont
ils sont historiques ils existaient
avant 45 et puis ils font surtout partie
du contrat social de l'entreprise moi je
rencontre assez régulièrement
les dirigeants qu'ils soient de la RATP
qu'ils soient de EDF etc les régies
spéciaux font partie du contrat social
de ces entreprises
ça veut dire que si vous les supprimer
il faudra d'autres compensations pour
les salariés maintenant il faudra
l'inventer ça veut dire que vous allez
entrer dans sur des des grandes
entreprises telles que EDF-GDF tels que
la rftp qu'elle voilà sur des
compensations et donc éventuellement sur
du conflit social en interne c'est ça
qu'il faut bien avoir en tête également
sur ce qui est sur ce qui est des des
régies spéciaux sur l'espérance de vie
l'espérance de vie
il faut qu'elle soit bien évidemment
pour nous le la plus longue possible en
bonne santé et plus on partage à la
retraite moins on a une espérance de vie
en bonne santé je rappelle quand même
qu'on peut pas oublier aujourd'hui que
l'espérance de vie projetée on n'a pas
pris en compte par exemple et bien les
catastrophes climatiques
on a connu des canicules et les
travailleurs qui seront obligés de
travailler dans des conditions
sous le soleil dans dans des entrepôts
surchauffés et bien cela ils ont une
espérance de vie moins moindre et que
donc il faut prendre il faut se projeter
et il faut prendre en compte également
les effets de des crises climatiques
écologiques et climatiques
il faut il faut le prendre en compte il
faut l'avoir faut l'avoir en mémoire
voilà et que prolonger la carrière telle
que le gouvernement nous le propose et
bien c'est mettre en danger les
travailleurs enfin sur la retraite
progressive la retraite progressive nous
on est favorables à retraite progressive
on est même favorable à ce que ça soit
la loi puis les accords de branches puis
ensuite éventuellement des accords
d'entreprise pourquoi pas
mais la retraite progressive ne doit pas
faire baisser la pension du salarié
attention
la pension de retraite elle doit être la
même s'il y a des dispositifs de
retraites progressive que si la personne
avait travaillé à temps plein et que
donc il faut penser à des systèmes qui
permettent que cette retraite
progressive et bien qu'au moins les
cotisations elles soient compensées sur
le taux plein pour que le salarié lui
quand il arrive à la retraite et bien il
est une pension
à taux plein comme on dit et voilà c'est
à dire que et bien il puisse bénéficier
puisque maintenant c'est comme ça pour
le privé pas pour le public c'est encore
les six derniers mois mais on voit bien
par exemple que à terme si on se réfère
à l'article 1 de la loi qui a été votée
à l'Assemblée qu'on va plutôt vers un
régime unique dans les années qui
viennent et bien évidemment c'est bien
c'est bien la difficulté la question
posée il va Ricordeau sur la la base
salariale dans la fonction publique il
faudra bien qu'on réponde à la question
parce que ça c'est de la cotisation en
moins l'autre le dernier point que que
je voulais évoquer c'est sur le C2P nous
aussi on a fait des propositions et
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales étaient assez étaient toutes
d'accord pour que faire progresser des
plafonner le C2P reprendre en compte
l'ensemble des critères des critères
ergonomiques nous avions fait aussi une
proposition d'où le C2P des plafonnés
plus de 100 points doit permettre de
partir à la retraite plus tôt et il ne
doit permettre que ça à côté de ça il
faut inventer un droit à la transition
professionnelle pour les salariés qu'on
des métiers pénibles pour qu'ils
puissent faire leur deuxième partie de
carrière restez donc en emploi dans des
métiers moins pénibles ça c'est un vrai
droit qui doit exister et qui n'existe
pas aujourd'hui et il y a du financement
il y a du financement il faut un moment
donné responsabiliser aussi les
entreprises dans ce cadre là voilà les
alors sur les carrières longues les 43
ans enfin voilà les 43 ans d'activité
pour mon organisation nous y étions
opposés à l'époque voilà nous continuons
à y être opposés elle s'applique à tous
mais je rappelle que que à aujourd'hui
la majorité des jeunes rendent sur le
marché du travail après 25 ans enfin
avec un bras en poids je veux dire
quelque chose ou vous cotisez quoi pas
un CDD par-ci un CDD par là avec des
petits salaires au SMIC non 25 ans vous
rajoutez 43 on est déjà bien au-delà des
64 ans et que donc reculer l'âge de
départ à la retraite pour le mettre dans
un texte c'est purement inutile et
démagogique
voilà Monsieur mardinet oui bah écoutez
je vais compléter les éléments de Michel
Boga sur l'espérance de vie en
particulier parce qu'on a analysé le
rapport que l'Insee publie tous les 5
ans qui est le rapport sur la
démographie de la France le dernier
étant sorti fin 2021 et finalement
comment l'Insee projette l'espérance de
vie dans le futur et ben c'est un débat
de statisticien sur est-ce que je
prolonge la pente de la droite de des
cinq dernières années des dix dernières
années ou des 20 dernières années et ils
choisissent de prendre un intervalle
relativement long mais c'est pas
justifié par le l'analyse des facteurs
qui réellement influent sur l'évolution
d'espérance de vie ces documenter dans
quelques études dont une étude de l'OCDE
sur la santé dans le monde et l'OCDE
c'est des gens qui ont même qui
travaillent et les facteurs qui influent
c'est quoi c'est l'état du système de
santé et du système hospitalier c'est le
niveau des pollutions environnementales
de toute nature au nourriture air etc
voir les changements climatiques et si
vous considérez ça et bien
l'espérance de vie notre système
hospitalier je crois que pas grand monde
peut dire qu'il est en très bon état des
gens meurent dans les couloirs aux
urgences maintenant donc
et ben non l'espérance de vie est plutôt
stable et d'ailleurs on avait repris
quels étaient l'espérance de vie prévue
en 2021 dans les projections qui avaient
été faites en 2011
les projections de 2011 étant celles qui
ont servi à la loi Touraine et bien
l'espérance de vie constatée en 2021 et
d'un an inférieur à celle qui était
projetée dans les projections ce qui
veut dire que pour revenir non non non
le covid c'était 2020 l'espérance de vie
2022 elle est au même niveau que celle
de
de 2021 les mêmes inférieurs à celle de
2017 si vous voulez donc non non le
plateau il est pas lié au covid le
plateau qu'on rencontre et donc même
s'il y a eu un pic on est bien d'accord
de mortalité en 2020 et un petit peu en
2021 et donc voilà les facteurs sont pas
objectifs et on peut même dire que la
loi Touraine l'esprit de la loi Touraine
c'était comme la rappeler
Ivan mais sans mettre les chiffres
c'était on alloue deux tiers des gains
d'espérance de vie à la vie active et un
tiers à la retraite c'était ça ce qui
avait été dit à l'époque ça veut dire
que si on s'appuyait sur l'espérance de
vie constatée par rapport à ce qu'elle
était projetée dans le rapport de 2011
qui a servi à la base mais il faudrait
s'arrêter à 42 ans bon bon alors c'est
pas le débat actuel on dit ok c'est
comme ça mais si on prenait en compte
ces éléments on devrait même s'arrêter à
42 ans donc vous voyez que ces données
d'espérance de vie de même que quand
vous prenez l'avion vous atterrissez à
Orly je sais pas ben si le pilote a eu
des prévisions météo qui lui prévoyaient
du beau temps vous espérez que s'il y a
du brouillard il va quand même
actualiser sa pratique et pas se poser
comme s'il y avait beau temps s'il y a
du brouillard donc bah là c'est pareil
faut actualiser et prendre en compte les
facteurs qui influent et pas uniquement
des projections statistiques qui ne sont
pas réalistes et d'ailleurs
Hervé Le Bras de Linette l'a bien
souligné lui-même et lui c'est un expert
démographe donc voilà
le deuxième point sur lequel je voulais
intervenir bon sur la pénibilité bien
sûr il faut s'améliorer moi je vous ré
souligner ça avait été déjà fait et en
particulier sur la disponibilité
psychique qui croit fortement et
d'ailleurs qui influe sur les contes de
l'assurance maladie parce qu'il y a de
plus en plus d'arrêt de travail quand
les gens arrivent fatigués en fin de
carrière
usées psychologiquement qui ne trouve
plus de sens dans leur travail et ça
fera bien le considérer aussi dans la
pénibilité parce que beaucoup de nos
concitoyens qui ont des fonctions
d'encadrement vu que nous on adresse
plutôt ce public là ben considère que le
projet de loi avec l'augmentation de
l'âge c'est un projet de loi liberticide
c'est-à-dire moi si j'ai plus de sens
dans mon boulot si je suis fatigué je
veux garder la possibilité de partir
même si j'ai pas tout mes trimestres et
ça c'est vécu dans l'encadrement comme
un projet de loi liberticide un jeu et
si on a autant de mobilisation dans les
Russes et essentiellement pour ça après
moi je voudrais vous alerter aussi alors
c'est Monsieur ça va monsieur monsieur
Savary qui l'a dit mais il faut pas
réduire un système de retraite
comme étant sensible à un seul facteur
bon le facteur nombre d'actifs sur
nombre le ratioactif retraité est
souvent cité comme un élément important
je suis d'accord c'est un élément
important et on le voit bien sur la
fonction publique ou ce ratioactif
retraité fonction publique d'État est
inférieure à maintenant parce qu'il y a
plus d'embauche au statut etc voilà et
donc si un problème de recettes dans nos
systèmes de retraite il est
essentiellement du côté du fait que
l'État ne finance pas correctement et
donc est un gestionnaire de très
mauvaise qualité de la retraite des
salariés dont il a la responsabilité et
pour ça s'il y a un problème de de
recettes au niveau de l'État bah c'est
pas à tous les salariés de travailler
deux ans de plus pour fournir vers cet
état c'est à l'état de mobiliser toutes
ces recettes et nous on en appelle en
particulier à avoir un meilleur partage
de la valeur qui ferait rentrer
plusieurs sets dans les caisses de
l'état de la part des grandes
entreprises qui et puis de traiter enfin
le sujet de l'évasion fiscale et de la
fraude fiscal qui ramènerait un grand
nombre de ressources dans les caisses de
l'État plutôt que de demander aux gens
de travailler plus pour que ça continue
à amplifier l'évasion fiscale donc ça
nous et on voit bien on est sa pénalise
fortement les salariés les travailleurs
et sur un problème d'exemplarité moi
j'en appelle quand même à un point vous
savez qui existe des retraites chapeau
pour les dirigeants d'entreprise et ça
on en a nous on aimerait bien parce que
quand on dit ah bah il y a des hautes
retraites bah oui bah quelqu'un qui
touche une retraite de 4000 euros ou
4500 euros parce qu'il a une une
carrière avec une forte rémunération
c'est pas lui qu'il faut venir amputer
la retraite il faut augmenter les
petites retraites en entièrement
d'accord mais j'attire en particulier
votre
attention sur ce qu'on appelle l'article
82 par référence à l'article 82 du CGI
qui est un dispositif de retraite
chapeau beaucoup utilisé en entreprise
et où finalement les entreprises vu que
c'est un dispositif ou l'imposition se
fait l'entrée les entreprises payent des
dirigeants si vous voulez donc on offre
moi j'appelle c'est quasiment de l'abus
de bien social ça quand vous avez une
entreprise et qui pendant ce temps là et
ben elle ne sait pas de l'argent qui va
dans les investissements pour créer de
l'emploi en France et pas de l'argent
qui va pour rémunérer les salariés et
donc moi j'aimerais bien que ce sujet là
soit abordé parce que c'est vraiment un
dispositif scandaleux
très bien alors mais chers collègues
nous avons 12 questions
12 questions donc nous allons prendre
les douze question à suivre et enfin les
12 collègues à suivre et je demanderai à
nos intervenants de répondre brièvement
sur des points particuliers mais je vous
demande de faire des questions concises
parce qu'à 11 heures nous avons en
principe les organisations patronales
donc des questions consistent ce n'est
pas la peine forcément de répéter ce que
vient de dire le collègue des questions
très précises et très concises même si
je sais que le sujet est très important
et nous aurait fallu sans doute plus de
temps néanmoins c'est ainsi victoire
jasmin
merci oui merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur pour les
informations que vous avez transmises
alors moi je vais parler des Outre-mer
de participer et particulièrement de la
Guadeloupe
en outre-mer il y a un fort taux de
chômage des jeunes et il y a une grande
majorité de femmes qui travaillent pas
qui sont chômage et celles qui
travaillent ont des carrières qui sont
chaotiques je dirais donc vous avez
illustré par vos propos des situations
qui sont celles que vous connaissez et
j'ai même entendu qu'il y avait pas en
France des retraites et pauvres alors
que je fus vice-président de CCAS et
beaucoup de femmes retraitées ont des
difficultés pour garder leur loyer pour
payer leur loyer pour garder leur
logement et pour payer leurs factures
alors je voudrais également savoir ce
que vous pensez du chômage des jeunes
alors est-ce que quand prolongeant le
nombre d'amitié pour les personnes qui
travaillent et qui malheureusement n'ont
pas forcément une retraite décente
est-ce que les jeunes doivent payer
justement en étant au chômage
en ayant évidemment des
contrats des contrats saisonniers ou
quelquefois carrément rien du tout
ils sont malheureusement dans des
situations de violence quelquefois c'est
du trafic de toutes sortes y compris de
drogues qui leur permet de faire des
choses indécentes il va illicite alors
moi je ne voudrais qu'on puisse
réfléchir aussi pour les jeunes parce
qu'on parle des aînés des seniors c'est
vrai travailler plus longtemps c'est le
choix du gouvernement mais moi je suis
très inquiète pour ce territoire là et
particulièrement pour la Guadeloupe
merci
très bien Monique Lubin ensuite ce sera
vraiment de penserment j'ai encore une
merci madame la Présidente bon je vais
éviter tous les commentaires que j'ai
envie de faire pour pas rallonger on les
frappe pendant le débat donc
monsieur Ricordeau vous avez un
préambule fait une comparaison avec la
période qui était celle de la réforme
Touraine en disant qu'effectivement les
le comment dire le la situation
financière à l'époque des régimes de
retraite n'était pas du tout celle que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui ce que vous
avez des éléments un peu plus précis à
nous donner deuxième question
le système des carrières longues est
maintenu mais il est modifié quelqu'un
qui a commencé à travailler à 18 ans
devra travailler jusqu'à 62 ans et non
plus jusqu'à 60 ans et c'est donc là
qu'on peut trouver des gens qui auront
44 annuités la première ministre dit on
va remédier à ça de quelle façon est-ce
que est-ce qu'il y sera remédier est-ce
que ces gens là pourront partir à 61 ans
est-ce qu'il y a des discussions à ce
sujet et où on sent ces discussions
troisième chose troisième alors c'est
toujours pour Monsieur Ricordeau vous
avez été franc je serai franchement
aussi
la question de de l'emploi des seniors
elle est évidemment primordiale c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que moi je dis qu'il
s'agit pas d'un projet de réforme des
retraites mais juste effectivement d'une
loi de finances parce qu'on aurait dû
commencer par parler travail avant de
parler retraite mais on en débattra
ce qui s'est passé hier soir à
l'Assemblée nationale effectivement vous
avez l'air bon de le regretter en
considérant que c'est comment dire une
erreur puisque du coup il y aura plus
rien dans la réforme des retraites
concernant l'emploi des seniors mais si
ça s'est passé comme ça c'est parce que
de toute façon ce qui était prévu ce qui
est prévu dans la réforme tout le monde
le sait que ça ou rien c'est à peu près
pareil tout le monde de sait qu'un index
ça ne sert à rien d'ailleurs on a qu'à
voir ce qui se passe en matière
d'égalité salariale homme-femme par
exemple il y a eu plein d'index plein de
machins plein de trucs bon bah
finalement il se passe toujours la même
chose et des lois qui ne sont pas
respectées donc on peut regretter ce qui
s'est passé hier soir mais effectivement
le dialogue social il se passe pas
à l'Assemblée nationale au Sénat le
dialogue social il se passe par des non
pas des concertations mais des
négociations avec les syndicats est-ce
que vous penchez pas que c'est plutôt
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que c'est
plutôt là que ça a péché
bien évidemment plutôt côté gouvernement
je ne remets pas en question la volonté
de débattre des syndicats je vais
m'arrêter là j'aurais plein d'autres
questions à poser mais on verra ça plus
tard
vraiment de penser manger brièvement
également brièvement il me le rappelle
grande crainte
moi j'aimerais que toutes les
organisations syndicales
très rapidement me répondre sur le bilan
qui font quand même des réformes
précédentes et notamment du passage de
60 à 62 ans car quand même cette réforme
ou des annuités on nous l'a vendu un
petit peu enfin certains ont été pour
certains ont été compte mais pour ces
fameux critères de pénibilité alors je
reviens pas sur le fait qu'on en a
enlevé 4 remis 3 en ergonomique mais
quand même c'est bien beau cela mais si
vous regardez des statistiques quand
même
les critères de pénibilité sont tous
dans une tendance d'aggravation que vous
preniez tous les critères d'exposition
d'exposition aux risques les contrats et
risques physiques à partir de trois
contraintes l'intensité du travail la
contrainte de temps la contrainte de
rythme la CFDT en a parlé qui font
effectivement les risques aussi
psychosociaux tout cela ils explosent
d'un année et donc on fait une réforme
en disant on donnera deux ans à ceux qui
deux ans maximum et maintenant 62 ans à
ceux qui sont exposés sans critiquer
sans aucune critique du fait que
l'évolution tendancielle elle est à de
plus en plus où il y avait une
contrainte physique il y en a trois une
contrainte de rythme c'est avec sans
autonomie tout ça donc vraiment
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu avec avec je
dis bien maintenant le CHSCT qui a été
supprimé moi j'insiste beaucoup sur le
CHSCT qui explique peut-être aussi cette
exposition
de plus de plus en plus forte car enfin
répartir entre la carrière et la
retraite enfin aujourd'hui c'est pas le
cas la durée de la retraite baisse
c'est-à-dire que non seulement on a
bouloté les gains d'espérance de vie
mais on a pris sur
donc je crois qu'il faut moi j'aimerais
vous entendre
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu 60-62 enfin
et ça affaiblit aussi les faire
redistributifs de la retraite vous
qu'est-ce que vous vous avez vu et
comment si vous voulez partir du moment
où les conséquences ont été aussi graves
de 60 à 62 ans on peut effectivement
oser penser 62 64 qui sera avec des
effets beaucoup plus durs rien ne fait
rien merci messieurs merci madame la
Présidente à mon tour de vous interroger
sur la pénibilité de deux questions vous
l'avez rappelé donc quatre critères sur
qui ont été supprimés en 2017
aujourd'hui dans ce projet de loi
rectificatif le gouvernement propose de
réintégrer j'ai mis des guillemets trois
critères ou c'est pas réintégrer c'est
pour ça que j'ai mis des guillemets non
mais c'est pour ça que j'ai bien dit de
réintégrer avec des énormes guillemets
parce que c'est aussi leur communication
trois de ces quatre critères les trois
critères ergonomiques mais rien sur les
risques chimiques donc que pensez-vous
de cette proposition quel est votre avis
sur cette proposition de la même façon
l'autre question quel est votre avis sur
la proposition de mise en place d'un
fond le fipu le fond d'investissement
pour la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle voilà que pensez-vous de
cette proposition
très bien Katia pour ce Boli
merci madame la Présidente alors moi je
ne vais pas revenir sur tout le bien que
je pense de cette réforme avec l'horos
Cohen nous aurons le temps évidemment en
séance de d'essayer de démontrer avec
les amendements que nous déposerons et
bien évidemment
bien évidemment pourquoi cette réforme
est profondément injuste et ça a été dit
par les syndicats profondément injuste
pour les femmes et profondément injuste
pour les salariés et les ouvriers qui
peinent le plus parce que finalement
la question est bien elle est celle-ci
moi je voudrais féliciter les
organisations syndicales
parce que il y a quand même des millions
des milliers dans toutes les villes dans
des petites villes parfois moi je le
vois chez moi à Saint-Omer 4000
personnes dans une petite ville
féliciter les organisations syndicales
parce que il n'y a pas de débordement
les manifestations alors qu'il y a des
millions de personnes dans la rue et
bien se passe bien
sans aucun débordement et nous n'avons
ici enfin pour ma part ni à souffrir les
uns les autres d'agression ou quoi que
ce soit je préfère qu'on se dit les
choses parce que parfois on a tendance à
dire bon voilà mais là franchement pas
du tout chou on a connu pire avec
d'autres projets de loi donc en tous les
cas je tenais à le dire voilà alors moi
je voudrais vous poser juste trois
questions puisque le temps nous est
compté et qu'on va pouvoir le faire ici
même si je pense que la méthode n'est
pas la même puisque nous avons affaire
il faut se le dire à un 49-3 déguisé
c'est ce que nous pensons avec cette
réforme des retraites moi je voudrais
savoir si si vous enfin si vous pouvez
répondre à cette question peut-être pas
là tout de suite parce que finalement je
demande des chiffres mais avez-vous des
chiffres précis sur l'espérance de vie
parce qu'il y a l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé en bonne santé entre les
professions et entre les milieux
sociaux qui sont différents parce que on
lit des choses mais j'aimerais si vous
le pouvez donner des chiffres on parle
euros brut
on entend tout et n'importe quoi et
d'ailleurs le gouvernement n'est pas en
capacité aujourd'hui de nous répondre
sur le nombre de personnes qui
toucheront les 1200 euros avez-vous pour
votre pain un chiffre et nous
communiquer et j'aimerais savoir
finalement en moyenne de combien de
combien
les personnes donc seront-ils augmentées
et j'ai une troisième question si vous
me permettez la prise en compte de la
pénibilité
sera
comment dire sera prise
la pensez-vous que le report de l'âge va
compter et créer de nouvelles personnes
finalement en situation de précarité
j'arrête parce que j'avais encore 5 ou 6
questions sur la précarité mais c'est
pas la et sur
surtout la pénibilité ou les quand même
Emmanuel Macron avait déjà remis les
critères de pénibilité en cause
puisqu'il avait remis quatre critères de
pénibilité en cause merci
je suis désolé
merci madame la Présidente
donc de questions pour moi d'abord
davantage de dialogue social avant les
projets de loi notamment sur le travail
des seniors que vous avez tous évoqué et
je pense que ça aurait été beaucoup plus
fructueux avant ce projet de loi pour
pour mettre en place donc ce projet de
loi et travailler d'abord avant sur les
emplois seniors puisque nous sommes les
plus mauvais au niveau de l'Europe donc
deux questions quelles solutions pour la
retraite progressive et le travail
partiel quelle solution pour inciter les
PME à conserver les seniors d'abord
incitation fiscale
ou sanction et aussi au niveau niveau de
la pénibilité
monsieur de la CGT a indiqué tout à
l'heure par exemple que les aides
soignantes les infirmières
ne pouvaient pas aller jusqu'à 64 ans je
suis d'accord c'est quand ça va être
considéré comme un travail pénible et
selon vous qui doit mettre en place les
critères pour la qualification de
travail pénible voilà merci
bien Frédéric puissant ensuite Alain
Dufour à chaque molle vient nous
Martinique Christine bonfantilote je
vais tout de suite à ma question merci
pour vos interventions Monsieur Madame
présidente simplement nous avons un
certain nombre de nos collègues députés
conduits par notre collègue Philippe
Juvin qui propose de mettre en place un
régime additionnel et d'introduire une
part de capitalisation dans le système
quel est votre avis
question courte mais Claire Alain Dufour
oui merci
messieurs les intervenants les
représentants syndicaux juste une
question aussi rapidement il a fait il a
été fait état de du travail des seniors
et on sait qu'en France il y a seulement
33 % des seniors qui sont embauchés bon
quels sont les incitations que vous
voyez pour les entreprises pour
permettre l'emploi de ces seniors
premier point le deuxième point il
faudrait qu'on s'y sur le projet de loi
il se soit clarifié les 1200 euros par
mois car on parle de 1200 euros si vous
voulez net et 85 % du SMIC ça fait pas
le compte donc je voudrais avoir vos
éléments là dessus merci
oui merci madame la Présidente oui je
voulais rapidement aussi vous
questionnez messieurs sur l'emploi des
seniors et sur l'égalité du salaire
femme homme puisque vous avez dit que en
rencontrant nos trois rapporteurs que
dont je salue d'ailleurs
l'investissement et le travail sur un
texte qui est quand même très technique
vous aviez donné des pistes et j'aurais
bien aimé connaître les pistes sur
lesquelles que vous envisagez merci
Olivier c'est nous oui merci madame la
Présidente merci messieurs d'abord un
juste un constat rapide je crois qu'on a
la démonstration tous les jours que on
peut pas engager une réforme sociale de
cette ampleur sans un pariarisme fort et
la question qui va être la nôtre c'est
comment on va renforcer le paritarisme
dans les années à venir maintenant trois
questions
très très pointu la première sur la
question de la pénibilité vous l'avez
évoqué mais ce qu'on a pas quand même un
regard un peu
passéiste sur la pénibilité et vous
l'avez abordé sur la question psychique
la pénibilité elle existe pour un
ouvrier mais encore qu'avec la
robotisation parfois un peu moins
qu'autre fois tant mieux mais elle
existe aussi pour un professeur qui est
dans l'enseignement dans un collège ou
dans un lycée difficile et finalement il
y a pas beaucoup de voix qu'on entend
sur sur ce sujet deuxième question sur
l'index senior feu l'index seniors mais
enfin tout de même aborder cette
question est-ce que
[Musique]
quelque chose qui tomberait autour d'un
bonus malus pour être une idée selon
vous très très très précisément et
troisième question sur la politique
familiale j'ai la conviction moi que on
est aidé à accompagner dans beaucoup de
choses dans notre société aujourd'hui
finalement encore assez peu pour avoir
un enfant pour éduquer un enfant et donc
la question du renouvellement des
générations est posée et pensez-vous que
en matière de politique familiale la
majoration de pensions pourrait être une
incitation et et et
quelque chose de concret pour faciliter
une vraie politique familiale parce que
il y a des interrogations est-ce qu'il
faut aider ou gratifier les gens plus
tard ou est-ce qu'il faut les aider au
moment où ils ont des enfants avez-vous
un regard sur cette question je vous
remercie Martin lévrier merci madame la
Présidente quelques questions qui sont
importantes pour bien comprendre le
problème parce que on a un problème
d'équilibre malgré tout du régime des
retraites alors en jouant sur certains
curseurs je l'ai entendu tout à l'heure
on dit que finalement il y aura
peut-être pas de déficit est-ce que
finalement et ça rejoint la
problématique des seigneurs si
finalement on dit que le taux de chômage
est très bas dans le choix qu'on va
faire de calcul
indirectement on inclut une embauche une
prolongation longue des seniors de
l'entreprise si le taux de chômage est
de 5% je crois que d'ailleurs le corps
son analyse et sur une base de l'ordre
de 5% de chômage quelque part ça veut
dire que les seniors restent dans
l'entreprise et que les jeunes sont
plutôt actifs 5% de chômeurs donc une
fois qu'on prend ce critère là le débat
sur les seniors est un autre débat selon
moi et si on est sur 5% malgré un
déficit comme on fait pour avoir plus de
recettes c'est-à-dire
plus de recettes sachant qu'on n'aura
pas plus d'actifs quelle est la bonne
solution
j'ai entendu aussi augmenter les
cotisations donc c'est baisser le
pouvoir d'achat moi j'ai pas oublié que
quand on a enlevé 5 euros de cotisations
d'appel ça a été la fin du monde donc
augmenter les cotisations me paraît pas
aujourd'hui dans la dans la
problématique du pouvoir d'achat une
bonne solution donc quelles sont les
solutions que vous proposez par rapport
à ça si on part du principe que le taux
de chômage et de l'ordre 5% du plein
emploi donc qui dit plein emploi dit pas
de problématique seniors mais je ne nie
pas que la problématique Seigneur existe
un jeu de l'année absolument pas
on dit que c'est l'analyse le curseur
qui est posé là puis une deuxième
question qui est la dernière quand je
regarde la France n'est pas une île
quand je regarde les autres pays
d'Europe je me rends compte que nous
sommes un des pays qui a le l'âge de
départ à la retraite le plus bas c'est
très bien en soi mais qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on est meilleur que les autres
comment vous analysez le fait qu'on soit
bien meilleur que les autres sur ce
sujet là puisque l'Italie est prêt à
monter à 69 ans alors que ce sont nos
voisins les plus proches merci beaucoup
et pour terminer Christine Bonfanti de
ça alors lorsqu'on arrive presque enfin
les questions seront un peu redondantes
moi j'ai trois points rapides vous avez
beaucoup parlé d'espérance de vie mais
pas ou peu de natalité alors que la
question de la de la politique familiale
et fondamentale lorsqu'on sait qu'il
faut plus de 20 ans pour un jeune pour
qu'il contribue à ce système de
répartition auquel vous êtes très
attaché qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me
dire sur cela la pénibilité donc je
redis que effectivement il y a des
critères qui ont été enlevés est-ce il
faut aujourd'hui les réhabiliter et plus
particulièrement je pense à l'exposition
au risque chimiques et puis pour finir à
travailler égal salaire égal c'est ce
qui est inscrit dans la loi du 4 août
2014 pour qu'ils pour une égalité réelle
entre les hommes et les femmes donc
2014-2023 comment expliquer vous alors
la situation qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
très bien merci à mes collègues qui ont
été
obéissante à mes consignes un peu oui
non c'est pas rare aux États-Unis
d'être quand même un peu maîtresse
d'école
genre de débat et je laisse monsieur
Ricordeau on regarde toujours le même
ordre ok ma chérie
je sais pas si les quatre syndicalistes
vont être obéissants mais au moins dans
les rêves au moins dans les règles du
jeu on va enfin je vais pas répondre à
l'ensemble des questions en parlant on
se répartir sans doute pour essayer de
les traiter dans le temps qui est un
parti
sur différentes questions qui ont été
qui ont été posées le comparatif je vais
le faire très rapidement mais le
comparatif par rapport aux
réformes précédentes c'est aujourd'hui
le débat public je reviens pas sur les
discords peu importe le débat public
parle de aux alentours d'un besoin de
financement de 10 milliards d'euros par
an 2014 le même débat public point un
enjeu financier aux alentours d'une
trentaine de milliards d'euros trois
fois plus important en 2010 quand il y a
eu la réforme Fillon il y avait une
perspective financière aux alentours de
50 milliards d'euros 5 fois plus
important et 2014 2010 systématiquement
les projections prévoyaient des systèmes
financiers en chute libre derrière le
besoin à court terme que je viens de
libérer donc aujourd'hui on est à 10
milliards d'euros et une perspective de
stabilisation de l'équilibre financier à
terme donc c'est ça les pures voilà et
la question qui est la question qui est
posée c'est pourquoi alors qu'on est
dans l'horizon financier le moins dur
pourquoi on a la réforme la plus brutale
c'est ça la question qui est posée et la
question qui est derrière cette affaire
là mais qui mais qui est un vrai débat
politique et qui a un vrai débat public
le la question qui est derrière c'est
que en fait la réforme et le PLFSS qui
est proposé n'est pas une question de
règlement du problème financier des
systèmes de retraite c'est une question
d'ajustement des finances publiques
c'est ça la question qui est derrière
mais c'est une question qui
politiquement peut venir dans un pays
quel qu'il soit et le nôtre on avait on
avait un déficit public qui était
important il y a une politique publique
de soutien à l'économie pendant la crise
covid qui est tout à fait justifiée sur
nous mais qui a encore dégradé les
finances publiques et donc la question
de comment rétablit les finances
publiques il y a un vrai débat politique
a mené dans ce pays-là la seule question
pour la CFDT qui est imprenable c'est
qu'on ne peut pas rétablir les finances
publiques uniquement en ajustant la
protection sociale des travailleurs or
c'est ça le choix politique qui est fait
dans la période actuelle on a commencé
par l'assurance chômage on continue par
les retraites et donc il est pas
question que on ne touche pas la
fiscalité que l'on touche pas on ne
regarde pas la question des aides aux
entreprises qui sont des autres éléments
importants de dépenses publiques et que
puisqu'on ne veut pas toucher la
fiscalité puisqu'on ne veut pas changer
le mode opératoire en termes de
conditionnalité pour les aides publiques
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et ben on a juste
la protection sociale c'est ça le débat
derrière et c'est pas le débat sur le
financement du système de retraite en
premier qui est posé donc voilà pour la
première partie sur les carrières
longues sur les carrières je vais pas
répondre précisément on sait ce qui
s'est on connaît les annonces on a lu le
phrasé de la première ministre hier à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a pas la
possibilité d'avoir quelques éléments
d'analyse si on n'a pas le futur décret
il y a rien dans la loi sur les
carrières longues dans la loi il y a
juste besoin de mettre des bandages et
encore même ce qu'il y avait dans la loi
aujourd'hui est suffisant tout se
réglera par décret derrière donc il faut
absolument dans le débat qui a lieu
actuellement sur l'ajustement des
dispositifs avoir la transparence du
futur décret s'il y a pas ça c'est
impossible de dire est-ce que c'est
plutôt positif ou plutôt négatif la
mesure qui est proposée et combien de
salariés seront concernés par les
annonces qui ont été effectuées en
fonction de quels critères si vous
n'avez pas le décret vous avez rien en
termes de connaissances on a trop
navigué dans la concertation qu'on a eu
avec le ministère du travail sur des
éléments oraux sur les carrières longues
à enfin on a dit si vous nous mettez pas
sur la table des tableaux qui nous
disent comment évoluent ce dispositif là
et ben on y arrivera pas et ben vous
avez la même chose Assemblée nationale
et Sénat sur le dispositif carrière
longue si vous avez pas un truc carré
avec l'ensemble des critères l'ensemble
des tableaux qui vous dit comment les
choses vont évoluer il y a enfin pour
nous c'est impossible de se prononcer
donc pour l'instant c'est trop vague et
c'est un truc particulièrement important
pour la CFDT c'est nous qui sommes à
l'origine de ce dispositif là et on a on
est on s'est beaucoup intervenus pour
vérifier comment les choses allaient
évoluer vous voyez la difficulté dans
laquelle on se situe et j'ai cru
comprendre que l'annonce d'hier à
l'Assemblée nationale provoque le même
élément de demande de clarification pour
savoir exactement qu'est-ce qui bouge ou
ça bouge dans quel sens ça bouge et à
quelle hauteur ça bouge quoi bah voilà
on a résumé la question sur ce
dispositif là je il me reste deux points
sur lesquels intervenir sur l'index sur
sur l'index ce que je veux dire c'est
moi j'ai enfin on a été alerté par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé conseillère
pas tant que ça a été repoussé ou pas
repoussé on a enfin l'index c'est un
outil c'est pas l'index qui va faire la
politique de l'emploi du Seigneur dans
notre pays donc là-dessus on n'a pas
d'état d'âme le seul élément qui enfin
le seul élément l'élément d'inquiétude
de la CFDT c'est que l'article 2 a été
repoussé parce que je suis désolé je le
dis tel que moi je l'ai compris je peux
me tromper parce que les républicains ou
une partie des républicains se sont
positionnés pour dire on est contre le
fait de baisser le seuil à des
entreprises à 50 salariés et on est
contre le fait de renforcer la
négociation d'entreprise quand l'index
va pas dans le bon sens et donc
une partie et une partie des
de la majorité c'est aussi positionner
dans ce sens là ce qui veut dire qu'on
avait déjà un dispositif index senior
qui n'était pas à la nature d'avoir une
politique de l'emploi du Seigneur mais
en plus on a un refus nous on regarde ça
dans la perspective du débat au Sénat ou
sur lesquels enfin tout le monde a
compris le film qui pouvait se passer
quoi et donc du coup le seul qui peut se
passer selon nous à l'avenir c'est que
la politique de l'emploi du Seigneur qui
était déjà pas très ambitieuse dans le
projet initial dans le cadre de la
concertation on essayait de le renforcer
on a formulé des amendements qui
permettaient d'aller plus loin sur le
dialogue social plus loin sur les plus
loin sur tout cela est détricoté au fur
et à mesure il y avait déjà pas la
politique de l'emploi des seniors on va
avec quoi on va se retrouver au sortir
des Sénats sur cette politique là
c'était ça le le propos que je tenais
tout à l'heure sur la pénibilité sur la
pénibilité il y a quatre critères qui
ont été sortis en 2017 il y a un critère
sur les agents chimiques dangereux ça
c'est d'une autre nature que les trois
autres tout simplement parce que c'est
très on l'admet au niveau de la CFDT
c'est compliqué sur ce sur ce critère là
sur les agences chimiques dangereux de
calculer comment chaque salarié est
exposé en fonction et c'est plutôt et on
a convenu dans la discussion avec le
ministère du Travail on est transparent
et on est on est enfin on n'a pas de
discours différents au niveau du Sénat
qu'on l'ASSE national qu'on l'a dans la
rue et qu'on l'a avec le ministère du
Travail on dit la même chose on a
convenu avec le ministère du Travail que
sur les agents chimiques dangereux
c'était une vraie question de
législation pour protéger les
travailleurs sur les normes des agences
chimiques dangereux et que c'était
compliqué de le faire rentrer dans le
compte pénibilité position de la CFDT
affirmer comme ça voilà par contre sur
les trois critères ergonomiques par des
charges lourdes
vibrations mécanique et postures
pénibles ils ont été sortis en 2017 ces
trois critères ergonomiques provoquent
95% des troubles musculo-squelettiques
dans le monde du travail aujourd'hui
donc ceux-là ils sont névralgiques en
termes de conditions de travail et de
réparation de la pénibilité cela le
gouvernement le ministère du Travail et
la première ministre ne veulent pas les
voir réintégrer le compte le compte de
prévention de la pénibilité le C2P pour
et donc pourquoi ils ne veulent pas ils
ne veulent pas sur un marqueur politique
qui est de pas le remettre dans le à
l'origine et en faisant ça ils
interdisent la réparation pour les
salariés pour qu'il bénéficie en
fonction de critères de dispositif de
départ anticipé à la retraite c'est ça
c'est ça c'est là-dessus qu'on a une
opposition quoi et donc ce que
revendique la CFDT c'est sur ces trois
qualités là il faut les remettre dans le
compte de prévention de la pénibilité
c'est ça qu'on prenne professionnelle de
prévention de la pénibilité c'est ça
qu'il faut faire sur les 1200 €, je
finis là-dessus j'ai juste une petite
touche pas je peux pas m'empêcher je
vous passe la parole derrière je sur le
match Park européen sur le benchmark
européen là-dessus enfin je ok les
grandes images on peut se les passer les
uns après les autres moi j'ai la
responsabilité européenne au niveau de
la CFDT aussi en même temps quand je
discute avec les syndicalistes européens
il se passe deux choses c'est en France
faut pas oublier qu'on a deux critères
l'âge de la retraite il est à 67 ans
l'âge d'ouverture des droits il est à 62
ans aujourd'hui et la mécanique a
fonctionne sur ces deux éléments là et
donc le truc du benchmark européen
uniquement sur la retraite à 62 ans
c'est facile de le faire mais la réalité
est pas celle-là parce que en France le
départ moyen a dépassé l'âge d'ouverture
des droits et quand vous discutez avec
les syndicats listes européens vous
savez ce qui se passe il se passe que
les Français disent nous on a
l'ouverture des droits au-delà de 62 ans
et on est en train de prolonger après
les 62 ans et tous les Européens vous
disent nous on a la retraite à cet
âge-là et les salariés font le choix de
décoder ils partent avant c'est ça la
réalité et donc nous on a une réalité
qui dépasse le critère et eux ils ont
une réalité qui anticipe le critère donc
faut y aller faut faire attention il
faut faire attention à ce qui se passe
au niveau européen on est sur on est sur
la continuation de l'augmentation de la
durée d'activité comme les autres pays
Européens on n'a pas choisi parce qu'on
est en France et qu'on a un système de
répartition en France qui a une histoire
et vous allez discuter en Belgique aller
discuter en Belgique dans l'indexation
des salaires vous allez voir ce qui se
passe par rapport à ce qui se passe en
France sur la revalorisation des
salaires chacun une histoire sociale qui
a qui a construit notre système
de
60 ans à 62 ans en 2010 même Ligas pour
prendre des sources quand même qui qui
élargissent en fait la permet d'élargir
la réflexion un disque indique pardon
que l'allongement du sas de précarité
explose du fait des conséquences du
report de l'âge légal du droit de départ
à la retraite vous savez on rassure tout
le monde ce qui s'épanouissent dans leur
métier on le souhaite on est là pour ça
ils peuvent y rester il y a aucun
problème nous on demande simplement la
possibilité et le droit de partir
ensemble à 62 et avant la position de la
CGT c'est 60 mais ces deux éléments
amènent quand même à chacune des
contre-réformes ça toujours été les
salariés qui devaient payer finalement
systématiquement et pourquoi on appelle
ça une contre-réforme parce qu'une
réforme est nécessaire peut l'être il y
a celle de 82 qui permet de réaugmenter
les pensions de la population et de plus
avoir des de moins avoir de retraite
pauvres notamment par la possibilité de
de départ à l'âge de 60 ans
c'est une réforme de justice et de
progrès social pas un recul
supplémentaire mes propos ont du être
maladroit aussi parce que je partage
complètement ce qu'a dit la sénatrice
madame jasmin sur la question des femmes
et des retraités de preuves évidemment
je le partage pleinement ce que j'ai
voulu dire très précisément c'est que
u égard ou comparativement aux autres
pays européens nous n'avions pas ou peu
de retraite de misère et que bien sûr il
y a encore trop de retraités pauvre d'où
la question 2200 euros traité mais d'une
manière indécente par celles et ceux qui
ne perçoivent pas puisque cet effet de
communication est le seul présenté comme
une justice sociale comme une mesure de
justice sociale qui aurait dû être
appliquée comme ça a été rappelé depuis
2003 à 85% du SMIC mais pour avoir
participé comme mes collègues au
concertation et pas aux négociations
c'est dire l'état du dialogue social
dans ce pays que des concertations
jamais de négociations
il n'était pas capable de quantifier de
chiffrer de dater cette mesure et pas
capable de recalculer puisque c'est un
élément fort pour les citoyens de ce
pays pour les travailleurs de ce pays
qui sont à la retraite pour avoir un
réhaussement de cette pension minimum
personne n'est en capacité aujourd'hui
de le faire j'entends de du gouvernement
qui va mettre en œuvre cette réforme et
ça fait plus qu'interroger deuxième
troisième élément pardon et je
rebondissais aussi ce qui avait dit
madame la sénatrice sur il y a une
évidence aujourd'hui j'entends que il y
a une amélioration de l'emploi quel type
d'emploi c'est extrêmement important
précaire le million de d'apprentis tant
mieux que les que les salariés que les
jeunes puissent participer au vie de
l'entreprise mais quel est quelle est la
réalité de de des emplois d'aujourd'hui
et du du de la baisse du chômage
aujourd'hui tous les cas de figure il y
a près de 6 millions de chômeurs si on
fait travailler plus longtemps les
anciens les jeunes n'auront pas de
travail avec tout ce que ça induit de ce
vous avez posé tout à l'heure c'est dire
la gravité du sujet et de la situation
sur la question des carrières longues
nous il y a un élément qui là devrait
être une mesure de JC sociale qui
devrait prendre en compte la totalité
des mesures des citoyens des salariés de
ce pays des procédants des congés
maternité paternité plus et mieux des
années d'études parce que quand on fait
des études c'est bien pour être
performant dans nos entreprises ensuite
et qui participent à l'activité du pays
aux richesses créées dans ce pays quand
on est contraint au chômage pourquoi il
y a la limitation et l'attaque qui a été
faite qui est d'une violence absolue où
là aussi toutes les organisations
syndicales étaient opposées ben là aussi
nous on considère que les notions de
validation pour le chômage et la valeur
et la maladie pardon devait être prise
en compte pour améliorer les carrières
longues dernière chose sur la question
de la pénibilité
priori pas que nous qui sommes dissipés
la question des critères la première
élément on l'a fait comme proposition la
notion de contrôle et de contrepartie
aux aides publiques c'est-à-dire que
c'est assez simple le budget est loué
nous vous demandons d'imposer de
contrôler de conditionner pour pour que
les corrections soient réalisées c'est
pas du plus en budget c'est une
possibilité et une main que vous avez
sur la pénibilité on a une approche
différente mais complémentaires les
salariés sont différents les
organisations syndicales aussi nous on
considère qu'il faut qu'il y ait un
trimestre validé par année d'exposition
aux critères de pénibilité limité à cinq
années voilà mais de quoi nous parlons
des femmes de ménage des travailleurs et
travailleuses en 3,8 en posté qui sont
confrontés aux produits chimiques c'est
à ces éléments là que nous discutons et
c'est un élément important pour avoir
enfin la possibilité d'une
une retraite descente pardon sur la
question de capitalisation je vous
rassure tout et tous si ce projet avance
évidemment elle aura lieu elle sera
subie pas choisie puisque les 300 et
quelques milliards d'euros versés chaque
année
aiguise les babines d'une partie de ceux
pour qui c'est un marché et alors que
pour nous c'est un bien commun
évidemment que la conséquence de ça ça
va induire des retraités extrêmement
pauvres voire de misère pour répéter le
propos qui a été dit précédemment et
ensuite des retraites moins défavorables
pour ceux qui pourront se les payer
c'est ça la société française que nous
voulons c'est ça les conséquences d'une
retraite de capitalisation ça serait
parce que tout le monde ne pourra pas se
la payer et on le voit aujourd'hui à
chaque fois que la protection sociale
est attaquée c'est comme ça que ça se
termine
et pour terminer moi je tiens à vous
remercier dommage que ce temps ne soit
pas plus long pour qu'on puisse
approfondir aboutir expliquer vous voyez
les nombres d'incompréhension et de
précision que nous avons les uns et les
autres à apporter pour avancer vous
savez je vais paraphraser une collègue
de la CFTC qui a dit la dernière fois à
l'Assemblée nationale que nous avons été
reçues en fait alors que les
travailleuses et les travailleurs les
salariés font tourner ce pays
qu'est-ce qu'on vous a fait et c'est pas
vous que je m'adresse mais d'abord au
Parlement pour nous infliger ce projet
merci de cette conclusion ensuite
oui oui
rapidement alors sur sur le minimum de
pension pour pour s'en souvenir bien
évidemment le minimum de potion doit
être égal à minima au SMIC puisque
effectivement quand on est le salaire
minimal c'est le SMIC on est à la
retraite on doit on doit pouvoir
bénéficier au moins de ce minima je
rappelle quand même que dans ce pays le
seul de pauvreté il est à 1102 euros
voilà et que beaucoup de retraités
aujourd'hui sont en deçà et j'en profite
pour pour effectivement
rappeler que 18% des Français en grande
pauvreté effectivement réside et bien
dans les outre-mer et que c'est pas
forcément un problème de retraite mais
c'est plutôt un problème de vie chère et
que il faut travailler sur ces
problématiques là il y a pas de raison
que les produits qui arrivent et qui
sont vendus dans les outre-mer soit
pratiquement 50% plus cher comme
métropole c'est d'abord me semble-t-il
qu'il faut travailler travailler sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat travailler
bien évidemment sur la pérennité des
emplois dans les outre-mer sur sur des
idées alors sur la retraite progressive
je l'ai déjà dit on ne souhaite pas que
ça fasse baisser les pensions des gens
mais il y avait quelque chose qui était
intéressant
d'ailleurs je l'avais proposé au
ministre du travail c'est de remettre en
place par exemple le contrat de
génération le contrat de génération n'a
pas fonctionné parce que les entreprises
n'ont pas voulu qu'il fonctionne et je
leur ai même dit sur le temps de la
plaisanterie même si c'est filmé je vais
le refaire que si le contrat de
génération était trop connoté François
Hollande il suffisait de changer son nom
voilà mais en tout cas on pouvait le
remettre on pouvait on pouvait le
remettre on pouvait le remettre on
pouvait le remettre en place bien
évidemment mon organisation est opposée
à la capitalisation la capitalisation si
elle est subie et quand on regarde là où
il y a des pensions basées sur la
capitalisation un krach boursier il se
passe quoi que ce soit économiquement
vous avez une systématique des pensions
il a qu'à regarder ce qui s'est passé
dans les pays nordiques qui étaient
donnés en exemple pendant un moment à
aujourd'hui ils reviennent tous tous ils
reviennent tous sur un autre système de
retraite parce que les pensions dès que
ça va pas elle baisse et que donc c'est
pas possible pour nous le meilleur
système à aujourd'hui c'est encore le
système le régime par répartition adossé
à côté avec la retraite complémentaire
retraite complémentaire gérée par les
interlocuteurs sociaux c'est ça
l'efficacité me semble-t-il voilà et
c'est des choses et non pas mettre un
chapeau de capitalisation qui il est
vrai ne profiterait que plus que plus
riche des des retraités enfin
[Musique]
de regarder de baisser d'un côté de 25%
l'indemnisation au chômage ou de vouloir
faire travailler les Français de plus
merci
là et pour compléter rapidement je vais
reprendre les éléments de Michel sur le
taux de chômage en particulier parce que
on voit bien que l'approche du corps est
très
synthétique et macro hein vu qu'ils
partent du PIB d'évolution de la
productivité et du taux de chômage mais
taux de chômage catégoria or la
situation de l'emploi ne peut pas se
résumer au taux de chômage catégoria vu
que vous avez les autres catégories de
chômage vous avez le halo du chômage
dont une étude récente de l'Insee a
montré qu'il ne baisse pas c'est 2
millions de personnes dans notre pays de
Halo du chômage et il n'a pas baissé
depuis cinq ans lui et puis et bien ce
qui compte c'est la masse salariale
après tout et il faut avoir nous on
n'est pas pour augmenter les cotisations
on pense les taux de cotisations parce
que c'est pas nécessaire mais c'est la
masse salariale qui doit augmenter via
un partage de la valeur rééquilibré via
une gouvernance plus responsable des
entreprises et ça va faire le lien
directement avec la capitalisation parce
que là comme on dit il faut travailler
sur l'emploi le travail
souvent de parler des retraites et
parler aussi des transitions et des
évolutions que ça va avoir qui vont être
structurelles sur notre vie notre
organisation de l'activité économique et
de la vie de nos concitoyens et bien il
faut d'abord établir une gouvernance
responsable des entreprises avant de
pouvoir parler de capitalisation parce
qu'on pourrait se dire nous on l'avait
évoqué ça pourrait permettre de
reprendre pied dans le capital de nos
grandes entreprises et ça on y est
plutôt favorable mais il faut d'abord
mettre les
l'encadrements au niveau de la
gouvernance des entreprises et au niveau
de la finance pour que tout ça soit géré
de matière manière responsable parce que
aujourd'hui les retraites par
capitalisation sont un frein à
l'investissement des entreprises vu que
les grandes entreprises préfèrent
distribuer des dividendes faire
augmenter le cours de l'action plutôt
qu'investir je citerai une citation de
Monsieur larryfing patron de BlackRock
qui avait pris l'habitude d'envoyer une
lettre tous les ans au directeur
généraux des entreprises dont il est
actionnaires y compris en France et qui
au mois de mai a déclaré ben non ce
n'est pas aux entreprises d'investir
dans les transitions
écologique
énergétiques etc donc pareil toujours
pourquoi c'est à l'état de financer oui
donc on continue à privatiser les
profits et à mutualiser les pertes parce
que c'était il était sous la pression de
fond de pension qui sont ces principaux
clients voilà donc la capitale pourquoi
pas marginalement parce que notre
système est le mieux établi mais avec
ces conditions là d'abord je vous
citerai un exemple allez demander à nos
collègues de la tecoère dont on envisage
de délocaliser les emplois alors que
l'origine elle est toute neuve elle
était construite en 2018 et ben c'est un
fond de pension qui est actionnaire
fond d'investissement dont les fonds de
pension sur actionnaires donc on voit
bien que un système de retraite ne peut
pas tenir si votre système de retraite a
pour objectif de vous faire virer de
votre entreprise parce que il faut
sortir des résultats et d'ailleurs j'en
reviens à un dernier point sur les
comparaisons internationales de même
qu'on a dit que les âges qui étaient
cités ne sont pas comparables parce que
c'est pas les mêmes indicateurs en fait
et bien sûr le poids dans le PIB c'est
pareil parce que quand vous êtes un
régime majoritairement capitalisation vu
qu'on compare les cotisations et bien le
but d'un régime par capitalisation c'est
de cotiser entre guillemets pas trop
pour que ça soit le rendement des
capitaux qui génère le capital en fin de
carrière pour avoir une retraite donc on
voit bien et tout ça se fait au
détriment des investissements et de dans
la transition
écologique en particulier et j'en viens
sur le taux de natalité parce
qu'effectivement il faut revenir je
pense qu'un objectif de notre pays doit
être de renouveler ses générations pas
d'avoir une démographie croissante mais
au moins de renouveler ces générations
et pour ça faut traiter les causes de
petit pénalise la natalité aujourd'hui
alors c'est d'abord beaucoup de
précarité chez les jeunes et d'ailleurs
ça me permet de revenir quand vous êtes
travailleur des plateformes alors
d'abord vous cotisez peu pour la
retraite et vous serez rattrapé par la
solidarité plus tard effectivement c'est
une des
anomalies qui se construit dans la vie
active et qui pénalisent notre système
de retraite et ça fera le corriger ok
pourquoi pour qu'on soit indépendant
pour entrer dans l'emploi etc pendant
une période limitée mais pas pour
travailler 5 ans ou 10 ans dans ce
statut qui fait que vous cotisez pas et
vous êtes un incapable de vous
construire un projet de vie et donc bah
oui bah pas de projet familial pas
d'enfant pareil pour l'anxiété
écologique et bien il faut y remédier et
je pense que le gouvernement aurait bien
mieux à faire à travailler sur ces
sujets qui sont vraiment
urgents
sociétalement plutôt que d'un travail
sur une réforme de retraite
inutile injuste et brutale voilà
juste un point non non parce que je
viens de voir que c'est en train de
sortir un peu sur Twitter l'ensemble des
organisations médicales participant à
l'intersyndical ce sont adressés aux
députés pour recevrez probablement dans
la matinée ce même courrier qui vous
sera adressé à tous individuellement
voilà
en tout cas merci
et la deuxième ouais le courrier était
adressé ce matin mais juste en
transmission entre les deux auditions
l'histoire retiendra peut-être que c'est
pendant le l'audition des organisations
syndicales au Sénat que la pétition
intercerdicale a franchi la barre du
million de signataires ce matin donc
c'est un petit symbole
mais chers collègues
voilà
bon allez on se calme on se calme nous
avons encore les organisations
patronales en tout cas merci à vous
quatre un de cet échange musclé au
départ mais néanmoins indispensable pour
nous et pour vous je pense merci
beaucoup
mes chers collègues nous continuons s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît
nous consacrons cette matinée à
l'audition de partenaires sociaux sur le
projet de loi retraite comme ça comme je
l'ai dit toutes les organisations ont
été entendues par nos rapporteurs mais
j'ai souhaité que nous conduisions
également cet exercice en réunion
plénière après avoir entendu les
organisations syndicales nous entendons
à présent
les représentants des organisations
patronales et j'indique l'u2p m'a fait
savoir qu'elle ne pouvait être
représentée nous entendons donc
Diane de Perroy du Medef Monsieur Eric
chevet vice-président en charge des
affaires sociales de la CPAM
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat je vais donner la parole à nos
intervenants afin qu'ils exposent
brièvement les principales observations
de l'organisation qu'il représente sur
ce texte avant qu'un débat ne s'engage
avec nos rapporteurs et les abdos René
Paul Savary et Sylvie Vermeillet qui a
présente la commission des finances puis
avec nos commissaires je vous laisse la
parole qui commence madame de Perroy
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
rapports tristes et mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs donc comme vous m'y
invitez je vais faire une synthèse sur
notre position
écouter notre notre position sur le
texte que vous allez examiner
prochainement
est une position où nous avons exprimé
un avis globalement positif saluant une
réforme courageuse et équilibrée qui
doit permettre de préserver durablement
l'équilibre du système de retraite par
répartition
nous constatons qu'il n'y a pas de
recette miracle et que si on souhaite
assurer l'avenir de ce modèle social
tout en maintenant le pouvoir d'achat
des actifs et des retraités il s'agit de
travailler plus longtemps
et si nous ne faisons rien et bien nous
allons laisser la situation de se
dégrader ce qui n'est ni souhaitable ni
tenable dans le temps ni soutenable dans
le temps dans un contexte économique
très incertain et puis avec un contexte
de déficit public qui n'ont jamais été
aussi élevés d'ailleurs je me permettrai
de rappeler que
tous les ans l'état injecte environ 30
milliards qui n'apparaissent pas dans
les projections financières mais qui
permettent de financer le déficit
structurel des régimes publics liés aux
déséquilibre démographiques et au
maintien de règles de calcul spécifique
dans le cadre des sujets de régime
public donc en fait par rapport à ce qui
peut être dit et présenter
nous pensons que le besoin de
financement et
supérieur à celui qui est présenté
aujourd'hui voilà nous comprenons
également que il y a des mesures
d'accompagnement à cette réforme avec
des mesures de d'ajustement mais que ces
mesures évidemment viennent réduire
quelque part le rendement net de la
réforme et qu'il s'agit d'être vigilant
à ce sujet de façon à ce que cette
réforme puisse apporter le bénéfice
attendu nous sommes tout à fait en
compréhension que c'est légitime d'avoir
une série de mesures d'accompagnement
pour atténuer l'impact de la réforme
envisagée sur les populations que l'on
peut peut-être qualifier des plus
précaires je fais allusion au micro
les populations aussi dont la carrière
professionnelle ou l'état de santé
justifie des carrières longues il y a eu
beaucoup ce sujet dans les débats
récemment et puis l'état de santé nous
pensons particulièrement aux populations
inapte Invalides travailleurs handicapés
ou des salariés exposés à des métiers à
usure élevés
voilà nous avons noté également que le
projet de texte entérine la suppression
progressive des régimes spéciaux c'est
un point important que nous qualifions
de de mesures de justice d'un point que
nous attendions et nous avons noté
également dans le projet
l'abandon du transfert de recouvrement
des cotisations agir Carco vers les
Urssaf c'est une mesure qui a été
demandée unanimement par les
organisations syndicales et les
organisations patronales voilà nous
avons souligné aussi le fait que les
mécanismes de transition emploi retraite
qui peuvent être les mécanismes de
retraite progressive ou du cumul emploi
retraite sont des mécanismes retenus et
ce sont des demandes que nous avions
donc nous sommes favorables à les
trouver dans le système que nous voyons
tel qu'il est présenté en termes de
projets je ferai deux incidents de
complémentaires l'une sur l'usure au
travail nous avons noté qu'il y a des
mesures d'évolution autour des droits
qui au titre du compte de prévention
enfin professionnelle de prévention le
C2P et puis le dispositif verte Bertrand
il y a aussi création d'un mécanisme
pour la prise en compte de troubles
musculo-squelettiques avec un volet
prévention et je tiens à rappeler que
les partenaires sociaux avec mon Éric
chevet à ma droite de la CPME nous avons
négocié un accord interprofessionnel sur
la santé au travail en 2020 traduit par
une loi sur la santé au travail et nous
avions particulièrement à coeur de
travailler le volet prévention donc nous
notons que le montant envisagé est de 1
milliard et nous avons bien noté aussi
ce filtre médical sur la réparation
auquel nous tenons deux remarques
là-dessus
il nous paraît important que les métiers
les plus exposés
ne soient pas des métiers qui procèdent
du négociation de branches
professionnelles mais bien que ce soit
la caisse ATMP la branche ATMP qui soit
au cœur de cette désignation parce que
il nous semble que c'est véritablement
son métier donc ça c'est un premier
sujet qui nous paraît important et le
deuxième sujet c'est qu'il ne vous aura
pas échappé que il y a une négociation
entre les organisations syndicales les
organisations patronales en ce moment
sur la branche ATMP et que pour nous il
est important que cette négociation
puisse fonctionner une autre remarque
c'est que il est mentionné qu'il y aura
un filtre médical et il est mentionné
que ce soit le médecin du travail qui
parle de ce qui rendent un avis sur ce
filtre médical il nous paraît important
que ce ne soit pas
le médecin du travail en fait bien sûr
celui-ci a un rôle très important
d'ailleurs nous l'avons consacré dans le
cas de nos discussions et notre ani
santé au travail et nous avons même
instauré une visite de mi carrière et on
voit bien que la visite de fin de
carrière peut être très importante dans
cette dimension de santé au travail mais
la reconnaissance d'un avis d'une
potentielle inaptitude pour nous ce ne
doit pas être le médecin du travail mais
la réparation doit relever des médecins
de la sécurité sociale et ça nous paraît
quelque chose de très important voilà je
tiens juste à souligner que nous n'avons
pas été à l'origine de l'échange de
cotisations entre la cotisation ATMP et
la cotisation retraite nous n'avons
jamais demandé cet échange qui figure
dans le projet de réforme
enfin je pense que pour nous c'est
important que nous soyons très clair
là-dessus nous serons particulièrement
vigilants sur la façon dont ça se
déroulera de façon à ce que on soit en
pleine équivalence et pas si ceci doit
avoir lieu et pas avec un déséquilibre
et sachez que je le mentionnais tout à
l'heure il est important de laisser à la
démocratie sociale sont
le chant des changes or ce projet vient
évidemment percuté ma deuxième remarque
est sur l'index seniors je voudrais
juste rappeler que nous n'y sommes pas
favorables parce que sur le premier
remarque c'est qu'il nous semble que
l'index égalité homme-femme est un index
qui repose sur des obligations légales
figurant dans le code du travail ce
projet d'index senior n'a pas de socle
et la deuxième remarque que je ferais
c'est que les entreprises quelle que
soit leur taille des plus petites au
plus grandes et bien sont des
entreprises avec des démographies très
hétérogènes des activités très
hétérogènes des tailles très différentes
l'ancienneté de l'entreprise peut
conditionner aussi la démographie donc
nous ne pouvons pas être dans une
démarche monolithique
de la même façon le reproche que nous
souhaitons exprimer c'est que nous
n'avons pas de visibilité sur son
fonctionnement et nous attirons votre
attention sur le fait que il ne faudrait
pas que nous regardions un pourcentage
de seniors et que celui-ci recule parce
que une entreprise a décidé
de recruter des apprentis de tutoriel
davantage d'apprentis etc enfin pensons
à l'équilibre général du sujet et à la
différence des entreprises et des
indicateurs monolithiques nous ne voyons
pas comment ça peut être possible en
revanche s'il devait y avoir un index
avoir des indicateurs définis au niveau
des branches quelque part étant maîtrisa
par l'entreprise étant regarder au sein
de l'entreprise dans une dynamique qui
appartient à l'entreprise c'est
peut-être quelque chose qui peut se
regarder mais de grâce regardons ça sur
des tailles d'entreprises significatives
plus nous allons dans une dynamique de
descente sur des petites entreprises
plus tout bêtement le sujet de la loi
des grands nombres ne peut pas
s'appliquer donc le seuil de 300 nous
paraît absolument indispensable à
observer mon camarade de
à ma gauche il reviendra peut-être voilà
et puis bien évidemment si on devait
avoir une sanction avec une appréciation
uniforme des entreprises ça nous paraît
absolument impossible de notre côté je
crois véritablement et je voudrais vous
en faire part lors des concertations
auxquelles nous avons été conviés par le
gouvernement nous avons beaucoup insisté
sur la dimension d'employabilité des
seniors et nous avons proposé à cette
occasion là et je ne sais pas si ça a
été partagé peut-être dans le cas d'une
audition préalable avec certains d'entre
vous mais sur l'importance de faire un
bilan de compétences l'importance aussi
des entretiens professionnels qui est
une dimension qui a été instaurée il y a
quelques années avec des entretiens tous
les deux ans et que ce socle nous para
important pour être travaillé avec
peut-être un entretien professionnel
particulièrement autour de du moment où
on doit envisager la deuxième partie de
la carrière c'est là dedans dans ce type
d'entretien qu'on met le sujet de
l'employabilité au cœur de l'entreprise
que ce soit pour l'employeur ou que ce
soit pour les salariés et il nous
apparaît très important de pouvoir avoir
ce dialogue parce que c'est là que l'on
parle de la formation et de
l'employabilité donc je j'apporte
beaucoup d'attention là-dessus et le
Medef y est tout à fait favorable de la
même façon d'avoir des priorités pour
les salariés au-delà alors je ne sais
pas c'est 45 ans 50 ans mais sur l'accès
aux dispositif de transition et de
reconversion professionnelle ça nous
paraît très important et n'oublions pas
que dans la loi santé au travail nous
avons instauré les partenaires sociaux
os comme op tous ensemble le fait qu'il
y ait une visite qui peut
la prévention de la désinsertion
professionnelle et qu'il y a un double
cadre autour de la santé au travail et
autour de l'employabilité la vie dans
l'entreprise et bien ça nous paraît être
tout à fait vertueux et d'engager les
entreprises quel que soit leur taille
sur cette dynamique de la seconde partie
de carrière voilà ce qui doit pouvoir
être fait et puis nous avons vu aussi
qu'il y avait un projet de taxation des
indemnités de rupture avant la retraite
je tiens juste à dire que ce dispositif
qui doit avoir à peu près 15 ans
maintenant
et bien et souvent plébiscité par les
salariés elles ne sont pas ce ne sont
pas que les entreprises qui sont à
l'origine de ce sujet là et donc il faut
être vigilant de façon à ce que ce
dispositif et bien ne puisse plus
fonctionner ce sont des procédures
simples ce sont des ruptures à l'ami
pour beaucoup d'entre elles c'est
flexible et c'est beaucoup plus
protecteur qu'une simple démission donc
nous attirons votre attention sur cette
mesure qui pourrait freiner les
embauches par ricochet voilà ce que je
souhaitais dire sur cette synthèse
autour de ce projet qui nous rassemble
aujourd'hui dans cette salle merci
beaucoup à tous de votre attention merci
madame monsieur chevet pour la CPME oui
merci madame la Présidente bonjour
madame lesinatrices messieurs les
sénateurs et merci à Diane d'avoir été
très complète sur la présentation ou sur
laquelle évidemment la CME partage
partage beaucoup de points
sur l'équilibre global qui en fait le
démarrage de la réforme l'équilibre
global la CME et depuis tout temps très
inquiète sur l'évolution de l'équilibre
global du régime
à moyenne échéance et aussi échéance
puisque quand on regarde les projections
du corps évidemment on a un problème à
moyenne échéance et c'est ce qu'on
essaye de traiter par cette réforme mais
on voit aussi qu'on a un problème à
longue échéance qui n'apparaît pas très
clairement mais qui vient en fait du
fait que à l'avenir les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui auront des taux de
remplacement bien plus bas que les taux
de que les taux de remplacement
d'aujourd'hui et donc aujourd'hui c'est
ce pays sur la retraite de de nos jeunes
demain l'équilibre global du système et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la CME
souhaitait dans un premier analyse aller
jusqu'à 65 ans pour le report de large
la proposition qui est faite pourquoi 65
ans parce que nous pensions
effectivement qu'un reculent de l'âge
aussi élevé nécessité beaucoup de
mesures d'accompagnement et évidemment
des dérogations possibles à tous ces cas
l'équilibre qui est proposé dans le
texte que le gouvernement a mis sur la
table nous paraît le bon puisque il
permet à la fois de rétablir l'équilibre
à moyen terme de du régime du système de
retraite pour être plus large du système
de retraite et dans le même temps
d'embarquer un certain nombre de mesures
de solidarité qui nous paraissent
absolument essentiel je citerai 4 qui
nous nous
interpelle ou du moins nous que nous
accompagnons très clairement à la CPME
alors il y a évidemment le dispositif
d'usure professionnelle j'y reviendrai
parce que pour nous c'est vraiment la
création d'un droit nouveau un droit à
la prévention de l'usure professionnelle
qui n'existe pas actuellement dans le
code du travail et qui est une novation
qu'apporterait le texte qui est qui est
aujourd'hui qui vous est soumis
aujourd'hui j'y reviendrai parce que
c'est un sujet pour la CPME très
important et qui est très lié au
dispositif de carrière longue auquel
nous sommes aussi très attachés le
deuxième point effectivement c'est
question des minima de pension avec la
possibilité pour toutes les carrières
complètes
passer et à venir de bénéficier d'une
pension qui soit au moins égale à 85%
d'un SMIC pour une carrière complète et
nous avons fait dans ce sens au cours
des échanges de concertation avec le
gouvernement nous avons fait des
propositions pour faire en sorte
d'accompagner l'équilibre global de la
réforme pour faire en sorte que tout le
monde toutes les catégories d'actifs
puissent en profiter et je pense
spécialement au commerçants ou aux
artisans qui en sont aujourd'hui très
éloignés le troisième point concerne les
modalités de modalités les points 3 et 4
concernent deux modalités qui sont
prises sur la durée et qui sont
extrêmement importantes en termes de
solidarité et d'équilibre aussi de la
réforme c'est la question de
l'annulation de la décode qui reste à 67
ans c'est un point sur lequel nous nous
étions aussi à la CPME
très allant pour éviter d'avoir un
report puisque quand on reporte l'âge
légal reporte toutes les bornes le fait
de maintenir à soi cette sept ans est
une mesure que nous trouvons
particulièrement équitables et surtout
plus encore quatrième point la question
de l'invalidité incapacité qui maintient
un départ à 62 ans deux ans avant et qui
nous qui est absolument indispensable de
notre point de vue en relation notamment
avec ce nouveau dispositif de prévention
de l'usure professionnelle qui pourrait
permettre de corriger des situations
inéquitables en permettant un départ
anticipé pour les catégories exposées
enfin avant de d'approfondir deux points
évidemment le les dispositifs de
facilitation de cumul emploi retraite et
de retraites progressive sont tout à
fait intéressants à développer dans les
entreprises ou dire que pour les TPE PME
nous pensons plus que de la nécessité de
garder un cumul emploi retraite plutôt
que la retraite progressive mais c'est
un objectif qui peut être aussi utilisé
dans les TPE PME généralement les
compétences on les garde le plus
longtemps possible et donc on les garde
généralement jusqu'au bout et peut-être
pouvoir les conserver après notamment
dans une période de transmission de
connaissances mais plutôt après là je
d'ouverture des droits nous paraîtrait
tout à fait intéressant nous sommes
bloqués sur ce sujet je tiens le
rappeler par la disposition qui interdit
de reprendre chez le même employeur
pendant une période de six mois une
franchise de 6 mois avant de revenir
chez le même employeur et donc nous
avons soumis quelques propositions sur
sur ce sujet et nous aimerions bien que
ça se puisse être corrigé je reviens sur
le dispositif effectivement usure
professionnel qui nous paraît avec
évidemment ou à côté en parallèle des
améliorations sur le C2P qui nous paraît
être un point essentiel et que sur
lequel nous avons beaucoup travaillé à
PME en collaboration ou en échange avec
le gouvernement pourquoi parce que nos
chefs d'entreprise sont évidemment aussi
impliqués
que leurs salariés dans les petites
entreprises dans l'artisanat les chefs
d'entreprise sont aussi impliqués sur
ces questions d'usure professionnelles
et ils voient en direct sur les
chantiers chez les clients dans les
marchés il voit bien les difficultés que
présentent certains métiers et l'usure
attachés et donc il nous paraissait
important sans rentrer dans j'allais
dire l'usine à gaz
qu'on avait connu à l'époque du C2P sur
les critères supplémentaires d'inventer
un nouveau dispositif qui puisse prendre
en compte cette usure qui est une usure
réelle et de l'intégrer dans un
dispositif nouveau de d'usure
professionnelle c'est ce que fait la
proposition de le projet de loi qui est
sur la table et nous retrouvons notre
compte petite nuance nous nous pensons
que dans ce domaine les branches
professionnelles pourraient
effectivement si elles souhaite si elle
le souhaite se saisir de cette question
là et de regarder quels sont
objectivement dans chacune des branches
professionnelles les métiers qui sont
exposés et sur ce sujet
c'est vrai que c'est le rôle aussi
d'avoir au niveau de la commission
action du travail maladie
professionnelle une vision d'ensemble
sur l'ensemble des métiers et notamment
de pouvoir comparer en toute en toute
équité entre les branches
professionnelles d'avoir des dispositifs
avec de la cohérence mais il nous
n'écluons pas la possibilité pour les
branches de donner leur avis sur sur ce
sujet là et évidemment le dispositif
prévoit avec la visite de mille carrière
qu'on avait prévu dans notre accord sur
la santé au travail
cherdiane le dispositif prévoit qu'au
autour de 45 ans il doit y avoir une
réflexion sur l'état physique psychique
mental formation de
du salarié de façon à faire en sorte
qu'il puisse aborder correctement la
seconde partie de carrière et qu'on
puisse aller le plus longtemps possible
rester le plus longtemps possible actif
nous nous travaillons en ce moment entre
partenaires sociaux effectivement à un
accord national interprofessionnel sur
la TMP les actions du travail maladie
professionnelle dans lequel nous avons
mis comme pour la santé au travail en
premier point la prévention de des de la
prévention de la santé au travail la
santé et les accidents aussi les
accidents et la santé au travail et
évidemment nous avons besoin que ce
dispositif que qui est sur la table
puisse être en fait accompagné dans un
échange entre ce que nous négocions au
niveau des partenaires sociaux et ce
qu'il y aura dans la future loi retraite
si elle va son terme donc du coup on est
dans un dispositif
cohérent en phase avec la réflexion des
partenaires sociaux en ce moment sur sur
la question de l'usure professionnelle
et du traitement des secondes parties de
carrière c'est un point essentiel on
peut imaginer demain que notre objectif
très clairement pour être très clair
notre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
que la prévention supplante la
réparation aujourd'hui on répare
énormément mais on ne sait pas
correctement prévenir le risque d'usure
professionnelle et c'est ça en fait que
nous visons dans notre négociation ATMP
et que nous retrouvons pour partie sur
le dispositif
usurprofessionnel avec évidemment une
attention particulière c'est une incise
mais importante sur les carrières
longues nous sommes nous très favorables
à la CME de tenir compte effectivement
de la durée de la de l'exposition à la
carrière sans que sur ce sujet ça soit
ça soit non plus un juge de paix puisque
carrière longue ne veut pas dire
inéquité et les études du corps sont
très claires là-dessus ne veut pas dire
inéquité sur la durée de vie à la
retraite et notamment en bonne santé la
vraie différence et vous le savez c'est
sur l'invalidité et l'incapacité où il y
a effectivement une une diminution de la
durée de vie en bonne santé à la
retraite et donc c'est pour ça qu'il
était important de maintenir la borne à
62 ans sur ces dispositifs là un dernier
mot pour conclure avant que ne vous
laissez évidemment sur l'index senior
vous dire que un peu comme le disait
Diane de Perroy tout de suite
nous sommes pas défavorables à l'idée
d'observer et d'avoir des indicateurs
qui nous permettent d'apprécier dans les
branches et dans les entreprises
quels sont voilà quels sont les
évolutions sociologiques de nos
populations sal dans nos entreprises
bien évidemment ce que
ce que nous avons dit dès le début sur
ce sujet là c'est que malheureusement
les les imaginations sont parfois
débordantes et donc du coup à partir de
la création d'un simple index derrière
on imagine bien tout ce que ça peut
entraîner et nous ne l'avons connu dans
d'autres dans d'autres démarches un peu
similaires la preuve c'est que le
premier texte prévoyait de réserver au
dessus de 300 salariés et ça avait du
sens pourquoi ça avait du sens parce que
les informations qui sont celles de la
bdse la banque de données sociales
environnementale des économiques des
entreprises et plus complètes dans les
plus de 300 salariés et du coup la
constitution d'un index ne nécessitait
pas forcément de travail complémentaire
extraordinaire en revanche quand on
descend dans les 5300 salariés le seuil
a été baissé à 50 salariés nous sommes
là dans une situation
ou on risque de demander à des PME qui
en plus n'ont pas forcément les services
RH adéquats de recréer de la donnée pour
pouvoir derrière construire ses index
donc franchement nous ne pensons pas que
ça soit une avancée déterminante que
d'avoir rebaissé à 50 salariés la
création de cette index senior voilà les
deux points sur lesquels je voulais
conclure Madame la Présidente c'est
Elisabeth Doisneau ensuite nos deux
autres rapporteurs et on aura
5 6 collègues merci Madame présidente
merci à l'un et l'autre de votre propos
liminaire nous on a eu l'opportunité
déjà de vous rencontrer donc on va
laisser la main à nos collègues
simplement peut-être deux éléments à
comment dirais-je à préciser d'abord sur
les effets financiers de la réforme
est-ce que mais vous l'avez dit est-ce
que le diagnostic du gouvernement est
je dirais le plus le plus adéquat pour
arriver à l'équilibre financier du
système de retraite est-ce que le fait
d'avoir choisi un taux de 4,5% de de
chômage et prudent ou pas et un taux de
croissance à 1% là encore est-ce que
vous avez comment des choses à nous dire
l'équilibre atteint en l'état actuel des
débats parlementaires vous semblent-ils
satisfaisant pour assurer la viabilité
du système de retraite mais là c'est
vrai qu'on est en plein débat et on voit
bien que on est sur des sables mouvants
euh y a-t-il des points particuliers sur
lesquels vous souhaitez insister mais je
pense que vous l'avez fait d'ores et
déjà sur les cotisations on a eu
l'occasion de recevoir hier la branche
ATMP mais ma collègue Pascal grünic est
très au fait de de ce secteur de cette
branche en particulier aura certainement
des questions mais est-ce qu'il de votre
point de vue est-ce que le transfert en
fait de cotisation prévue pour 2024
entre la branche ATMP et la branche os
dont l'annonce intervient alors que
comme vous l'avez dit les partenaires
sociaux sont en pleine négociation
interprète interprofessionnel sur la
branche est-ce que ça vous semble bien
judicieux
très bien prenez pas le Savary oui merci
on est tout à fait d'accord sur ces le
travail sur la prévention puisque plutôt
que la réparation sur l'usure sauf que
cette différence de traitement entre le
C2P qui peut éventuellement y répondre
pour les facteurs quels facteurs en ce
qui concerne les troubles et
ergonomiques ce qui est proposé c'est
vraiment un système de réparation plus
que de prévention quand même comment
vous voyez comment on pourrait
rapprocher les deux dispositifs vous ne
voulez pas intégrer
et le gouvernement non plus les
dispositifs
ergonomiques on a compris bon mais
comment on pourrait faire un
dispositif parallèle quoi
voilà vous savez mieux que d'autres ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour arriver à ça
et je pense que ce serait véritablement
une avancée mais en restant peut-être
au droit actuel
pas décalé forcément à 62 ans il y a des
choses qui peuvent peut-être rester à 60
ans parce que ça prendrait peut-être
mieux en compte ce problème d'usure que
de le décaler sur les âges et puis bon
hormis l'index il y en a beaucoup qui
disent les entreprises sont fort aidées
c'est très forme elle est plus faite
pour les salariés que pour les
entreprises et en conséquence il serait
tout à fait normal que les aides aux
entreprises soient conditionnées
justement à
un engagement par rapport au Seigneur et
notamment de non licenciements qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez et puis est-ce que on
rétablit le contrat de
génération améliorer ce que vous avez
une idée là-dessus et puis on refait un
contrat de génération
21e siècle
si vous avez des idées on est preneur et
précisez moi quand même
votre position par rapport à l'index là
vous dites que dans finalement l'index
vous l'acceptez alors que jusqu'à
présent vous étiez pas très enclin à
l'accepter enfin j'ai cru comprendre des
fois je comprends pas tout mais j'ai cru
comprendre donc maintenant qu'il existe
plus
vous êtes tout à fait enclin à
l'accepter donc à 300 donc l'index à 300
ça vous paraît acceptable si j'ai bien
compris et il me semble que vous
privilégiez plutôt
les le rôle des commissions ATMP que les
critères établis par les branches
préciser un peu votre position par
rapport par rapport à cela merci
madame le Président j'aurais juste une
question donc madame monsieur vous avez
parlé de la nécessité de travailler plus
longtemps
concernant l'emploi senior vous avez
parlé d'entretien de bilan de
compétences en fait vous avez plutôt
expliqué ce que vous vouliez pas mais
vous nous avez assez mal dit quelles
sont les mesures concrètes qui
pourraient favoriser l'emploi des
seniors donc j'aimerais savoir vous
entendre sur ce point merci on va
continuer avec les questions
des rapporteurs à la Milan
oui merci Madame présente Madame
Monsieur Merci pour vos interventions
tout d'abord une petite remarque je sais
que je vais me faire huer mais je
regrette que les gants de la que les
grands de la gauche soient clairsemés au
moment de votre édition j'aurais aimé
que nous soyons tous présents afin de
pouvoir vous auditionner au mieux
cela dit cela dit cela dit n'empêche que
non pas du tout
cela dit maintenant donc je vais me
faire applaudir par la gauche
vous avez dit Madame nous avons
auditionné les organisations syndicales
salariés tout à l'heure il y a eu des
propos intéressants des propositions
intéressantes et des propos un peu plus
perturbants vous avez eu en ce qui me
concerne vous madame à propos qui m'a
perturbé vous avez dit que l'État
injecté 30 milliards en semblant
regretté que ces 30 milliards soient
injectés par l'État est-ce que vous
regrettez de la même façon les
exonérations sociales parce que au bout
du compte cesations sociales pourraient
permettre vous voyez comme quoi vous
allez m'applaudir maintenant
est-ce que est-ce que
est-ce que si ces exonérations sociales
étaient supprimées il y aurait un impact
sur l'emploi et quel impact sur l'emploi
merci merci madame la Présidente alors
très rapidement je vais vous poser la
même question que j'ai posé aux
organisations syndicales des salariés
tout à l'heure un certain nombre de nos
collègues députés dans notre collective
Juvin propose de mettre en place un
régime additionnel et d'introduire une
part de capitalisation dans le système
quel est votre une part obligatoire de
capitalisation quel est votre votre avis
là-dessus et la deuxième question alors
c'est vrai que l'enjeu des de l'emploi
et de préserver l'emploi des seniors et
est une chose l'enjeu d'embaucher des
seniors est aussi une chose Oriane outil
qui existe qui est à l'échelle
expérimentale je crois que le Medef
n'était pas très favorable et j'aimerais
quand même avoir votre avis c'est le CDI
d'employabilité qui permet aux
entreprises d'externaliser leur main
d'oeuvre sur le long terme tout en sont
conservant la flexibilité de l'intérim
est-ce que ça serait pas une solution
pour éventuellement embaucher des
seniors qui en aurait bien besoin dans
le cadre de la réforme qui s'annonce
la présidente moi je voudrais vous poser
une question qui me taraude qui sera
courte on entend tous les jours les
revendications des organisations
syndicales on vous a peu ou pas entendu
pourquoi c'est une question que j'ai
posée à un membre de la CPME à Toulouse
qui a pas été foutu de me répondre
c'était à Toulouse c'est à Toulouse
Véronique Guillotin oui merci j'avais
deux questions une ça va être très court
puis ça reprend la question de Sylvie
Vernier concernant les solutions faites
concrètes pour maintenir l'employabilité
on entend bien qu'on c'est le sujet
principal c'est comment maintenir dans
l'emploi les personnes à partir d'un
certain âge les critères les indicateurs
les déclarations les petites moyennes
enfin les tailles d'entreprise vous
qu'est-ce que vous proposez concrètement
en fait pour arriver à maintenir les
emplois le plus longtemps possible et
c'est pas une question mais c'est
peut-être un fond de réflexion j'entends
beaucoup parler de prévention moi j'y
suis forcément très attaché je pense que
la piste en fait pour maintenir
quelqu'un dans l'emploi et et j'allais
dire peut-être voir l'emploi sous un
autre jour aujourd'hui parce que c'est
un c'était quand même un choc c'était un
choc confrontation entre les deux
auditions et je crois qu'il faut qu'on
renoue effectivement avec le travail je
pense que le travail j'ai pas que ne
doit pas être que le bagne alors il y a
des métiers où c'est plus simple à
comprendre que que pour d'autres pour
autant je pense qu'il faut qu'on
travaille sur ce sur cette piste là et
dans la prévention j'ai pas compris ce
que vous entendez parler en termes de
prévention j'ai l'impression que c'est
toujours sur l'accident de travail etc
mais par exemple quel piste
pourriez-vous pourrions-nous proposer en
termes de prévention alors moi je pense
à de l'activité physique pendant les
entreprises à proposer de l'accès à
certains services pour des personnes des
femmes avec enfants qui doivent
travailler et c'est pas que le travail
qui va être peut-être pénible c'est
j'emmène mes gamins à la crèche question
de mobilité les questions de service de
conciergerie enfin je sais pas alors on
va dire que sur les très grandes boîtes
c'est facile sauf que beaucoup de monde
travaillent dans des petites entreprises
et moi quand je dis ça je pense beaucoup
en fait aux personnes qui travaillent
par exemple dans les services d'aide à
la personne où on voit que c'est très
très compliqué et je suis conseillère
régional donc par ailleurs et on
travaille beaucoup sur poudre donc ces
métiers en tension sur les territoires
et on voit qu'on est obligé de faire de
la couture fine entre les collectivités
les boîtes qui emploient etc donc vous
en termes enfin voilà qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez proposer dans ce pour ce sujet là
très bien Nadia ce logo oui merci madame
la Présidente en fait c'est pas une
question c'est plutôt une remarque sur
les la retraite minimale à 85% du SMIC
pour les commerçants et artisans en fait
c'est le parallèle de ce qui a été fait
par la loi chassaine pour les
agriculteurs et d'ailleurs à l'époque on
avait dit que c'est pas très juste de le
faire pour les agriculteurs et pas pour
les autres mais juste petit retour
d'expérience parce que j'habite dans un
territoire rural en fait ça crée c'est
une mesure très vertueuse mais c'est
elle est très peu lisible et elle crée
beaucoup de frustration et
d'incompréhension parce qu'une fois que
toutes les retraites sont soldées il y
en a pour qui le fait d'arriver à ce
seuil des 85% du SMIC il y a une
augmentation et puis il y en a d'autres
qui l'ont et alors les gens moi ils
m'appellent tous les jours pour dire
finalement la retraite elle augmente
elle augmente pas en face et mon frère
s'est augmenté moi ça augmente pas c'est
c'est vertueux mais c'est compliqué et
ça crée beaucoup de frustration à la fin
merci madame la Présidente je vous
remercie Monsieur et Madame pour vos
propos mais je suis assez sidéré par
certaines choses que j'ai entendu parce
qu'en fait moi je suis de la Guadeloupe
et dans les autres maires il y a un fort
taux de chômage des jeunes et là je vais
reprendre ce que j'ai dit aux ordinaires
organisation syndicale je ne comprends
pas que vous puissiez vous focaliser
autant sur les seniors l'emploi à
l'accumulant trois retraites les
retraites progressifs je veux bien mais
je voudrais savoir ce que vous voulez
faire des jeunes parce que les jeunes
sont diplômés ils sont là pour la
plupart justement dans l'Hexagone ou
ailleurs tout simplement parce qu'ils ne
sont pas recrutés alors je voudrais
savoir quelles sont les mesures que vous
comptez prendre pour faciliter
évidemment la transmission des
connaissances et des valeurs des
entreprises des sentiments de
l'appartenance avec les aînés mais je
voudrais savoir ce que vous envisagez de
faire pour faciliter les recrutements
des jeunes d'autre part je voudrais
savoir également concern les femmes pour
croire vous qui représentez des
employeurs pourquoi les femmes ne sont
pas mieux payées mieux pris en compte
pourquoi vous ne valorisez pas les
femmes de façon générale parce que c'est
sidéré de la façon dont vous proposez un
certain nombre de mesures vous approuvez
c'est votre droit ce qui est mis en
place par ce gouvernement mais je crois
en tout cas que pour le territoire
d'outre-mer ce que vous comptez faire et
mettre en place et vous approuvez madame
ces mesures également vous l'avez dit
clairement
là la dégrade réversible qui attend nos
territoires je crois que vous devez
faire autrement et réorienter en tout
cas pour ce que vous pouvez votre façon
de voir parce que les usures
professionnelles vous en avez parlé vous
voulez à la limite cassée davantage les
anciens alors que les jeunes sont là ils
ne trouvent pas d'emploi ils sont
diplômés ils sont hors de leur
territoire
et sans qu'on leur sort qu'on leur
propose ce sont justement des minimas
sociaux et tout ce qui ne les valorise
pas alors moi je suis assez sidéré par
ce que vous représentez et ce que vous
proposez de continuer à représenter
vraiment de penser oui merci ma
présidente
alors écoutez puisqu'on est là puisqu'on
est resté quand même
Alain
pas tous vous avez commencé enfin en
qualifiant cette réforme de vous avez
commencé en qualifiant cette réforme de
deux qualificatif quel serait équilibrée
qu'elle serait couragueuse alors tout
d'abord équilibré quand même
reconnaissons et reconnaissés qu'elle
n'est pas du tout équilibrée pour ce qui
est des deux partenaires d'une branche
de sécurité sociale c'est paritaire
puisqu'elle pèse totalement à 100% sur
le travail donc je comprends que vous
vous appeliez ça équilibré mais moi
j'appelle ça très déséquilibré puisqu'il
y a rien absolument
d'efforts consentis enfin ou demander
plutôt pour les employeurs
courageuse là je vous rejoins parce que
il faut être courageux pour
effectivement
soutenir une réforme dont 93% des actifs
des actifs et pas des Français des
actifs sont absolument vent debout
contre dont une majorité aujourd'hui
malgré une un pouvoir d'achat une à la
peine malgré l'inflation malgré la
déflation salariale parce que en France
quand même les augmentations de salaire
ne suivent pas l'inflation donc il y a
une véritable déflation salariale une
majorité quand même dans ce contexte là
préfère préféreraient une augmentation
du taux de cotisation plutôt qu'une
augmentation de l'âge c'est ça la
réalité un petit peu du courage de cette
de cette réforme et moi je voudrais
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit sur la
prévention et sur la réparation dire que
la prévention devrait supplanter la
réparation certes mais il est quand même
aujourd'hui on répare et mal on réparé
mal l'exposition au risque de pénibilité
aux facteurs de pénibilité car
surplanté par la prévention ça serait
réduire l'exposition oui au lieu de
réparer l'exposition de deux ans
seulement c'est à dire maintenant 62 ce
qui était 60 quand même hier
est une chose vous êtes dans la
réparation enfin vous soutenez une
réforme de la réparation mais on vous
demande en rien de réduire l'exposition
et quand même moi je vais m'arrêter sur
quelques chiffres c'est important quand
même depuis 1984 tous les indicateurs
sont
sont mauvais de ce point de vue les
indicateurs d'exposition facteurs
pénibilité
les travailleurs au moins soumis à trois
contraintes physiques il est passé donc
84 aujourd'hui de 12% à
34%. avoir au moins trois contraintes de
rythme de 5,8% à 35,2 %. c'est à dire le
facteur de l'intensité du travail et de
la pression temporaire qui font aussi
des risques psychosociaux
la contrainte de devoir des normes de
production insatisfaire en une heure de
5% à 29%. tous les indicateurs explosent
et donc c'est cette exposition qu'il
faut réduire donc nous sommes loin loin
très loin parce que là rien ne vous
demande de mettre fin à une tendance à
l'intensification du travail qui font
aujourd'hui
les et quand vous dites qu'il y a pas de
lien enfin qui aurait pas de lien entre
la pénibilité espérance de vie en bonne
santé enfin je crois enfin j'ai du mal à
entendre quand même parce que celui qui
a l'épaule cassée etc Il par la retraite
et toujours cassé je conviens que pour
les risques psychosociaux
oui enfin casser pas forcément en
invalidité l'invalidité c'est 80%, on
peut être quand même avec les retraites
courtes enfin le risque de retraite
courte des salariés d'ouvriers non
qualifiés ou d'ouvriers actuellement
courte c'est-à-dire de moins de 10 ans
de retraite
dans des retraites très courtes de moins
de 5 ans dont des retraites encore plus
courtes quand on meurt avant ça sera
9000 de plus si vous voulez elle est
quand même de 17%, il y a 17% des gens
et beaucoup plus des ouvriers qualifiés
soumis à ces contraintes quoi alors dire
que ça a pas de lien avec
je constate juste les risques
psychosociaux qui si vous n'êtes pas si
vous n'avez si vous n'êtes pas rentré
quand même dans un risque de Burn Out
qui peut être durer sur plusieurs années
le risque psychosocial s'arrête quand on
s'arrête effectivement il n'a pas
forcément d'impact important sur la
pénibilité voilà donc moi
ce que je vous je vous dis au-delà du
fait que soutient pas cette cette vous
l'aurez bien compris cette réforme c'est
si vous voulez prévenir cessez
l'intensification du travail il y a
dégradation de tous les critères
d'exposition qui sont constatés depuis
1984 par toute et qui sont documentées
par l'adresse Lindsay tout ce que vous
voulez voilà
merci
Oliviero on va tout prendre oui merci
madame la Présidente merci pour vos
interventions pour ramasser mon propos
ma question concerne la politique
familiale et les finalement assez peu
évoqué alors même que nous sommes dans
un système par répartition et que le
système de répartition exige le
renouvellement des générations donc ma
question concerne
est assez direct concerne cette question
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
essentiel d'avoir des politiques
spécifiques sur la retraite pour inciter
à la natalité ou est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il vaudrait mieux aider les les
parents qui ont des jeunes enfants ou
est-ce que vous pensez par exemple que
la majoration de pensions de 5% dès le
deuxième enfant peut être pertinent
est-ce que vous imaginez des gestes en
faveur de la politique familiale à
l'occasion de cette réforme des
retraites je vous remercie
Michel meunier
ma question va être courte puisque mes
collègues Frédéric puissa et Véronique
Guillotin opposé la plupart de ce que je
voulais vous demander dans le domaine de
l'emploi des seniors moi je vous entends
avec beaucoup d'intérêt mais comment
est-ce que vous expliquez malgré tout
que seulement 33% des personnes actives
de plus de 55 ans sont dans l'emploi et
quels sont souvent les premières
concernées par des mesures de
restriction d'emplois ou des vagues de
licenciement donc c'était ma question
voilà en complément de toutes celles qui
ont pu être posées auparavant sur ce
sujet on arrive à la reine Beck ensuite
il nous restera quatre collègues merci
madame la Présidente moi j'ai deux
questions pour Monsieur chevet pour
représentants de la CPME une sur la
pénibilité vous dites monsieur chevet
que la prévention doit supplanter la
réparation et je rejoins la question de
René Paul Savary comment vous intégrer
les pourquoi ne pas intégrer les
critères ergonomiques dans la C2P pour
véritablement faire de la prévention et
éventuellement d'ailleurs les prendre en
compte sur les trimestres de
bonification c'est une première question
une deuxième ça concerne les seniors
j'ai lu
dans un journal une tribune de Monsieur
Asselin votre président qui proposait
trois qui faisaient trois propositions
sur les seniors une première c'était de
proposer une prime à l'embauche pourquoi
pas d'ailleurs
parallèlement sa dispositif parallèle à
ce qui existe pour les juniors si j'ose
dire pour les jeunes deuxièmement il
proposait une exonération avec
éventuellement compensation mais une
exonération des cotisations chômage si
on embauchait ou si on maintenait plutôt
dans l'emploi des seniors et
troisièmement je pense que c'est la
mutualisation par un fond spécifique
de pour éviter que le dernier employeur
pour une personne handicapée de soi
effectivement uniquement et le seul
cibler alors vous n'en avez pas beaucoup
parlé
j'aimerais effectivement vous entendre
sur ce sujet voilà merci
ma première question concernée aussi
l'emploi des seniors mais je vais
attendre les réponses aux questions de
mes collègues alors je voulais vous
questionner sur l'emploi des femmes
ou plutôt sur le salaire des femmes
puisqu'on constate que dans le privé il
y a encore une différence de salaire de
9%. alors je voulais savoir entre les
femmes et les hommes entre les hommes et
les femmes donc je voulais savoir
comment vous l'expliquez cette
différence et quelles sont vos
propositions pour arriver vraiment à une
égalité salariale entre les femmes et
les hommes merci Pascal venir
merci même la présidente moi je voudrais
déjà comme on parle des femmes je
voudrais déjà saluer quand même qu'on a
enfin une femme devant nous pour parler
des retraites parce que derrière il y
avait que des messieurs quand même ça et
c'est souvent comme ça donc voilà
moi je voudrais oui vous vous parlez la
dernière loi qu'on a faite en prévention
santé au travail avec non je t'ai
rapporteur avec mon collègue Stéphane
Hartman est-ce que vous vous pensez que
qu'il y a qu'on peut déjà avoir des
résultats positifs et notamment et ça ça
concerne monsieur chevet aussi pour le
plus petites entreprises
est-ce que le document unique
d'évaluation des risques professionnels
se fait davantage et peut répondre
justement sur sur la prévention
prévention des accidents prévention des
maladies professionnelles et je pense
que c'était vraiment le cœur en fait de
cette de cette loi donc je voulais avoir
votre votre avis sur ce sur ce sujet moi
je suis rapporteur effectivement sur la
branche à thème P et chaque année je dis
je malheureusement nous prend les 1,2 là
maintenant
un milliard maintenant c'est 1,2 pardon
la fois prochaine ça virgule 4 etc oui
bien sûr j'avais bien compris ça ou moi
ça me dérange pas qu'on prenne mais
j'aurais voulu que ce soit ciblé et que
nous on sache comment ici pour justement
accompagner les entreprises dans cette
prévention parce que la loi retraite si
moi je j'en suis convaincue d'ailleurs
mon positionnement est pas vraiment ce
géographique ce matin je devrais être
plutôt là-bas je vous le dis si vous
avez peut-être étonné dans les sujets
mais en tout cas voilà dans cette loi
retraite bien sûr faire travailler les
les salariés plus longtemps ne me pose
pas de problème à condition qu'il soit
en bonne santé et puis qu'il puisse
partir à la retraite aussi en bonne
santé et la prévention c'est vraiment le
cœur du dispositif il y a l'emploi des
seniors bien entendu pour qu'il puisse
aller jusqu'au bout de leur carrière moi
j'ai plutôt connu des personnes qui
pleuraient parce que ils ne pouvaient
pas justement continuer leur profession
parce qu'ils avaient été usés donc ça
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai sujet et
ensuite je voulais aussi vous ne vous
dire la pénibilité d'aujourd'hui n'est
pas celle de demain et n'est pas celle
d'hier donc il faut prévoir aussi de le
revoir moi j'ai une expérience de 14 ans
dans le transport de marchandises et par
exemple les camions pour les grands
routiers le confort est total et une
porte plus de chargeur donc voilà il
faut il faut aussi le revoir voilà je
crois que c'est tout ah oui si j'avais
aussi un exemple très concret très
concret qui avait été mis en place dans
dans ma ville avec la médecine du
travail sur des rendez-vous fait entre
les chefs d'entreprise
qui justement un moment donné ont une
personne qui ne peut plus travailler
dans leur entreprise parce que justement
a été usé maladie professionnelle etc
mais pourrai travailler dans une autre
et donc ils se regroupait pour voir
comment il pouvait faire évoluer ça et
en fait juste un truc madame la
Présidente les risques sur les risques
psychosociaux moi je voudrais vous
parler vous voir si vous avancez sur les
risques psychosociaux des chefs
d'entreprise parce que notamment quand
ce sont des petites entreprises c'est la
fermeture de l'entreprise et c'est des
personnes au chômage et donc des
personnes qui vont pas payer leur
retraite on parle toujours des risques
psychosociaux des salariés je vais vous
dire les chefs d'entreprise on en a
beaucoup et on en avait bien parlé avec
Stéphane Artano merci et pour terminer
Martin lévrier je suis une guidez et
ensuite vous répondrez merci madame la
Présidente merci Madame et Messieurs une
première question donc vous avez dit en
préambule que vous qui est plutôt pour
cette réforme parce que en résumé elle
permet d'équilibrer les comptes parce
que le temps de cotisations sera plus
long et donc je rebondis immédiatement
sur les seigneurs pour bien analyser la
problématique des seniors encore
faudrait-il en comprendre vraiment les
causes et pourquoi et c'est à vous que
je possède question nous sommes les plus
mauvais élèves en France sur l'employé
des seniors c'est un vrai sujet quand
même on veut le résoudre en disant on va
allonger la durée la durée de travail
certes mais si les gens travaillaient
plus longtemps on n'aurait pas se débat
ou ne pas en tout cas en totalité donc
quelle est la cause profonde en France
qui fait qu'on soit les mauvais élèves
des pays industrialisés quel est cette
cause comment vous la ressentez-vous en
tant qu'employeur la deuxième concerne
effectivement la la pénibilité mais
au-delà au-delà peut-être la formation
il y a malgré tout un certain nombre de
métiers ils sont pas des millions mais
il y a certains de métiers qui sont
d'une telle pénibilité qu'on pourrait se
poser la question des interdire à partir
d'un certain âge parce que
permettre à des personnes de partir en
retraite plutôt alors qu'elles sont
définitivement cassées c'est franchement
hypocrites voir cynique est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas y imaginer et je vous pose
la question d'une idée de métier qui
s'arrêterait un certain âge
obligatoirement et donc derrière un
système de formation qui permette la
réinsertion dans notre métier mais donc
avec une logique de formation très forte
très poussée et à financement non pas de
50 euros 800 euros 1000 euros mais un
véritable financement porté par les
employeurs aussi par les salariés je
vous remercie
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas parlé des aidants
familiaux pour ceux qui reprennent le
travail après parfois un arrêt assez
prolongé je voulais savoir si vous
pensez que le gouvernement au niveau de
ses propositions sont satisfaisantes et
est-ce que vous-même vous avez fait des
propositions par rapport aux aidants
familiaux merci
très bien beaucoup de questions mais
beaucoup de sujets qui se recoupent
aussi donc qui commence madame
de Perroy merci beaucoup pour l'ensemble
de ces questions donc je vais essayer de
regrouper
je pense avoir manifesté la vigilance
que nous devons avoir sur l'équilibre
global de cette réforme
et la vigilance il faut l'avoir sous
l'angle des recettes et des mesures
d'accompagnement et si nous avons
souhaité mentionner
l'existence de cette somme de 30
milliards qui est versée régulièrement
c'est pour avoir un regard plus élargi
sur finalement le sujet de la retraite
plus globalement
voilà le cadre dans lequel j'ai exprimé
le sujet après bien sûr il y a des
hypothèses c'est c'est une réforme
amenée par le gouvernement elle le
gouvernement a choisi de ce de retenir
un certain d'hypothèses et bien il
faudra voir si celle-ci se réalise ou
pas mais en tout cas
l'importance nous semble-t-il et d'avoir
vraiment cette vision globale et nous
serons vigilants sur cette dimension là
en ce qui concerne le transfert qui est
proposé
sur cet échange de cotisation entre la
caisse ATMP et donc la CNAP ce qui est
important pour nous c'est d'être
vigilant de façon nous n'avons pas à
demander ce transfert et d'être vigilant
de façon à véritablement
voir à ce qu'il y ait bien une
équivalence si ce cet échange doit être
fait mais je crois que ce qu'il faut
vraiment regarder précisément c'est ce
milliard qui est évoqué sur cinq ans
comme un fond de prévention et comment
se font de prévention sera allouée sera
dépensé de façon à accompagner
le travail à accompagner les postures
nous voyons si vous allez dans les
entreprises beaucoup d'entreprises
investir sur des d'aide au levage des
systèmes d'exosquelette etc on pourrait
prendre beaucoup d'exemples je pense que
nous n'avons pas le temps mais c'est
véritablement ça le
l'investissement dans la prévention
autour du travail et nous serons bien
sûr très vigilants là-dessus et c'est
là-dessus que les partenaires sociaux
ont engagé une discussion dans le cadre
de la ni tu y reviendras peut-être
Eric
tout à l'heure je voudrais par là
revenir sur la santé au travail parce
que en effet la loi est sortie si ma
mémoire est bonne début août 2021 avec
un nombre de décret qui arrive au fil de
l'eau je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur le rôle important de la
médecine du travail et les dispositions
qui ont été mises d'abord dans l'accord
des partenaires sociaux puis reprises
dans la loi pour lesquelles il nous
semble que les décrets sont en cours de
je me permettrai d'insister sur deux
sujets c'est le soutien que peuvent
avoir les médecins du travail au travers
du rôle des IPA du travail qui nous
apparaissent indispensables à développer
et à avoir sur le terrain parce que nous
avions
également demandé à ce que il est une
capacité à avoir des médecins praticiens
correspondants qui ne sont pas à
proprement parler des médecins du
travail mais qui pourraient venir
soutenir dans un certain nombre de cas
pourquoi je me permets de vous parler de
cela parce que la visite de désinsertion
professionnelle qui a été instaurée à
cette
à ce moment-là et bien elle fait partie
de la prévention et il ne faudrait pas
qu'elle ne puisse pas avoir lieu et les
visites de fin de carrière là aussi sont
des visites importantes et la prévention
c'est un tout et certains d'entre vous
ont été évoqués tout à l'heure aussi
finalement un sujet que je qualifierais
d'équilibre Vie privée vie
professionnelle et de qualité de vie au
travail et de qualité de vie et des
conditions de travail je rappelle que ce
terme nous l'avons partagé avec
Eric chevet de la CPME lors de notre
négociation avec les partenaires sociaux
dans l'anisante et au travail et ça a
été repris depuis les employeurs
négocient de plus en plus avec les
partenaires sociaux et le dialogue
social et quelque chose de très
important à cette occasion parce que ça
permet d'ancrer la dynamique et d'en
créer ces accords là au sein des sujets
et des contextes de chacune des
entreprises ça s'appelle des accords
mobilité vous y avez fait allusion tout
à l'heure ça s'appelle aussi des accords
qualités de vie et conditions de travail
et cet ancrage au plus près de
l'entreprise nous apparaît faire partie
aussi de cette dynamique d'employabilité
d'emplois et pas uniquement des seniors
finalement
c'est une dynamique globale vous avez
évoqué parfois peut-être un sujet entre
les jeunes et les seniors mais il nous
apparaît important de ne pas opposer les
jeunes et les seniors l'entreprise c'est
une dynamique à part entière les jeunes
doivent pouvoir y être accueillis et
d'ailleurs tout est dimension autour de
l'apprentissage et autour des alternants
sont des soutiens qui sont importants et
les personnes expérimentées au sein de
l'entreprise sont aussi très importantes
parce que elles pourront apporter un
relais on peut appeler ça le tutorat on
peut appeler ça le mentorat on peut
appeler ça des dispositifs de patrimoine
métiers compétences il y a de nombreux
sujets qui sont déployés au sein des
entreprises et on voit bien que le
reversement Touring aussi ce sont des
dimensions qui permettent aussi aux
jeunes d'apporter leurs connaissances
peut-être plus importantes du monde par
exemple num digital au sein de
l'entreprise et d'organiser ces
collectifs qui doivent être des
collectifs
intégrant
inclusifs voilà donc à la réponse que
faisons-nous pour les jeunes que font
nous pour les anciens je pense que
l'entreprise a à cœur de développer ses
collectifs et au travers des accords que
les employeurs négocient dans le cadre
d'un dialogue social avec les
partenaires sociaux et bien c'est toute
cette dimension qui est développée et je
voudrais revenir aussi sur les questions
autour de l'employabilité et bien
l'employabilité c'est aussi parler de ce
sujet d'emploi et donc de ce sujet de
formation au sein des entreprises et là
aussi la dimension de dialogue au sein
des entreprises de façon à faire en
sorte que les formations soient
déployées auprès des différents publics
avoir ces entretiens professionnels qui
existent régulièrement déjà mais dont
certains pourraient davantage focalisé
autour de la deuxième partie de carrière
ça nous paraît être une dimension très
importante et lorsque nous y allonsons
avec les chefs d'entreprise sur les
territoires en proximité et bien ce sont
des dimensions qui sont déclinés et qui
nous paraissent être importantes et si
on arrive à injecter avec cette
dimension de prévention au travers de la
santé au travail au travers de la
branche ATMP et bien nous aurons je
pense fait oeuvres utile en termes de
prévention de l'usure au travail et je
voudrais remettre en parallèle
usure au travail dans le cas de la santé
et l'usure au travail nous ne sommes pas
égaux devant l'usure au travail c'est un
sujet qui doit être regardé au travers
des visites médicales individuelles et
en même temps l'employabilité c'est la
projection des salariés et notamment les
formations
sur les dimensions
de de politique femme familiale je ne
voudrais pas être dans une dimension qui
est plus une dimension
sociétale et bien sûr que le sujet de la
natalité est important puisqu'on voit
bien qu'un régime de retraite par
répartition et bien repose sur le nombre
de cotisants qui peuvent financer le
nombre de personnes à la retraite donc
le sujet est important mais il ne
m'appartiendra pas d'être dans cette
dimension autour de la politique
familiale cela dit je reviens sur mon
propos liminaire au sein de l'entreprise
toute la dimension qui pourra être sur
l'équilibre vie privée professionnelle
et toute cette déclinaison autour des
marques employeur si j'emploie un autre
vocable et bien sont des dimensions
importantes pour permettre là aussi que
ce soit l'emploi des femmes ou à
l'emploi des hommes et bien de vivre
dans un contexte de vie
équilibrer avec des fonctionnements plus
fluides
il me semble et Eric je vais te passer
bien sûr la main que autour de la
dimension des femmes et de la retraite
le corps lui-même a dit que
les systèmes étaient redistributifs et
qu'il n'y avait pas de sujets
particuliers à cet effet là nous nous
pensons au MEDEF qu'il est très
important de regarder le sujet pendant
la carrière professionnelle et que les
indices égalité professionnelle
développer du temps de Madame Pénicaud
ou rixin toutes les mesures autour de
cette dimension là sont des mesures
visant à pouvoir faire progresser ces
sujets là il y a bien les regarder
pendant la carrière professionnelle mais
sur le sujet de la retraite je me
refaire à ce qu'a dit le rapport du
corps voilà ce que je peux dire à ce
stade et puis Eric peut-être on
reviendra en complément mais je te passe
la main sur les différents sujets et
puis on pourra je pourrais en
commentaire merci merci beaucoup de vos
questions qui sont toutes et qui me
m'ont fait penser que du coup j'avais
été un peu bref dans mon propos
liminaire puisque il y a un certain
nombre d'explications complémentaires
qui sont absolument nécessaires merci de
me donner l'occasion de le faire madame
la Présidente première chose sur la
question de l'équilibre financier global
au terme de cette réforme c'est une
question intéressante vous savez que
pour ces sièges au corps sommes un
certain nombre nous aurons au mois de
juin une un rapport du corps qui doit
raisonner un législation actuel et donc
si la législation est adoptée modifiée
après cette loi et bien évidemment qu'on
aura la projection du corps sauf que
j'attire votre attention sur le fait
quand même que
le corps fait beaucoup beaucoup de
projection
qui fait des projections à très long
terme
et qui sont évidemment
autant qu'il y a de projection autant de
discussions possibles et surtout se
retourner dans le long terme donc moi je
pense que il y a une nécessaire
réflexion sur j'allais dire la
autour de j'allais dire le cadrage ou
l'idée que le corps devrait être un peu
plus précis peut-être avoir une échéance
à moyen terme très clairement identifié
à la Gère Carco je rappelle que les
partenaires sociaux gèrent la JR Carco
avec une échéance de 15 ans
j'ai l'impression qu'il le gère pas si
mal que ça et avoir une prospective
évidemment à l'issue d'une génération il
faut garder ça en tête mais avoir des
conventions des hypothèses etc
multiplier sans arrêt dans un rapport
comme ça c'est derrière troublé plutôt
les esprits que de donner je rappelle
que quand l'Insee fait des prévisions
démographiques à l'hypothèse haute
l'hypothèse basse et l'hypothèse moyenne
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne je
pense qu'on pourrait peut-être recadrer
un petit peu le corps je rappelle que
c'est des éléments de loi qui sont là
dessus donc vous avez la main
éventuellement sur sur ce sujet là il y
a un sujet majeur c'est celui de de la
question de l'usure professionnelle et
j'ai été bref et donc je veux bien
réexpliquer le dispositif qui est mis
sur la table d'abord on ne peut pas se
satisfaire d'un système qui prévoit à
97%, 98% aujourd'hui
de la réparation 2% pour la prévention
14 milliards de cotisations patronales
il y a allez on est quand on compte 2%,
on comprend y compris toutes les toute
l'infrastructure pour faire mais en fait
il y a des pensées dans les entreprises
une centaine de millions d'euros par an
pour la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle c'est quoi c'est faire
en sorte que à chaque poste de travail
on puisse identifier le rôle le rôle
c'est la question du du RP qui a été
soulevée par madame la sénatrice qu'on
puisse identifier les risques qui sont
associés et mettre les moyens en place
pour réduire les risques professionnels
il y a aussi la question des accidents
du travail limiter les risques
d'accident et pour ça il faut des moyens
mais encore plus que des moyens il faut
des compétences il faut qu'on amène de
dans la tpeme sur l'ensemble du
territoire il faut qu'on amène la
compétence pour accompagner le chef
d'entreprise sur cette question de la
prévention de l'usure et du quelques
professionnels et aujourd'hui forte est
de constater que tout passe dans la
réparation ce qui était humainement
inacceptable je trouve que on se trouve
on se trouve quand même un peu je
rejoins votre votre réflexion monsieur
le sénateur donc il faut absolument
qu'on arrive à basculer ce que je dis
sur de la prévention et pour nous y
aider effectivement il y a un fond d'un
milliard qui est créé qui va être
abonder pour progressivement et qui doit
permettre d'enclencher cette culture de
la prévention que nous n'avons pas
suffisamment pas seulement dans les
entreprises mais dans l'ensemble de
l'écosystème qui qui concerne la
production la production de services ou
la production de la production
industrielle donc c'est un point
extrêmement important que d'imaginer ce
dispositif là deuxième chose on aura
malheureusement enfin ce sera toujours
comme ça il y aura toujours de l'usure
professionnelle et il faudra y faire
attention l'exposition certains sur
certains métiers et dans certains
critères du C2P qui sont restés dans le
C2P sont des je pense au métier hyper
bas en milieu hyper bar enfin etc
effectivement qu'on peut même réfléchir
à des durées d'exposition maximum sur
lesquelles il faut pas dépasser
d'ailleurs je pense que l'ancêtre doit
certainement avoir des travaux sur ce
sujet là et il y a des précautions qui
doivent être prises effectivement mais
là en fait ce que nous imaginons dans le
dispositif usure professionnel c'est
pour les dizaines de milliers de métiers
et je rappelle qu'effectivement
85 à 90% des sorties en inaptitude le
son pour les trois facteurs ergonomiques
des troubles musculo-squelettiques et
donc on a trouvé un dispositif qui ne
soit pas la création de catégorie active
ou de régime spéciaux mais qui puisse
quand même traiter correctement le
risque d'usure professionnelle c'est ce
qui est envisagé avec ce dispositif
puisque autour de 45 ans mi carrière on
va dire il y a une première étape qui
est fait et chacun vient à raison chacun
réagit en fonction de sa physiologie et
de son de sa constitution au métier à
l'exposition au métier à partir de là
sous évidemment l'étude du médecin du
travail et en collaboration avec un
certain nombre d'acteurs qui doivent
être dans les métiers de la prévention
de la désinsertion professionnelle il y
a évidemment des ergonomies etc tout un
tout un tas et puis évidemment sur la
question de la je rejoins Diane
là-dessus sur la question de la
formation professionnelle il y a une
visite de mie carrière qui de mon point
de vue devrait être une un bilan à 360
pour savoir si le salarié il adore son
métier il veut y rester parce que ça
arrive
très clairement ça arrive relativement
souvent que les gens veulent pas changer
de métier ils veulent y rester comment
on fait pour l'accompagner quand il veut
rester dans son métier et éventuellement
si le à 61 ou 60 61 ans il est
effectivement abîmé par l'usure
professionnelle lui offrir la
possibilité de partir plus tôt mais
aussi de prévoir des orientations
différentes des réorientations soit à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise soit à
l'intérieur de la branche soit sur
d'autres métiers et aujourd'hui les
dispositions de transition
professionnelle sont là pour ça donc
c'est tout un mécanisme avec un suivi
individuel renforcé pour ses salariés
actuellement dans la visite parce que
pour ces troubles ergonomie c'est 45 60
ans excusez moi j'ai pris la parole
madame la Présidente mais
et par contre pour le c2pic quand est-ce
qu'il partira en départ anticipé il y a
les points qui tombent comment vous
rapprocher les dispositifs parce que là
c'est une personne en entier qu'il faut
prendre en compte c'est pas oui nous
sommes nous sommes d'accord avec vous
sur l'analyse de dire on peut pas on n'a
pas une santé au travail d'un côté et
une santé civile de l'autre ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que nous étions nous
favorables à l'introduction des médecins
praticiens correspondants parce que ça
crée une personne mais je comprends
monsieur le sénateur je comprends
monsieur le sénateur mais ce que je
comprends effectivement c'est vite
pourquoi on ne déverse pas l'usure
professionnelle dans ces deux P c'est ça
en fait votre question c'est vous très
dans ce qui nous est proposé et vous en
avez le responsabilité en ayant sorti
les les facteurs de pénibilité c'est pas
une accusation je constate
dans la proposition ont été faites de
loi c'est que l'examen se fait en
fonction de des critères d'usure et non
pas en fonction de la personne on peut
très bien imaginer un médecin du travail
qui va voir à sa visite obligatoire des
60 à une personne qui porte des charges
de l'eau mais elle s'occupe pas du
travail alors ça c'est le plus c'est pas
moi vous comprenez l'approche il faut
remettre comment on peut rapprocher pour
que on puisse savoir parce que
actuellement j'en finis là actuellement
le départ
anticipé pour les personnes soumises à
des troubles ergonomiques c'est le
médecin qui va
le le définir d'accord tandis que c'est
la personne qui définit son départ par
les points quand elle est soumis aux
autres facteurs de pénibilité si elle
travaille de nuit et compagnie donc
comment on rapproche qui a raisonnement
qui soit parallèles parce que sinon on
découpe les personnes quoi je comprends
mais les critères de pénibilité sont des
expositions tout à fait particulières
qui méritent un traitement particulier
première chose deuxième chose le médecin
du travail est là pour ça c'est son job
de faire sauter et c'est pour ça que
nous voulons lui libérer du temps
médical avec les médecins praticiens
correspondants pour faire en sorte de
redonner sa spécialité à la médecine du
travail c'est-à-dire les orientés sur
des métiers qu'on aura sur des salariés
qu'on aura préalablement fait chier au
niveau de la TNT au niveau de la branche
et dont on sait que il y a des taux
d'usure professionnelle qui sont plus
importants que les autres donc on a déjà
un faisceau d'indice qui nous permet
d'orienter et petit à petit
effectivement les visites elles sont pas
uniques tous les 5 ans il y a un suivi
particulier qui permet effectivement
d'aller au bout mais voilà
mais non parce que je l'idée c'est de ne
pas recréer des registres parce que
sinon on regrette très clairement pas
des registres spéciaux mais des
catégories actives très clairement c'est
ça et donc il faut pas recréer des
catégories actives puisque ça crée des
effets de bord qui sont évidemment
absolument pas supportable voilà
une facilite pas la tâche pour trouver
un dispositif qui serait plus adapté
c'est vraiment un traitement différent
d'un côté c'est le choix du médecin de
l'autre côté c'est le choix du salarié
comment rapproche quand même les deux
sans créer effectivement tout ça sans
mettre les trucs il faut quand même
rapprocher un petit peu tout ça parce
que c'est incompréhensible pour nos cas
dans tous les cas il y a un choix enfin
le choix du salarié du Chat du salarié
aussi de rester dans de exposer dans ces
critères du C2P parce que il faut qu'ils
puissent le supporter
il a le choix et c'est aussi le choix de
l'employeur il y a un moment aussi on se
pose la question de savoir de savoir
effectivement si on peut garder tel ou
tel salarié au milieu urber ou quand il
a fait je sais pas toute une carrière
oui mais je comprends je comprends mais
je vois pas comment vous rendez la main
au salarié sans avoir une un jugement
objectif et la le jugement objectif il
vient individuel il vient par le médecin
santé au travail et le médecin conseil
de la sécurité sociale moi ça me paraît
pas être exorbitant l'idée que on puisse
pas non plus
à l'encontre de vos efforts que vous
voulez faire sur la prévention ça c'est
vraiment le système de réparation je
suis d'accord c'est un système de
réparation
qu'on retrouve dans le C2P puisque il y
a le choix la formation etc vous voyez
dans le C2 ports
[Musique]
sans en avoir les obligations
d'effectivement de faire des catégories
bien spécifiques oui on a vas-y vas-y
vas-y mais c'est vrai que si on revient
sur le du RP c'est pour moi la première
marche et je crois que la question était
adressée donc je veux pas l'appréhenter
mais pour moi c'est la première marche
de prise de conscience d'identification
des risques et du travail de la
prévention au sein de l'entreprise après
il y a le travail de la prévention dans
un dialogue aussi avec la médecine du
travail et puis il y a au sein des
branches la dynamique de prévention avec
incitation ATMP voilà mais comme tu
avais été sur le DRP je veux pas je
comprends je sais pas forcément rendre
la main au salarié sur la question de
l'usure
mais en tout cas cette imaginé c'est
possible puisque en fait il y a prévu
dans le suivi individuel renforcé qui
est fait c'est pas seulement un suivi
médical c'est aussi la possibilité de
suivre de demander effectivement de
proposer un certain nombre de
transformation de carrière etc etc c'est
peut-être ça qu'il faut sur lequel il
faut préciser mais en tout cas c'est
comme ça que nous on l'a imaginé au
début quand on nous l'avons imaginé je
vous propose de poursuivre vos échanges
dans le cadre des auditions rapporteur
éventuellement ou des échanges directs
et je vous invite à poursuivre
il faut qu'on revienne sur l'emploi des
seniors et vous m'avez interrogé Michel
sénateur effectivement les propositions
du président Hasselin alors d'abord
pourquoi pourquoi aussi peut-être pour
faire la transition entre les deux
points pourquoi en fait on a des taux
d'emploi des seniors aussi faible je
suis désolé de vous le dire mais quand
même depuis 40 ans
quand même on part de l'idée en France
que la quantité de travail est limitée
et que du coup il faut dégager nos
anciens pour faire de la place aux
jeunes ça n'a jamais marché mais on a
fait ça depuis 40 ans
et de ben c'est exactement ce qu'on
propose et donc aujourd'hui tout le code
du travail a été construit dans ce
sens-là les partenaires sociaux aussi
dans les dispositifs et je pense
notamment aux dispositif sur l'assurance
chômage ont mis en place des dispositifs
dans ce sens là et donc alors que on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui notamment avec la
réforme de l'apprentissage que il y a
une explosion de l'embauche des jeunes
notamment sous format d'apprentissage et
que ça n'a pas d'impact aujourd'hui sur
l'embauche des seniors ou le taux
d'emploi des le taux d'emploi des
seniors donc c'est pour ça que dans le
parallèle de ce qui a été fait sur le
contrat d'apprentissage nous nous
pensons très clairement que il faut
effectivement des dispositifs
particuliers qu'à proposer le président
aslin mais que fondamentalement ce qui
compte c'est l'évolution des mentalités
sur cette question là or sur
l'apprentissage on a franchi un cap sur
l'évolution des mentalités avec la loi
avenir professionnel de 2018 qui a
provoqué dans l'opinion française l'idée
que l'apprentissage effectivement
c'était une voie d'excellence pour
arriver à un métier à l'emploi etc et
s'insérer dans le monde économique je
pense que cette même révolution
culturelle doit être fait sur l'emploi
des seniors aujourd'hui et que de toute
façon mécaniquement avec le recul de
l'âge c'est quand même étonnant de
constater que c'est en France dans le
pays on parle plutôt à la retraite que
les taux d'emploi avant sont les plus
faibles c'est quand même étonnant de le
constater quand même statistiquement
donc c'est vraiment je pense que c'est
vraiment et donc du les propositions une
proposition qui tourne effectivement
autour de la prime sur pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs sur un contrat proposition
que certains ont demandé quelle
proposition proposition sur un contrat
effectivement qui peut être le contrat
d'employabilité revue enfin etc un
contrat qui puisse sur lequel il y a un
engagement réciproque de de l'entreprise
et pourquoi pas de l'assurance chômage
mais c'est peut-être la CME portera ça
dans la réforme de l'assurance chômage
enfin puisque vous savez qu'on a tout on
a une revue de la convention assurance
chômage tous les trois ans dans la
future qui va être négocié cette année
la CPME portera l'idée d'un contrat
spécifique qui est exonéré des
cotisations d'assurance chômage pour des
anciens qu'on emmènerait jusqu'à l'âge
de départ et donc la contrepartie c'est
que si on emmène pas jusqu'à l'âge de
départ on reverse à ce moment là le le
l'avantage obtenu donc ça c'était
c'était la proposition qu'on faisait et
puis il y a un point essentiel que le
sénateur à Van derenberg a rappelé c'est
la question effectivement de la
mutualisation de l'inaptitude c'est pour
nous extrêmement important que de faire
en sorte que le coût de l'inaptitude
professionnelle ne soit pas supporté par
le dernier employeur ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui mais qu'il soit mutualisé
pour les employeurs
c'est proposer ces réglementaires donc
je crois que vous avez peu de choses au
niveau mais c'est prévu dans le
tu veux compléter là-dessus en fait
juste tu parlais à un moment donné
sur le chômage je pense qu'on peut
injecter aussi la réflexion que nous
avons exposé au gouvernement lors des
concertations sur l'importance de
retravailler les 36 mois qui sont le
temps d'indemnisation
réservée aux personnes de plus de 58 ans
ou 59 ans si ma mémoire est bonne et de
le travailler à 24 mois je pense que
c'est aussi un élément non c'est à 36
aujourd'hui moi
alors en tout cas d'aller d'aller à un
nombre de mois inférieur ça nous paraît
aussi une dimension importante et je
voudrais juste ajouter à ce que tu as
dit c'est aussi que lors de la réforme
précédente on a vu que mécaniquement
lorsque la réforme est passée finalement
les personnes sont restées en emploi
plus longtemps puisque vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui on part grosso modo à 63
ans donc mécaniquement à votre question
tout à l'heure il y a un effet décalage
qui se fait naturellement mais le sujet
du chômage doit être gardé également
je continue à rapidement je vais essayer
d'être assez bref sur les points alors
sur la question de la politique
familiale sénateurs et nous est parti
mais je dirais volontiers que sur ce
sujet là on voit bien que les dernières
évolutions socio-économiques montrent
bien qu'il y a de notre point de vue
CPME la nécessité de repenser la
politique familiale moi je pense que on
a là une première étape nous sommes très
favorables effectivement avoir des
politiques familiales très
encourageantes effectivement mais
comment on tient compte des différentes
évolutions qu'on voit aujourd'hui y
compris le fait que petit à petit les
carrières se resserre et que des
dispositifs qu'on avait imaginé pour
corriger
la situation des femmes puissent
deviennent aujourd'hui un peu caduques
et donc ça nécessite de revoir de notre
point de vue de reprendre le dossier de
la politique familiale un peu dans son
ensemble pour pouvoir aimer nous sommes
nous très très intéressés et nous sommes
les plus gros
cotisant vous allez quasi au familiale
très intéressé notamment sur la garde il
faut faire des efforts massifs sur les
gardes
peut-être en relais
Eric il y avait une question tout à
l'heure sur les danses en effet je pense
que les mesures qui ont été prises nous
nous sommes tout à fait favorables parce
que nous voyons bien que finalement un
emploi de seniors c'est aussi un parent
qui a peut-être des petits enfants mais
qui a aussi ses parents et qui peut être
aussi dans une dynamique des danses donc
il y a des mesures qui figurent dans le
projet nous les avons vu et c'est une
dimension sur laquelle il faudra
travailler bien évidemment puisque ça
fera partie de l'équilibre Vie privée
vie professionnelle et accompagnement et
là on tombe aussi dans une dimension
sociétale mais on ne peut que être
favorable à ces mesures et je
compléterai Diane en disant que les
partenaires sociaux qui viennent de
signer un accord sur le partage de la
valeur ont mis dans les motifs
supplémentaires de déblocage l'épargne
salariale la question des aidants
familiaux c'est-à-dire pouvoir débloquer
des sommes parfois nécessaire pour les
danses familiales donc ça c'est aussi
vraiment dans notre champ dans notre
champ en ce moment au niveau des
partenaires sociaux revenir sur la
question de l'équité des 1200 euros pour
les commerçants et les artisans je crois
qu'il y avait une sénatrice qui avait
posé cette question là
c'est une question que sur laquelle
évidemment nous sommes très attachés à
ce que les commerçants et les artisans
soient pas les derniers après les
agriculteurs et tout le monde allait à
un dispositif de minima de pension qui
soit équitable bien souvent ce que nous
constatons c'est que les commerçants
notamment et mais les artisans c'est un
peu vrai aussi même s'ils ont en fait un
peu plus cotisé et donc ils ont des des
retraites un peu supérieures
les commerçants
j'allais dire était victime à la fois de
mauvais conseils pendant des années et
de l'évolution de économie qui fait que
aujourd'hui
l'économie a beaucoup changé que le
commerce de centre-ville a disparu au
profit du commerce périphérie et que
celui-ci est en train de disparaître au
profit du commerce sur internet et que
ces évolutions effectivement qui sont
des évolutions sociétales qui sont comme
ça font que ceux qui constituait la
recette la retraite du commerçant
généralement c'était la vente de son
fonds de commerce ou de son pas de porte
etc aujourd'hui a disparu donc on a des
situations d'extrême pauvreté aussi dans
le commerce notamment dans le commerce
un peu moins dans l'artisanat et que un
devoir de solidarité si on peut
rattraper
un devoir de solidarité là-dessus nous
nous sommes favorables à la CME de le
faire et nous avons proposé
effectivement selon l'assume cette
proposition que dans le cadre de
l'équilibre global c'est de regarder
comment le régime complémentaire des
indépendants puissent participer à cette
équilibre global et notamment parce que
la question de l'équité à l'intérieur ne
sera mieux traitée que par les
représentants des commerçants et des
artisans eux-mêmes et donc dans le
dispositif je crois qu'il faut qu'on le
traite à l'intérieur c'est vrai que la
question ils ont peu ils ont peu cotisé
donc du coup on leur dit bah dans ces
conditions évidemment vous avez pas de
retraite certes
alors par contre mais ils peuvent depuis
la loi à venir profiter la loi santé au
travail ils peuvent adhérer à un service
de santé directement voilà absolument
donc je voulais préciser ça là-dessus
sur l'index on est favorable on n'est
pas favorable aux index les index non
globalement
non mais de moi
donc
pour répondre sur la question des
annexes non on n'est pas favorable parce
que les index sont dévoyés voilà ils
sont détournés de leur objet premier qui
est celui de la connaissance et bien
souvent ils sont transformés en
instrument
de taxation pour en faire des
instruments de politique franchement
nous on pense pas on pense vraiment pas
que ça peut marcher très clairement au
contraire bien souvent on a des effets
délétères voir des effets pervers voire
complètement inverse je rappelle de la
lande voilà donc c'est pour ça que on
est très très prudent autant ça nous
intéresse franchement de savoir et donc
d'avoir la statistique les évolutions
les études qui vont avec autant
alors peut-être à la belle
et que d'aucun pourrait effectivement
s'en prévaloir mais on est très très
prudent sur le fait que et dans les mois
entre les 50 et 3 et 300 mais là je
reprends le ministre je crois qu'à dis
ça avec des tensions de pas créer un
monstre administratif dans les TPE PME
enfin c'est enfin c'est pas des TPE PME
là les 5300
des entreprises sont très hétérogènes
donc je pense qu'on doit tenir compte de
ça après si on doit aller dans cette
dynamique là avoir quelque chose qui
valorise les efforts de l'entreprise qui
pourrait être un label c'est peut-être
quelque chose sur lequel on peut on peut
réfléchir mais c'est vrai que notre
première approche et de dire notre
position à l'index en tout cas tel qu'il
est présenté et
par ce projet
pardon monsieur le rapporteur Martin
lévrier a exprimé le souhait de pouvoir
parce que c'est un peu en complément de
ma question tout à l'heure vous je vous
entends de parler de un peu comme
l'apprentissage qui oui a été une vraie
révolution en France mais qui n'était
pas que des aides pour les employeurs
qui est une vraie révolution sur la
formation sur l'approche de la formation
qui doit faire les formations etc donc
c'était un ensemble là les idées que
vous proposez sont quand même de nouveau
des aides de l'État ou des taxes en
moins c'est pas une révolution et vous
voulez pas de l'index parce qu'il
pourrait vous pénaliser moi j'aimerais
que vous fassiez des propositions en
disant oui on embauchait pas ou on
licenciait trop tôt les seigneurs et
voilà vers quoi on veut aller nous pour
faire la révolution mais de vous-même en
plus de d'aide potentiel mais voilà
j'avoue que
moi je tiens à rappeler que une
entreprise c'est une communauté c'est
une collectivité avec des âges
différents des talents différents des
compétences différentes et il nous
apparaît important
d'être dans une dynamique de développer
à tout âge l'employabilité des
collaborateurs et sur le sujet
spécifique des seniors il s'agit à un
moment donné de faire un arrêt sur image
et d'envisager la deuxième partie de
carrière je serai dans cette dynamique
parce que je pense qu'on ne peut pas
opposer les jeunes et les plus anciens
au sein d'une entreprise il s'agit
d'avoir toujours un corps social qui est
en capacité d'être
employé employable au sein de
l'entreprise il y a peut-être deux
dimensions sur lequel et je te repasse
la parole peut-être juste enfin sur
lesquels on n'est pas revenu c'est la
retraite progressive et le cumul emploi
retraite qui sont des dimensions et des
dispositifs qui nous parais de première
importance pour contribuer aussi à
l'emploi des seniors on les a pas
mentionnés tout à l'heure en répondant
aux questions c'est pour ça que je me
permettais de les rajouter
le cumul emploi retraite pour nous je
pense qu'on peut imaginer avoir des
vrais politiques là-dessus dès lors
qu'on libérerait l'histoire des 6 mois
alors je sais pas comment il faut il
faut travailler sur cette question là
parce que c'est assez compliqué je sais
mais avec alors comment on pourrait
avoir un dispositif qui permet parce que
ça c'est vraiment intéressant je crois
que c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
pourrait être porté et pour la
transmission pour la révolution
culturelle qu'on appelle de nos vœux sur
l'emploi des seniors je pense que ce
serait intéressant parce qu'on peut
imaginer de liquider les droits à la
retraite et de conserver pour une
période de trois mois six mois un an la
transmission sur le poste imaginez du
coup le contrat de transition racontera
de génération rénovée 21e siècle je
crois que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
je crois que ce serait intéressant de
travailler sur ces questions là
oui oui je tâche de répondre à toutes
les demandes je vais vous demander de
pouvoir avoir un propos un petit peu
plus ramassé et je redonne la parole
pour la richesse des échanges à Madame
Pascal Grigny monsieur le rapporteur
bien sûr et à Monsieur Alain Milon
révolution là sur l'emploi des seniors
mais oui parce que moi j'entends bien
chez les salariés voilà on a toujours
tendance à dire bon ils veulent ils
veulent partir plus tôt voilà donc en
plus dans le sujet c'est compliqué mais
en revanche ça existe mais il y a une
vraie révolution à faire chez les chefs
d'entreprise et ça on vous l'a pas
entendu moi franchement mais
moi je vais vous dire j'ai 62 ans voilà
tu es gentil
non pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
c'est ça ça m'étonnait aussi venant de
l'épaule que ce soit un compliment
non en revanche moi j'ai des gens autour
de moi qui étaient des cadres en
entreprise j'en ai beaucoup pour pas
dire plein que je connais soit parce que
j'ai été DRH et je les connais soit
parce que ce sont des amis ou des
collègues ou des gens voilà que je
rencontre dans différentes différents
lieux mais en revanche énormément sont
partis on leur a demandé de partir de se
mettre au chômage pendant les deux ans
et ça si vous ne le dites pas vous vous
ne ferez pas la révolution vous ne la
ferez pas si vous n'apportez pas ça et
si on ne l'entend pas et il l'entend ça
veut dire qu'il faut le marteler vous ne
ferez pas cette révolution pas toujours
d'un côté
parce que effectivement on peut le dire
du côté des salariés mais sincèrement
chez les cadres ils sont plutôt envie de
rester dans l'entreprise et on a
derrière des gens déprimés parfois ils
ont qui partent à la retraite ils sont
peut-être en bonne santé tant qu'ils
sont dans l'entreprise et quand ils sont
plus ils sont dans la déprime voir la
dépression
alors je vais vous reposer ma question
puisque j'ai pas eu de réponse
systématiquement tous les ans nos
collègues et amis par ailleurs parlent
des exonations de cotisations sociales
et des fraudes fiscales
ce que j'aimerais c'est que nous
puissions avoir des éléments de réponse
pas simplement dire bah écoutez les
isolations sociales ça permet à
l'entreprise de vivre à la rigueur c'est
pas une réponse mais moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est connaître exactement
les chiffres aussi demain par exemple et
me venaient l'idée folle de vous de
faire un amendement proposant la
suppression des émotionnations fiscales
je suis sûr que au Sénat ce serait voté
mais j'ai pas l'envie folle de faire ça
mais par contre j'ai envie folle de
savoir exactement quel serait les
conséquences d'une telle suppression au
niveau de l'emploi
René Paul Savary peut-être dernière
question
oui non mais elles peuvent être en
complément il y a on a un moment
essentiel quand même du texte là
essentiel l'index Seigneur vient d'être
supprimé
l'index ça pénalise le label ça valorise
il y a quand même une voix de passage
entre eux quand même il y a possibilité
d'avoir des points des mois à 100 mettre
des bonus des malus c'est un truc simple
ça peut me semble-t-il l'index pénalisé
et pourquoi pas au-dessus de 300 le
label ça peut valoriser pourquoi pas en
dessous de 50 enfin
entre 50 et 300 mais faites des
propositions c'est le moment là parce
que après ça va trancher après ça va
trancher alors j'allais dire excusez-moi
mais ne venez pas vous plaindre quoi
vous avez la possibilité là dans les
dans les heures qui viennent c'est quand
même un délai relativement long de faire
des propositions concrètes moi je
partage le propos de Pascal il faut que
c'est pas le tout dire les seniors les
seigneurs il faut dire oui on a compris
les seniors véritablement c'est une
valeur ajoutée à nos entreprises et
c'est pas au détriment des jeunes voilà
comment on fait une proposition qui
puisse être acceptable et accepter par
les salariés c'est comme ça qu'on
arrivera dans ce pays à travailler mieux
la main dans la main votre proposition
CDI junior
c'est comme ça que je le vois style CDI
chantier junior contrat d'engagement
entre l'entreprise et le salarié qui dit
voilà je vous ai en CDI maintenant on
voit bien vous avez vos difficultés j'ai
les miennes on convient ensemble en
modifie votre CDI on vous fait un CDI
chantier jusqu'à votre âge de taux plein
vous voulez quoi du mi-temps du truc on
peut vous le proposer on peut pas de
l'accompagnement une amélioration au
travail tout le monde et à ce moment-là
ça évite que il aille au chômage et pour
vous vous garder l'expériment la partie
son expérience pardon ses compétences
que vous mettez à disposition d'autres
vous voyez j'avais cette idée que j'ai
proposé à mes collègues depuis deux
trois jours ça me le a confirme je sais
pas si on va pouvoir la mettre dans la
loi je ne suis pas sûr qu'on puisse
amène mais il faut qu'on obtienne du
gouvernement des engagements et des
engagements qui vous concerneront donc
autant que on y réfléchisse peut-être
ensemble qu'on propose également aux
organisations salariales elles ont des
idées également qui peuvent être prises
en compte ces organisations salariales
ce qui nous permettra de d'améliorer
quand même ce dispositif qui soit plus
accepté sur le plan social parce que
c'est quand même effectivement un
dispositif qui demande un effort
particulier aux salariés comme un donc
il faut bien que aussi une contrepartie
me semble-t-il patronale et j'en arrête
là
alors je vais peut-être me concentrer
sur les sujets de la retraite puis je te
passe la parole après
Eric
je pense que d'abord sur les sujets
d'exonération elles ont chacune leur
raison d'être donc il faut celles qui
existent il faut les regarder dans le
contexte où elles sont positionnées sur
l'emploi des seniors
nous avons fait des propositions parce
que finalement le sujet il faut qu'il
soit l'objet d'un dialogue d'un dialogue
entre le salarié et l'employeur et d'un
dialogue social et nous avons fait des
propositions autour par exemple de la
réalisation d'un bilan de compétences
obligatoires à un âge donné c'est ce que
je disais dans mon propos liminaire que
il y ait certains entretiens
professionnels qui existent aujourd'hui
le dispositif existe tous les deux ans
et que certains soient utilisés
spécifiquement avec un questionnement
spécifique pour que ce dialogue entre
employeurs et salarié existe autour de
sa deuxième partie de carrière et de son
employabilité par rapport à ses propres
compétences au sein de l'entreprise et
je pense que ces questionnements là
aujourd'hui il n'existe pas et si vous
mettez ces questionnements-là au sein de
l'entreprise en tout cas ils existent
peu et bien ça sera un dialogue qui
entraînera la formation et les efforts
de formation de l'entreprise pour
maintenir l'employabilité ces efforts de
formation d'entreprise pourront être
regardés notamment au sein d'un label ou
au sein d'un index ce sont des
propositions que que nous avons faites
et qui nous paraissent importante comme
des priorités données à des salariés sur
de la reconversion professionnelle Eric
je crois que tu voulais compléter mais
peut-être compléter sur la question
effectivement du label moi je suis pas
du tout opposé bien au contraire et je
pense que notre organisation pourra
évidemment travailler sur ces sujets là
je pense que c'est des sujets
effectivement de dernières sociaux que
et il faudrait et que de toute façon on
pourra travailler notamment travailler
dans le cadre soit de l'assurance
chômage soit à côté de l'assurance
chômage puisque c'est des sujets le
sujet de la bête c'est un peu un peu
annel annexe en revanche et dans les
branches par contre ça peut être une
négociation de branche sur lequel on a
on a ce travail effectivement
intéressant sur ce sujet là la question
des exonérations que vous posez monsieur
le sénateur elle est intéressante mais
elle ne peut pas ne pas faire
abstraction de la situation globale de
du système de prélèvement obligatoire en
France et du poids du du prélèvement sur
le travail et notamment sur les
cotisations employeurs et employées
aujourd'hui en France regardez quand on
a un dispositif qui font qu'il y ait
prévu globalement avec une exonération
fiscale une prime une prime à l'embauche
et c'est vrai vous avez raison de sur le
sénateur une modification des conditions
d'exploitation
sur l'apprentissage d'un seul coup vous
avez un boom vous avez et donc là il y a
bien des exonérations sur
l'apprentissage il y a bien des tripes
sur l'apprentissage la contrepartie
aujourd'hui c'est presque un million
d'apprentis donc c'est possible il faut
avoir une vue une dispositif global qui
associe un certain nombre de choses et
ce que je vois moi surtout c'est que on
a un coup du travail en France sur
lequel malheureusement on est quand même
pas les mieux placés donc les
exonérations vous les supprimer je sais
pas enfin on est je vais pas prononcer
des mots parce que mais il est trop tard
mais mais en fait vous aujourd'hui vous
supprimez les exonérations qui existent
sur tout un tas de champs et bien vous
retrouvez dans une situation de coût du
marché du travail complètement explosif
complètement explosif donc c'est
peut-être dommageable pour la lisibilité
du dispositif ça j'en conviens mais il
faut reconnaître que la résultat
aujourd'hui c'est que on prélève déjà
énormément
sur les entreprises sur le travail donc
peut-être qu'il faut faire peut-être des
propositions effectivement autrement je
voudrais quoi terminer
vous pouvez constater que nos bons se
sont quand même largement dégarnés je
vous laisse quelques instants pour pour
conclure et je vous invite à adresser
par écrit les réponses complémentaires
merci c'est gentil je voulais juste te
dire parce qu'il y avait une sénatrice
qui est intervenue sur la question de la
capitalisation c'est pas vous c'est une
collègue et je vous dire que nous il
nous semble absolument indispensables
mais je pense qu'on pourra le confirmer
avec l'étude du corps qui sortira en
juin du moins j'espère que ce sera
visible il nous semble absolument
indispensables pour protéger nos
générations futures de mettre un système
complémentaire de capitalisation
collective au dessus du dispositif par
répartition
qui est prévu donc nous porterons nous
CPME obligatoire gérés par les
partenaires sociaux collectifs et nous
porterons cette proposition je sais pas
si mes collègues le font mais la CPME le
fera au sein des négociations qui
s'engageront notamment à la jrco
puisqu'on est aussi là en révision de
convention
oui très bien vas-y peut-être juste en
conclusion en deux mots je pense que il
faut absolument garder en tête
l'équilibre financier de cette réforme
il y a des mesures d'équité de
solidarité intergénérationnelle il y a
sûrement des sujets de coups de l'emploi
on comprend bien les mesures
d'accompagnement qui sont nécessaires
mais gardons vraiment une réforme qui
trouve son équilibre au terme de tout ce
parcours parlementaire merci beaucoup en
tout cas de votre attention merci merci
à vous deux pour vous contribution
n'hésitez pas à nous adresser par écrit
les réponses ou les commentaires
à suivre merci beaucoup bonne journée
merci